Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Bist du aufgeregt? Dein Kanzler ist in Washington, DC.
Ja, ich hoffe, wir bekommen wieder great television zu sehen.
Ich glaube, sie werden sich Mühe geben.
Vermutlich, ja. Ich könnte es mir auch vorstellen. Wir werden, wenn es besonders interessant wird, es natürlich am Ende des Monats.
Dann kommt heute Abend noch das Update zum Besuch.
Ja.
Wir beginnen jetzt.
Genau. So schlimm wird es wahrscheinlich nicht werden oder so interessant wird es auch nicht. Mal schauen. Man weiß ja nie, was der Monat uns noch bringt. Aber wir haben es ja da mit einem Präsidenten zu tun, der offenbar noch sehr fit ist. Bei Joe Biden sah das anders aus. Wir haben ja jetzt eine große Debatte um Joe Biden deshalb, weil es ein Buch gibt von Jake Tapper, der ist von CNN, der ein Buch geschrieben hat über diese Ursünde, wie er es nennt, dass man bei den Demokraten und auch in den Medien, solange die Augen verschlossen hat, davor, wie der Gesundheitszustand von Joe Biden eigentlich ist. Als dieses Buch dann veröffentlicht wurde vor einigen Tagen, hat gleichzeitig die beiden Familie bekannt gegeben, dass Joe Biden an Krebs erkrankt ist. Man hat also damit auch natürlich diesem Buch ein bisschen Wind aus den Segeln genommen und gesagt, hier spielt die Musik, das ist unser Thema jetzt hier. Nun gibt es natürlich viel Kritik auch an Jake Tapper. Zum einen, weil er als Journalist die ganze Zeit mitgearbeitet hat an dieser Ursünde und immer so getan hat, als sei mit Joe Biden alles super. Und er gehört mit CNN und mit den anderen daran andockenden Mainstream-Medien, natürlich zu denen, die immer gesagt haben, das sind Verschwörungstheorien der Republikaner.
Er hat halt ein besonders schlechtes Gewissen jetzt.
Genau, schreibt also deshalb dieses Buch. Und sogleich wird ihm ja dann vorgeworfen auch von John Stewart zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt Journalist ist und News hat, dann muss man die News veröffentlichen und kann ich sagen, liebe Leute, es gibt wirklich ganz interessante News, aber da schreibe ich jetzt erstmal ein Buch und das erzähle ich euch in einem halben Jahr. Aber ihr könnt schon mal das Buch vorbestellen. Und das ist ja genau das, was jetzt gerade passiert ist. So ist also Jake Tapper nun sicherlich keine Figur, die mir besonders sympathisch ist, aber doch macht es ja etwas offenbar, was interessant ist. Nämlich, dass wir jetzt, nachdem Biden nicht mehr im Amt ist und so weiter, wir eine Situation haben, in der sich wieder alle einig sind darüber, wie das also mit Biden war. Und man fragt sich ja immer, wie kann es eigentlich sein, dass es dann immer so einen Anstoß braucht, der dann alles, also der das, was schon lange sichtbar war, plötzlich dann auch offensichtlich macht. Denn es ist ja jetzt nicht so, wie Elmar Thewesen oder andere immer suggerierten. Nee, nee, also bis vor fünf Monaten war Biden wirklich topfit. Aber dann kam dieses Duell und da hat man gemerkt, jetzt ist es vorbei mit ihm. Da hatte er nicht nur einen schlechten Tassel, sondern ging es dann wirklich bergab. Und da war auch schon die Wochen davor, das ist merkwürdig, sondern dass Joe Biden jetzt nicht der Fitteste ist, kognitiv mehr, das war ja schon häufig zu sehen. Aber irgendwie braucht es dann immer was. Vielleicht hören wir mal da rein in so ein Interview mit Jake Tapper, wie er das jetzt schildert. Und zwar geht es um eine Begegnung zwischen Joe Biden und George Clooney. Und wir alle wissen, wie George Clooney aussieht, nämlich wie George Clooney.
George Clooney hatte Joe Biden kennengelernt. Er hat ihn nach 9-11 getroffen und er hat ihn zumindest seit der Vizepräsidentenheit von Biden kennengelernt. Und so hatten sie eine Begegnung. Und dann, als Biden für einen Präsidenten rannte, hat Clooney ihm Geld geholfen. Sie hatten eine Begegnung. Sie wussten sich. Bei der Fundraiser geht Joe Biden rein, und George Clooney kann nicht glauben, wie alt er sich sieht und wie alt er sich sieht. Er hat ihn im Dezember 2022 gesehen, und wie wir in dem Buch schreiben, gibt es einen seriösen Verlust im Jahr 2023. So Biden geht rein, und er hat eine Begegnung, und er geht herum und sagt, hey, wie geht's? Danke, dass du hier bist. Eine Begegnung bringt ihn zu Clooney und sagt, du weißt George. Und Biden sagt, ja, hey. Und es fängt an, Clooney und ein anderer Begegnung zu erkennen. Joe Biden erkennt George Clooney nicht. Und das ist nicht George Clooney, mit schwarzen Haaren, die für den Spiel auf Broadway gespielt haben. Das ist nicht George Clooney mit einem Haar. Das ist George Clooney, wie er in den letzten 30 Jahren ist. Einer der weltweit bekanntsten Gesichter und jemanden, den er seit mehr als ein Jahr kennt. Und dann sagt die Aide, George Clooney. Und Biden sagt, oh ja, oh ja. Und das schreckt Clooney zu seinem Korps. Aber außerdem, Bidens Performance im Hintergrund.
War, dass Joe Biden wie eingefroren dasteht und Barack Obama neben ihm steht, dann ihn so beim Arm nimmt und mitnimmt von der Bühne. Und das war dann ein besonders drastischer Ausfall. Und dadurch, dass George Clooney anwesend war und George Clooney sich ja dann später dazu äußerte, dazu kommen wir noch, ist das dann so publik geworden. Und war das dann sicherlich ein Schritt, der dazu geführt hat, dass Joe Biden nicht noch einmal antritt. Aber man fragt sich natürlich schon, diese Journalisten haben ja Joe Biden so häufig erlebt. Die Leute in seinem Umfeld haben ihn erlebt. Was passierte eigentlich mit der Macht, wenn das noch weiter gedeckt wird? Und was bedeutet das eigentlich, wenn wir die ganze Zeit von Vertrauensverlusten und so weiter reden, wenn sowas passiert? Also ich meine, es ist doch schon eine sehr eigenartige Zeit, dass wir diese ganzen wunderbaren Podiumsdiskussionen haben, wie gewinnen wir die Leute für die Demokratie zurück? Wie schaffen wir Vertrauen und all das? Und dass aber in diesen Diskussionen ja fast nie vorkommt, zum Beispiel sowas wie Joe Biden. Also was ist denn da eigentlich passiert für eine große Lüge? Anders kann man es ja nicht bezeichnen. Wir konnten jetzt durch die ganzen Sachen durchgehen. Der Impfstoff schützt nicht nur mich, sondern auch andere. Der Letzteres stimmte nicht und das hätte man auch früher sagen können. Man hat Ursula von der Leyen, die immer irgendwelche SMS dummerweise verschusselt. Wir haben einen Cum-Ex-Kanzler gehabt. Also ich meine, das sind ja schon alles Dinge. Die Russen haben Nord Stream 2 Pipeline gesprengt. Nee, waren sie dann doch nicht. Auf keinen Fall kann das Virus aus dem Labor sein. Ja, vielleicht, aber jetzt doch. Es gibt zumindest Erkenntnisse. Da kann man ja nicht sagen, dass die Öffentlichkeit einfach misstraut, sondern man muss ja eher sagen, man misstraut zu Recht.
Also es gibt einen längerfristigen Diskurs, ich sag mal so vor zehn Jahren ungefähr, ob man Nachrichten so aufbereiten müsste wie Wikipedia. Also irgendetwas passiert, gerade in Todesfällen. Und dann steht ja relativ zügig das Todesdatum in der Wikipedia. Also sobald es publik ist. Und bei der Frage, wer war diese Person, bleibt man dann einfach bei Wikipedia und liest diesen Artikel. Und es ist mir vorhin wieder aufgefallen, denn als ich auf dich gewartet habe, habe ich so geguckt, was schreibt Spiegel gerade zu aktuellen Geschehen. Und jetzt mal ein Beispiel aus dem Spiegel. Passend, ich lass mal das Thema und die Überschrift weg, der Text. Passend zum Antrittsbesuch von Bundeskanzler Friedrich Merz in Washington zeichnet sich eine wichtige diplomatische Personalie ab. Nach Spiegelinformationen soll der Diplomat Jens Hannefeld, deutscher Botschafter in den USA, werden. Hannefeld ist derzeit als Botschafter in Äthiopien eingesetzt. Über die Frage, wen Bundeskanzler Merz und sein Außenminister Johannes Wadepuhl nach Washington entsanden, war zuletzt viel spekuliert worden. Der bisherige Botschafter, blablabla, geht jetzt in Ruhe. So, ich wollte diesen Text nicht lesen, um zu erfahren, dass Wadepuhl und Merz eine Diskussion über irgendwas führen. Ich weiß auch, dass Merz in Washington ist. Das sind alles Infos, die brauche ich einfach gar nicht. Ich wollte einfach nur wissen, wenn eine Überschrift lautet, Jens Hannefeld sei deutscher Botschafter in Washington werden, wer ist dieser Mann? Ja. Also ist es mittlerweile so weit, dass ich auf einem Spiegeltext bin und dann lieber zu GPT rüber gehe und einfach frage, wer ist denn dieser Typ? Und dann sagt mir GPT einfach, Jens Hannefeld ist ein deutscher Diplomat, geboren 1964 in Köln, seit September 2024 Botschafter in Äthiopien, so gleichständiger Beobachter über die Afrikanische Union. Für die Afrikanische Union. So, nächster Satz. Hannefeld studierte neuere Geschichte und Anglistik und so weiter und so fort. Das werde ich einfach informiert. Ja. Also dieser Journalismus ist in allen Ebenen einfach intellektuell bankrott. Und es ist bei diesem Buch von Jake Tapper, John Stewart hat es ja ganz wunderbar. Hast du Clips von John Stewart? Nein. Also John Stewart hat ja wirklich, da kommt ja dieser ganze Doppel- oder Dreiklang. Leute machen News. Und dann denken sie, nee, die sind so gut, ich mache ein Buch draus. Aber ein Buch dauert Zeit. Und eigentlich, oder stellt man ja Journalisten schon immer, sie wechseln sich so als Teil des politischen Systems. Sie wollen Einfluss nehmen. Also kommen sie schnell mit News, um noch Einfluss auf die Wahlen zu nehmen. Nur die Wahlen sind ja gelaufen. Und dann kommt ein Jahr später ein Buch, das uns etwas exklusiv verraten möchte. Und so wurde es ja ganz aggressiv bei CNN promoted, mit einer Nachricht, die schon vor einem Jahr eigentlich gar keine Nachricht hätte mehr sein dürfen, weil die journalistische Pflicht ist, uns darüber zu informieren, dass das der Sachstand ist und dass das hier keine Neuigkeit ist. Ja. Also dieses Buch, ich werde nachher noch was Konstruktives dazu sagen, aber dieses Buch von der Anlage, von der Art, wie es in die Welt kam und wie es promotet würde, ist wirklich eine Bankrotterklärung dieser Art Journalismus. Und bei allen, du hast es angesprochen, Podiumsdiskussionen und hier Ertüchtigung der Menschen, Bewusstwerdung, Sensibilisierung für Demokratie. Die Menschen haben das nicht nötig. Die Journalisten haben das nötig. Es ist wirklich ganz schlimm. Und diese Begleitung von Trump jetzt in Amerika, dass wir morgens Podcasts haben, von denen wir genau wissen, wenn wir heute fertig sind mit dem Podcast, und ich fange 18 Uhr oder so an, diese zu hören, es sind die alle Nonsens. Weil bis dann ist das gelaufen. Es wird ganz anders gewesen sein als alle dachten vorher. Alle Szenarien sind total Nonsens. Und es ist stundenlange Podcastproduktion, die für die Tonne ist.
Man könnte es ja eigentlich auch sehr gut parodieren. Also es geht ja bei solchen Podcasts. Es geht ja dann bei solchen Treffen, darf ja eh dann der Journalist nicht mehr irgendwelche Namen konkret nennen, sondern wir haben über Kreise gehört. Man weiß auch gar nicht mehr, wie entfernt sind eigentlich die Kreise derjenigen, die jetzt wirklich in Washington mit Friedrich Merz sind. Und dann heißt es dann so, ja, es gab vorher auch Absprachen, man will ihn nicht provozieren, man will nicht dies machen, man will nicht das machen. Also im Prinzip könnten wir jetzt Karl zum Podcast aufnehmen, einfach sagen, ja Kreise haben uns gesagt, es gibt die Strategie, versuchen mit ihm einen guten Deal auszuhandeln. Aber manches ist noch so und so und so. Wir wissen es noch nicht genau, aber wir können schon mal Mutmaßen. Völliger Nonsens.
Deutsche Journalisten, die jetzt dabei sind, sitzen bei einem Fußballspiel im allerletzten Rang, in der allerletzten Ecke, hinten irgendwo haben keinen Fernglas, haben keine Wiederholung, haben keine Zeitlupe, gar nichts. Die können uns nichts erzählen darüber. Die können nur sagen, wir sind dabei gewesen. Und dann gibt es Fotos von, guck mal, wie wir alle flach auf dem Boden liegen, weil gerade Raketenangriff war. Wir sind ja hier in der Gefahrenzone und so was. Und darüber wird so eine Tension aufgebaut. Und der Rest ist... Also ich bin, ich sehe ja schon wieder so ein dickes Buch. Ich weiß gar nicht, was das ist, aber...
Das ist eine Biografie über Thomas Mann.
Ah ja, also diese Aufarbeitung über Rom, die einfach mit 2.000, 3.000 Jahren Abstand geschrieben werden, treffen den Ton. Und da steht alles aktuelle drin, was wir wissen müssen. Wir müssen nicht über März informiert werden. Wir kennen März und zwar aus Jahrhunderten, Jahrtausenden Menschheitsgeschichte. Wir wollen jetzt wissen, was hier passiert.
Aber lass uns doch mal einen Moment über diesen Vertrauensverlust, wie das immer so gern genannt wird, reden. Findest du es nicht erstaunlich, dass der Journalismus, also ich habe ja irgendwann schon mal gesagt, beim Journalismus ist es so, wie bei täglich grüßt das Murmeltier. Immer Tag eins. Es gibt es kein gestern.
Genau.
Und das ist ja wieder hier zu beobachten, dass plötzlich alle sich einig sind. Ja, stimmt, das war aber wirklich unglaublich, dass man nicht die Öffentlichkeit aufgeklärt hat darüber, wie es Joe Biden geht. Und deswegen sitzt man dann ein Jahr später da und liest noch mal ein Buch dazu. Zu etwas, was man schon ein paar Jahre vorher hätte aufschreiben müssen als Journalist. Und jetzt sind wir wieder in einer Situation, wo neue Dinge kommen, bezüglich Krieg, Verhandlungen, was auch immer, Nahost. Und dann sagt man immer später, ja genau, das war ja klar. Also ich könnte Artikel hier vorzeigen, ich glaube zum Beispiel aus der Augsburger Allgemeinen, nach dem 7. Oktober, wo man sagte, jetzt man nicht zu sehr die Bilder von den Kindern aus Gaza in die Köpfe bringen lassen. Aussagen von Politikern, Michael Roth und dergleichen, jetzt nicht sich hier durch Mitleid irgendwie in eine falsche Richtung bewegen lassen.
Nicht auf die Schleimspur der Hamas-Propaganda.
Also gar nicht darauf reinfallen. Plötzlich schreiben dann zum Teil dieselben Journalisten, gut Michael Roth ist unverbesserlich, aber die anderen, die Journalisten schreiben dann, so kann es nicht weitergehen. Man darf nicht wegschauen. Und ich denke, ja, aber ihr habt doch noch vor einigen Monaten geschrieben, wir sollen jetzt erstmal wegschauen. Und dass das dann sich aber immer direkt so anpasst wieder. Und plötzlich so ein neuer Mainstream entstanden ist. Also heute wäre ich ja jetzt total anti Mainstream, wenn ich sagen würde, also Joe Biden ist topfit, der sollte nochmal versuchen anzutreten beim nächsten Mal. Dann würde man sagen, jetzt bin ich verrückt geworden. Es ist wirklich erstaunlich, wie so eine Hegemonie sich so schnell immer bilden kann. Und es funktioniert nur, wenn man wirklich sagt, was schert mich mein Geschwätz von gestern. Heute ist wieder Tag eins, heute machen wir wieder weiter. Und das ist ja auch der Versuch von Jack Tapper dann. Insofern ist es ja erstaunlich, dass ein George Clooney, der das nicht hätte machen müssen, sich dann damals publizistisch geäußert hat und gesagt, das ist der falsche Mann, der Biden darf nicht noch mal antreten. Ich habe den erlebt. Und der wird jetzt auch von Jack Tapper noch mal interviewt, also aktuell.
Du hast etwas getan, was viele Leute als brav nennen würden, als du dein App-Ed geschrieben hattest.
Na, ich weiß nicht, ob es brav war. Es war eine zivilistische Pflicht, weil ich fand, dass die Leute auf meiner Seite der Straße, ich bin ein Demokrat, ich bin ein Demokrat in Kentucky, also, ich verstehe es. Als ich die Leute auf meiner Seite der Straße sah, nicht die Wahrheit zu sagen, dachte ich, das wäre der Zeitpunkt. Einige Leute, klar. Das ist okay. Du weißt, hör mal, die Idee der Freiheit der Rede, die spezielle Idee ist, du kannst keine Freiheit der Rede beherrschen und sagen, aber sag nicht schlechte Dinge über mich. Das ist das Problem. Du musst einen Stand nehmen, wenn du in den Fall bist. Nimm einen Stand, stand für ihn, und dann deal mit den Konsequenzen. Das sind die Regeln.
Wir haben jetzt George Clooney hier gesehen. In einem Theater, er spielt ja gerade Musical mit den dunklen Haaren.
Ja.
Man wünscht es ja sofort eine...
Oder es ist ein Musical, also ich glaube, es ist die...
Theater oder Musik, was ist denn das?
Na es ist A Good Night. Ein V-Spiel. Good Luck, also der Film als Theaterstück so scheint mir.
Theater, ja gut. Egal ob gesungen hat oder nicht. Man sieht ihn so und denkt sich, warum nicht? Er macht das jetzt, also so wie man ihn da sieht, will man ihn als Präsidenten sehen.
Ach so.
Und da ein Präsident ja einfach nur Aushängeschild eines politischen Apparats ist, der sich dahinter versteckt und wir gesehen haben, wie gut man sich in diesem politischen Apparat verstecken kann, könnte man ja dieses Prinzip umdrehen und sagen, anstatt dass der Apparat den Präsidenten versteckt, versteckt der Präsident jetzt mal den Apparat. Denn das, was wir bei Joe Biden gesehen haben, ist absurd. Das, was wir bei dieser Fernsehshow sehen, dass einfach was auch immer, gar nichts mehr versteckt wird, sondern nur gefragt wird, wo kommt das blaue Auge her? Ich habe meinem kleinen Sohn gesagt, er soll mich schlagen. Dabei war das wahrscheinlich der Finanzminister, mit dem er sich geprügelt hat. Solche Sachen. Dann doch lieber so. Also man kriegt sofort so eine Verlockung, wenn man ihn hier so sieht.
Du gehst ja auch nicht davon aus, dass die Demokraten jetzt daraus lernen werden aus dem Buch, in dem sie jetzt sagen werden, passt auf. Ab sofort machen wir das wirklich demokratisch. Wir wählen wirklich, wer der nächste Präsidentschaftskandidat werden soll. Sondern wir werden immer weiter machen mit diesen Machenschaften, damit ja nicht mal jemand wie ein Bernie Sanders oder so da rauskommt. Am Ende bei einer demokratischen Wahl machen wir lieber unsere Ränkel, Spiele weiter im Hintergrund irgendetwas und dann kann man nur hoffen, dass es demnächst nicht wieder jemand ist, der nicht mehr so ganz geistig da ist.
Die Demokraten waren damals überrascht davon, dass Obama in Iowa diese ersten wirklich aufs Publikum treffenden Wahlen gewonnen hat und sie konnten nichts gegen ihn tun. Dann haben sie später gemerkt, nein, wenn uns das nicht nochmal passieren darf, dass wir überrannt werden, überrascht werden als Partei, müssen wir Vorkehrungen treffen. Also haben sie diese Superdelegates und so weiter, die Clinton hofiert haben und Bernie Sanders verhindert haben. Bei Joe Biden ähnliche Prinzipien. Man hat gesagt, naja, die ersten Vorwarnungen sind gar nicht so wichtig, als ist South Carolina. So, dass da aber so eine Black Community wirklich aufgestachelt wurde, zu sagen, wir gehen jetzt auf Nummer sicher. Wir wählen den Alten, der schon jahrzehntelang für uns was getan hat, während die anderen Jungen auf der Bühne da gar nicht konkurrieren konnten und eigentlich für alle Welt klar war, das ist ein Sonderfall. South Carolina ist nicht Amerika, sondern ergreifen wie in jedem Staat eigene Prinzipien und die wurden gezielt angesteuert, gehypt, ausgebeutet. Und plötzlich war er der Kandidat. Das sind ja auch wieder solche Prinzipien. Die Republikaner waren ja, ich habe das immer noch im Ohr, wie Reince Priebus da sitzt und sagt, während sich Obama auf der Bühne macht sich Obama lustig über die Republikaner, weil nachdem 17 Republikaner auf der Bühne stehen und es sind nur noch 11 und Trump steht immer als Leader der Vorwahlen schon in der Mitte und so läuft eigentlich darauf hinaus. Alle machen sich drüber lustig. Reince Priebus damals, die haben ja nicht richtig einen Parteichef, aber so ein Organisations-CEO für die Republikanische Partei, sitzt so zurückgelehnt mit Füßen auf den Tisch da und sagt, wir lassen einfach die Leute wählen und danach arbeiten wir mit dem, was ist. Er hat natürlich schon seinen Fingern in den Wind gestellt, so dass er schon von Trump vor den finalen Entscheidungen namentlich immer erwähnt wurde und dann auch sein erster Stabschef wurde, der zumindest ein halbes Jahr dadurch gehalten hat. Die haben halt einfach den Prozess laufen lassen und wir wissen ja, zu was es geführt hat. Die GOP gibt es nicht mehr, es ist auch nicht Tea Party, es ist MAGA. Es ist ein völlig eigenes Ding.
Da vor allem die Demokraten Angst.
Genau, aber das Einzige, was die Demokraten überhaupt als Partei retten kann, ist, dass sie sich öffnen für einen Prozess, der sie komplett umkrempeln könnte. AOC könnte da mit so einem Populismus reinlaufen und sagen, jetzt ist die Jugend dran, jetzt sind die Frauen dran, jetzt sind wieder die Urbanzentren dran. Und das würde ja, wenn man es durchrechnet, mathematisch reichen. Man muss halt nur die ganze Kampagne geschlossen darum bauen. Man darf dann nicht wieder so, ah nee, und hier und überhaupt, die müssen wir erstmal ein bisschen einhegen. Und später muss der Apparat aber auch noch zur Geltung kommen. Ich glaube, der große Wettstreit zwischen Republikanern und Demokraten, der ist vorbei. Also da suchen nur noch Journalisten nach, aber das ist so vorbei. Es ist jetzt mager gegen, und dann ist die Frage ein großes Fragezeichen. Was kommt bei RUM? Wie gesagt, ich könnte mir George Clooney da vorstellen.
Ja, hoffentlich ist er klug genug, das nicht zu tun.
Aber das Präsidentenamt wurde jetzt so definiert, dass es folgerichtig ist, dort ein Schauspieler, der gemocht wird.
Da haben wir schon mal hier meinen Vorschlag für die Linkspartei damals.
Genau, den da hinzusetzen.
Als die groß auf der Kandidatensuche war, habe ich hier gesessen und gesagt, am besten wäre, man würde einen guten Theater-Schauspieler nehmen, den bezahlen und sagen, du bist jetzt der Vorsitzende der Linkspartei. Also das war, bevor diese neue Riege jetzt aufgetaucht ist. Und sagen, hier sind 7.000 Euro im Monat, du spielst jetzt den Vorsitzenden, hier sind die Talking Points, aber verkörpere es vor allem. Verkörpere den Politiker.
Zeig uns, was wir sehen wollen, mach die Ansprachen richtig. Und dafür braucht man, das ist eine eigene professionelle Erfordernis und Klasse. Und gerade in Amerika gibt es ja Menschen, die das können. Man muss ja nicht immer hoffen, dass die dann auch noch Politiker sind. Das wäre so bei Gavin Newsome oder so. Er funktioniert vor der Kamera, aber eben auch als Politiker. Aber ich finde, man könnte dieses präsidiale Amt, das ein politisches ist, von Politik befreien. Wir haben den englischen König davon befreit. Wir haben den heiligen Stuhl davon befreit. Wir können auch den amerikanischen Präsidenten davon befreien.
Wir sehen zumindest, es macht keinen großen Unterschied, wenn der Präsident gar nicht mehr richtig einsatzfähig ist, sondern nur noch ein paar Stunden am Tag überhaupt ansprechbar ist.
Wir haben doch gesehen, wie weit ein Apparat es treiben kann und sogar das Land so regieren, dass man heute sagt, Joe Biden halbtot, Joe Biden Regierung, best ever, hätte Amerika nicht besser passieren können. Die Differenz ist doch voll etabliert.
Ja, es ist ja auch interessant, dass wenn dieses desaströse Duell nicht gekommen wäre und Biden hätte sich noch ein bisschen irgendwie zusammengerissen oder man hätte die Auftritte noch mehr reduziert, hätte ihn noch mehr versteckt vor der Öffentlichkeit, was man ja wohl auch getan hat, dann hätte es ja durchaus sein können, dass er noch mal Präsident geworden wäre. Also es ist ja nicht ausgeschlossen.
Man hätte ihn nie wieder gesungen.
Also er wäre nicht unerfolgreicher gewesen als Kamala Harris, glaube ich. So und das sagt doch vieles aus. Wir hätten ihn vermutlich danach nur noch zur Inauguration gesehen und das wäre es dann noch mal hin und wieder eine Großbotschaft zu Weihnachten und andere hätten regiert.
Ja und wenn man das Amt auf der Schauseite mit nichts ausfüllen kann, stell dir mal vor, was ist, wenn man das mit was ausfüllt?
Jaja, gut, wir wollen ja jetzt nicht die Demokraten beraten, sondern noch einmal über diese Frage des Vertrauens sprechen, beziehungsweise wie geht man eigentlich mit Politikern um. Im Grunde, wir haben es ja in Deutschland gut. Hier wird ja der Parteivorsitzende der SPD ganz demokratisch bestimmt. Er ist der Talentierteste, der Eloquenteste. Er ist der, der erfolgreichen Wahlkampf für Olaf Scholz gemacht hat. Zumindest mal irgendwann. Und es ist doch klar, dass das der große Vorsitzende werden muss.
Es ist alles folgerichtig, super leicht erklärbar. Da ist gar kein Mysterium noch, das offen ist oder so.
Also Lars Klingweil, so ein Star. Da ist doch klar, dass da niemand dran vorbei kommt. Wir hören noch einmal Jake Tapper.
Aber lass mich noch eine Parade machen, sie liegt mir auf dem Herzen. Aber wir haben jetzt diesen Kontrast gerade aufgemacht. Amerika, Deutschland. Und wir haben eigentlich jetzt gerade gesagt, alles, was ich gerade über Joe Biden, Hillary Clinton, Obama gesagt habe, ein Apparat, der sich und so weiter, das gilt ja eben auch für die SPD. Nur, dass wir ein System haben, das auf dem Blatt Papier anders aufgestellt ist, sodass unsere Verwaltung und unsere Abläufe uns davor schützen, dass diese Egozentrik, die da drin steckt, bei Merz und Klingball, gebremst wird. Aber eigentlich, wenn wir ganz ehrlich sind und so meditativ und nicht über Spiegel Online uns mit den Sachen befassen, ist doch völlig klar, Friedrich Merz ist ein gebändigter Donald Trump. Der ist einfach nur contained. Aber in der Anlage würde der als amerikanische Präsident doch genauso funktionieren, wenn er mit Talenten, die er selber nicht unter Kontrolle hat, sondern die einfach Gott gegeben sind oder nicht, auf der Bühne so funktionieren würde. In einem amerikanischen System würde Merz doch genauso funktionieren.
Wir sehen es doch jetzt sehr gut an den Äußerungen, nicht nur von Friedrich Merz, sondern von Dobrindt und anderen, in Bezug auf die Zurückweisung von Asylsuchenden an der Grenze. Die Gerichte sagen nein. Die CDU, CSU sagt, wo kommen wir denn jetzt dahin? Wir machen doch jetzt hier unsere Sache. Das ist genau das. Und ja, das ist besser eingehegt noch. Noch, muss man dazu sagen. Aber ja, die Anlage ist vollkommen da. Deshalb, glaube ich, ist es jetzt auch nochmal wichtig, wenigstens eine Lehre aus diesem Jake Tapper-Buch zu ziehen. Und Jake Tapper zieht sie selbst. Und wir müssen das klar machen. Jake Tapper ist für CNN so wie früher Klaus Kleber für ZDF die Galleonsfigur schlechthin. Und die sagt jetzt Folgendes.
Und ich denke, dass wir skeptisch sein müssen, dass alles, was wir von den Menschen in der Macht sagen, und das sollte natürlich das Mantra sein, als Journalist zu beginnen. Wenn deine Mutter dir sagt, dass sie dich liebt, bekommst du eine zweite Source. Aber wir müssen das nur erinnern. Politiker leiden, White-Houses leiden, der Macht ist ein Aphrodisiak. Und wir müssen das alle erinnern und nicht alles, was wir gesagt haben, als Face-Value zu nehmen.
Ja, das ist das Interessante. Er braucht dafür jetzt drei Jahrzehnte, um das formulieren zu können. Hätte man ein bisschen früher mit einsteigen können. Aber ja, das ist der Punkt. Und nicht einfach, weil die nur Lügner sind, sondern weil die Macht zum eines da zu führt. Und aber auch, und da sind wir wieder bei Rutger Breichmann, weil natürlich dort Persönlichkeiten sind, die bereit sind, genau nicht irgendetwas Persönliches hinanzustellen, um das Volk, den Staat oder was weiß ich, zu schützen. Sondern sie sind dann sogar bereit zu sagen, ich werde halt nur noch hinten und vorne mit Klammern zusammengehalten, ich kann aber trotzdem nochmal Präsident werden. Wir hatten das ja auch bei den Richtern. Keiner dieser Richter ist zurückgetreten und gesagt, ich mache jetzt, während Biden regiert oder Obama regiert den Weg frei, für eine weitere progressive Richterin oder so, sondern man bleibt bis zum allerletzten Tag im Amt, weiß, dann wird man wahrscheinlich unter der Amtszeit von Donald Trump sterben und dann hat Donald Trump die Möglichkeit, seine Richter zu besetzen. Und diese Leute kleben an der Macht, egal was passiert und sind völlig uneinsichtig.
Genau. Und um das zu plausibilisieren, werde ich jetzt mal eine Zahlen-Ziffern-Poarte nennen aus einer Lektüre, die ich heute mitbringe. Apple in China, ein Buch von Dings McGee. Also man kann sie nicht glauben. Ich sage euch jetzt, ihr werdet sie nicht glauben, aber sie stimmt. Ich habe es jetzt wirklich tausendmal nachgerechnet. Es ist unglaublich. Denn ja, wir können immer sagen, die Politiker lügen oder die sind Rutger Breschmann mäßig durchgeknallt, wie auch immer. Also sozusagen in diesem Kontrast aus System und Person. Immer auf die Person gehen und sagen, da liegt unser Interesse, da liegt unsere Sehgewohnheit. Wir gehen ins Theater, wir gehen in die Oper, wir gucken Fernsehen, wir sehen Personen und wir blenden immer das System aus. Und ich habe jetzt schon häufiger so gesagt, grundsätzlich wird immer übersehen, wie groß so Systeme sind. Würde Friedrich Merz in einem 8-Stunden-Arbeitstag sagen, ich möchte jeden Deutschen für eine Minute sprechen, kennenlernen, kurz fragen, wie es ihm geht. Wie lange würde er brauchen? 700 Jahre. Das ist noch nicht die Pointe, sondern Deutschland ist viel größer als man glaubt. Und man bräuchte 700 Jahre, um jeden Deutschen kennenzulernen, was schon mal biologisch gar nicht geht. Da liegen Kräfte drinne. Masse ist Macht. So, mal ganz einfach. Ich kann dir die runtergebrochen. So, und jetzt zu dieser Zahl. Apple ist ein Unternehmen, das ein Wechselbad der Gefühle für seine Aktionäre durchgemacht hat. Steve Jobs gründet es mit Steve Wozniak. Die machen diesen Apple II, löten so die ersten Chips zusammen, verkaufen das, Verkaufserfolge. Sie brauchen so Leute, die das herstellen, wie auch immer. Dann wird Steve Jobs da irgendwie rausgekickt. Unternehmen taumelt so ein bisschen, kurz vorm Tod. Steve Jobs kommt zurück, Unternehmen geht es gut. Steve Jobs stirbt. Unternehmen so, hm, mal gucken, wie es da weitergeht ohne so ein Genius am Werk. Und er hat aber die Nachfolge geregelt mit Tim Cook. Tim Cook nimmt also 2011 die Steuer in die Hand von Apple. Apple hat einen spezifischen Börsenwert zu dieser Zeit. Elf Jahre später, 2022, durch Bericht Apple die Marke von drei Billionen Marktkapitalisierung. So, und das bedeutet, Zahlen runtergebrochen. Und das sind jetzt rohe Kräfte, die walten, die müssen contained werden. Politisch, wirtschaftlich, wie auch immer. Die Zahl lautet wie folgt. Jeden einzelnen Arbeitstag, den Tim Cook von 2011 bis 2022 bei Apple als CEO gearbeitet hat, jeden einzelnen Arbeitstag ist der Wert von Apple im Durchschnitt um 700 Millionen Dollar gewachsen. Steve Jobs, Tim Cook steht seit zehn Jahren jeden Morgen auf und lässt sich darüber informieren, heute ist mein Unternehmen wieder 700 Millionen Dollar Mehrwert als gestern. Das sind Zahlen, die können wir uns nicht vorstellen. Das sind rohe Kräfte, für die brauchen wir Containment. Wenn dann irgendein Politiker, eine Person so kommt und sagt, ich mach das mal über so einen Zoll, ich droh den jetzt 25 Prozent Zoll an.
Damit ihr immer nach Hause kommt mit der Produktion.
Da steht Tim Cook einfach da und sagt, eure Bedrohung, China, habe ich geschaffen. Das ist die These in diesem Buch. Das heutige China wurde von Apple geschaffen. Apple hat in China 28 Millionen Menschen ausgebildet, iPhones herzustellen. Das sind mehr Beschäftigte als ganz Kalifornien, als sechs größte Volksnationen der Welt hat. Also wir haben es hier mit Kräften zu tun, mit Größen, mit Dimensionen. 28 Millionen Menschen sind durch die Ausbildung.
Das finde ich eigentlich die noch verrückte Zahl.
Es ist grotesk. Alles, was wir jetzt sehen in der Politik, solche Geschichten wie, da war jemand im Weißen Haus, dann gab es da ein bisschen Stress und deswegen hat der Deutsche Bundestag eine Milliarde und so weiter. Das sind diese rohen Kräfte, die jetzt so walten insgesamt. Also wir brauchen hier ernsthafte Gedanken über Containment von rohen Kräften, die einfach walten. Dieses Buch bzw. die Sachlage hinter dem Buch, aber das Buch selbst bildet es einfach wunderbar ab. Man kommt aus dem Staunen nicht raus und man wird ganz demütig und man weiß, sorry, liebe Tagesschau, aber das kann nicht so kommuniziert werden, wie ihr das gerade macht. Eine Kurzmeldung über Zollandrohung, während Apple pro Jahr schon vor zehn Jahren 50 Milliarden Dollar pro Jahr investiert und Amerika in dieser 20-jährigen Geschichte einmal es hinbekommt, ein Chips Act zu machen, wo es heißt, once in a lifetime, wir investieren jetzt für vier Jahre lang zwölf Milliarden im Jahr.
Und sollte man nicht lieber noch mal einen Bericht machen über die Bezahlkarte für Arbeitslose, weil Gens Spahn das fordert?
Also heute geht es ins Eingemachte mit dem Geoeconomie-Buch schon und dann mit der Praxis, was wie Gie und so, dass man kommt aus dem Staunen nicht raus.
Wir gehen damit in den Salon. Wir haben hier die Geoeconomie in Praxis. Du stellst uns das vor mit Apple. Ich bin sehr gespannt darauf. Und wir sprechen aber zunächst gemeinsam über ein Buch, das, wenn man so möchte, die theoretische Grundlage legen will für das, was dann für Apple gilt und natürlich auch andere Konzerne. Denn wir haben gerade diese Debatte. Erleben wir die große Rückkehr der Geopolitik. Das heißt also nur noch Primat des Politischen und das Wirtschaftliche wird dem untergeordnet. Mitunter scheint es so. Aber der politische Ökonom Milan Babić sagt, das ist eigentlich nicht der richtige Begriff Geopolitik und auch eigentlich nicht die richtige Betrachtungsweise. Wir müssen über Geoeconomie sprechen. Anatomie der Neuen Weltordnung heißt der Untertitel seines Buchs, das bei Surkamp erschienen ist. Und darüber werden wir ausführlich reden, auch weil dieses Buch die neoliberale Globalisierung für beendet erklärt, aber damit nicht meint, dass die Globalisierung am Ende ist. Außerdem werde ich Musik vorstellen, Jazz gibt es zu hören. Dann eine Autorin Katharina Bendigsen schreibt über Mutterschaft, über das Muttersein, über das Leben mit Kindern. Und zwar in experimenteller Kurzprose, in Geschichten. Wirklich erstaunlich. Ich bin sehr begeistert davon. Dann werde ich ein Buch, das gerade heiß diskutiert wird, vorstellen. Und zwar hat Tilman Lahme eine große neue Thomas Mann Biografie veröffentlicht. Und diese wirft Fragen auf, wie konnte die Germanistik und wie konnten auch die Biografen zuvor so lange blind sein oder wollten blind sein? Und man fragt sich aber auch, ist also dieser intime Blick, der hier uns gewährt wird, wirklich der Blick, der jetzt bleiben sollte, wenn wir auf Thomas Mann blicken? Denn er hat sehr viel ausfindig gemacht, wie sehr die unterdrückte Homosexualität von Thomas Mann doch sein ganzes Leben prägte und wie sehr auch dies alles immer von der Forschung dann ja übergangen oder auch verschleiert worden ist. Es ist also ganz erstaunlich, was er da zutage fördert. Es ist ein sehr gut geschriebenes Buch, das auf jeden Fall, aber auch ein Buch, über das man sicherlich diskutieren kann. Dann gibt es einen Artikel aus der Zeit, nämlich hat dort eine Journalistin Andrea Jeska mit Ukrainern gesprochen, die nicht kämpfen wollen und die sich ein Ende dieses Krieges wünschen. Und wir blicken noch mit Le Monde Diplomatiek nach Rumänien. Was halten eigentlich die Rumänen von der EU?
Meinerseits gucken wir in ein Text, the State Department, die publizieren auf ZAPStack, machen also Newsletter. Und das ist trotzdem offizielle Kommunikation. Und wir gehen einmal durch, wie eine genealogische Kette vom Athen zu Rom, zum mittelalterlichen Christentum, zum Common Law, zur amerikanischen Gründung, zu Europas Zukunft kommt. Die also an JD Vans Rede da anschließt. Und wir machen uns danach auf die Suche nach Grundbegriffen, um dieses Phänomen, eine Geschichte neu zu vergegenwärtigen, um sie komplett zu missbrauchen für eigene gegenwärtige Argumentation. Mein Vorschlag wird dann der Synchretismus sein, die selektive Rekombination. Aber es gibt noch andere Vorschläge, kommen wir dann drauf. Wie gesagt, Apple in China. Also man kommt aus dem Staunen nicht raus. Axios hat einen interessanten Text gemacht mit Dario Amodai, also der CEO von Anthropic. Steve Bannon kennen wir und Mark Zuckerberg, die Zitate zum Thema, was ist, wenn es wirklich passiert und 50 Prozent der Entry-Level-Jobs einfach vom höheren Management aus Kostengründen abgeschafft werden. Wie sieht eigentlich Nachwuchs in der Hierarchien aus und so? Plus eine sehr große Studie, die von Spektrum der Wissenschaft in einen sehr kleinen Text umgemünzt wurde, in dem aber die zentralen Aussagen für uns erhalten bleiben. Warum sind Leute weltweit betrachtet, die ein bisschen im Abseits leben und von weniger als 1000 Dollar im Jahr eigentlich glücklicher als wir? Kann man sich schon mal die Frage stellen. Kann das sein? Glaubt man das erstens? Kann das sein? Ist es so. Das erste möchte ich sagen, es ist wahrscheinlich so. Die erhobenen Zahlen deuten es an, aber wie wir es glauben sollten, ist schwierig. Eine Anmerkung noch, ich habe Hinweise bekommen, nachdem wir so ausführlich über den, ich sage mal neuen Katholizismus gesprochen haben, weil du warst ja sehr skeptisch, nachdem ich sagte, ich brauche eigentlich diese Grundprinzipien des Katholizismus, um mich auch selber daran zu orientieren, aber ich will diesen Gott nicht. Und daraufhin schrieb mir Jonas, der auch schon zu ähnlichen Themen bei mir im Fernsehpodcast war, auch schon mal hier zu Gast war, also wir haben schon ein paar Mal miteinander gesprochen. Er war selbst fünf Jahre evangelischer Pfarrer und ist dann aber da wieder sich anders orientiert und erwies mich daraufhin auf das atheistische Christentum. Seine eigene Diplomarbeit, die er mir geschickt hat, hat den Titel Theologie ohne Gott. Es gibt eine Todgottesteologie, die durchaus mit einem war mal oder braucht man nicht Gottesbezug klarkommt. Er selber ist sehr skeptisch. Also Jonas sagt, die konventionellen Wurzeln wird man eigentlich nicht los, da ich aber nicht aus der gläubigen Richtung komme, sondern aus der heidischen. Finde ich das wahnsinnig interessant. Und es gibt wohl auch Kantz Religionsschriften, die sich auch sehr, kennen wir ja natürlich, aber eben auch mit einer neuen Fundierung von Ethik und Moral eben abseits von Gottes bezügen. Also darauf läuft ja vieles hinaus, was wir so populärwissenschaftlich kennen von ihm. ganzen Imperatives, Versuche und so. Wir kommen also darauf noch mal zurück. Und beim weiteren Nachlesen bin ich auch noch mal auf einen interessanten Umstand gestoßen, denn es lohnt sich durchaus, die immer auf Latein veröffentlichen Enzyklikas, wahrscheinlich Enzykliken, mal zu übersetzen, um sich nur die Ansprache anzuhören. Denn sehr typisch ist mittlerweile, womit Papst Johannes der 23.1963 begonnen hat in Pachem in Teres. Sie richtet sich nämlich an die ehrwürdigen Brüder, Patriarchen, Primaten, Erzbeschöfe, Bischöfe und sonstige Ortsordinarien, die in Frieden und Gemeinschaft mit dem apostolischen Stuhl leben, an den Klerus und die Gläubigen, die ganze Welt sowie an alle Menschen guten Willens. Also wir sind ganz explizit inkludiert in dieser Ansprache, was auch so weit geht, dass Laudato Si von 2015 noch mal allgemeiner auf die Formel hinausläuft in der Ansprache an jeden Menschen, der auf diesem Planeten wohnt. Also dieser Katholizismus, und ich will noch mal sagen, weil Jonas jetzt auch mehr über die evangelische Kirche kommt, mir ist schon wichtig, dass es da eine Hierarchie gibt, mir ist wichtig, dass es einen Papst gibt, dass es eine Adresse in Rom gibt und so weiter. Also das ist mir wichtig, aber der Gottesbezug ist mir nicht so wichtig. Und das finde ich wahnsinnig interessant, dass der Vatikan selbst in seinen zentralen Schriften sich sowieso schon immer an mich richtet, auch. Und das kann ich ja mal vergelten.
Denn du bist ja nicht verloren, du kannst ja auch noch missioniert werden, von daher ist das schon ganz sinnvoll. Und es ist eine ganz interessante Gegenposition, die du da einnimmst. Denn wenn man jetzt schaut, was die Kirchenkritiken den vergangenen Jahren, Jahrzehnten besonders in Deutschland ausmachte, dann war das ja eine Kritik der Kleriker an diesem ganzen System, bis hin auch zum Papst, also auch die Infragestellung einer solchen Hierarchie. Und man hat da so eine Kirche von unten gedacht, so heißt ja dann auch eine Organisation. Und das war immer zu sagen, Gott und wir wollen eigentlich unmittelbarer auch mit Gott in Bezug sein und wollen nicht diese Organisation, weil die natürlich auch patriarchal geprägt ist und all das, oder geprägt dominiert ist, muss man sagen, haben. Und du sagst jetzt, nein, ich will eigentlich die Organisation, aber bitte ohne den lieben Gott. Da reicht der Papst an der Spitze, ein vernünftiger Mann.
Genau, und mit Organisation meine ich ja auch dieses Containment durch die Organisation. Weil ich als Soziologe einfach sage, es geht nur durch Organisation. Also einfach jeder macht Freischaffen so einen Gottesbezug und erhält dann so eine Predigt, dann kommen 20 Leute vorbei, weil sie Lust drauf haben. Also so, ich will es jetzt nicht zu vulgär, aber so dieser evangelische Charakter, dass auch in Amerika einfach jeder selber seine Kirche erfindet und am Ende ist das so eine Musical-Show oder so, die da abläuft. Das will ich ja nicht, sondern ich will schon dieses ernst gemeinte Containment über Organisation. Nur, und das ist ja ganz früh Thomas von Aquin, der ja auch schon mit dieser Idee Thomas-Theorien und so. Wie wäre es, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das Thomas-Theorien von Thomas von Aquin, ich habe es jetzt so im Kopf zusammen, aber ihr kennt vielleicht das Thomas-Theorien. Wenn etwas eine Wirkung zeigt, wird es ja wohl eine Ursache haben. Wenn sich also Leute versammeln und die sagen alle, wir sind hier wegen Gott, dann sagt der Theologe, ja genau. Und dann sagt aber der Soziologe, nein, nein, der Regentanz ist nicht dafür da, damit der Regen kommt, sondern damit die Leute was zu tun haben, während sie auf Regen warten und alle so im gleichen Rhythmus. Und da ist natürlich der soziologische Einschlag wichtig.
Ja, man muss das vielleicht für die Leute, die dich nicht so gut kennen, erklären. Du hast ja, wenn darf ich das erzählen, wir waren einmal auf der Gamescom in Köln und sind dann danach noch was trinken gegangen. Uman war auch dabei und dort war ein Straßenfest. Und ich habe mich natürlich gleich aufgeregt, dass jetzt schon wieder irgendwo so laute Musik ist. Und du hast dich darüber gefreut, nicht weil du jetzt auf der Straßenfest wolltest, sondern du freutest dich darüber, dass die Leute sich freuen. Und so ist auch deine Betrachtung natürlich mit dem Katholizismus. Du freust dich, dass das so gut funktioniert. Die Show ist perfekt. Die Leute freuen sich, in Rom zu sein. Der Papst ist glücklich. Alle sind froh. Und das ist deine Haltung. Also bei dir ist es auch gar nicht so, du willst jetzt unbedingt dich mit da reinwerfen. Ja, also du sagst jetzt nicht, ich möchte irgendein epiphanisches Erlebnis haben, sondern dir reicht es zu sehen, dass Menschen sich organisiert haben und miteinander eine gute Zeit haben.
Ja, es ist eine ganz kleine technische Errungenschaft, aber die für mich ganz bedeutend war dieses Jahr. Denn wir hatten einen Papst, der jetzt dem Volk, dem Land, dem Erdkreis, den Menschen gezeigt wurde. Und das erste Mal konnten Drohnen über den Petersplatz fliegen. Sie kamen also von hinten, haben auf den Zinnen noch die Statuen gezeigt und dann war klar, da unten steht die Masse. Also man hat einen ganz neuen ästhetischen Einschlag auf das Ding. Man sieht zuerst das Volk und dann fliegt die Drohne rum und zeigt den Balkon und so. Oder eben man kommt von der anderen Seite und ist auf Augenhöhe des Papstes, der aber auf dem Balkon steht. Also man steht nicht unten und guckt hoch oder so, sondern die Drohne fängt die so auf Augenhöhe einfach ein. Man sieht die ganze Fassade aber asymmetrisch richtig und nicht aus so einer Perspektive. Und das sind alles solche kleinen ästhetischen Einschläge, von denen ich mich auch zurück erinnere an so Texte, die ich dann mal über die englische Kirche geschrieben habe, bei dieser Fragestellung. Die englische Kirche hat 100, 200, 300 Jahre, nachdem sie ihre Macht verlor, plötzlich so viel Aufmerksamkeit wie nichts. Also Lady Di ist tot und so. Das hat ja einen Fokus auf die Kirche, auf die englische Krone geworfen. Das war selbst der englische Krone nicht mehr geheuer. Wie viel Aufmerksamkeit sie plötzlich haben, wie wirkmächtig kleinste Kommunikation sind und so. Was ja aus unserer Medienbetrachtung und wir haben über George Clooney als Präsidenten gesprochen, bedeutet, so mächtig war die englische Krone noch nie. Wie in diesen Momenten. Das sind alles solche Sachen, die containen. Ich bleibe jetzt heute für euch mal beim Containment. Die containen rohwaltende Kräfte in dieser Gesellschaft. Die strukturieren, die geben Leute Orientierung. Da oben ist der Balkon, da findet es statt und so. Aber eigentlich, da winkt halt mal kurz jemand. Aber man ist ja trotzdem da und man erinnert sich daran, wie man da war. Und das Gerede heute noch über die Fußball-WM 2006 in Deutschland und so zeigt ja, um was es da geht.
Wir werden jetzt gleich nicht katholisch werden, sondern wir sprechen über die handfesten Dinge, die Geoökonomie. Wir sprechen über Apple, aber auch über Thomas Mann. Wir feiern ja seinen 150. Geburtstag in diesem Monat. Da ist es, glaube ich, interessant, noch mal einen neuen Blick auf Thomas Mann einzunehmen. Um all das wird es gehen im Salon. Wir freuen uns, wenn ihr den Salon abonniert und auf diese Weise auch den Podcast unterstützt. Also auch alles, was vor der Paywall stattfindet, unterstützt ihr natürlich dadurch, dass ihr den Salon abonniert. Ihr könnt übrigens den Salon auch verschenken. Bei Steady gibt es Pakete, die man anwählen kann. So kann man jemanden, den man mag oder bei dem man glaubt, der müsste mal aufgeklärt werden über einige Dinge, kann man also den Podcast dann für ein Jahr verschenken. Auch das ist kein Problem. Bei Steady ist es ganz einfach. Man geht auf die neu20er.de Seite, klickt dort auf den Salon-Button und dann kann man sich bei Steady ein Paket auswählen, hat dann Zugang auch zu allen Salons zuvor und hat auch Zugang zu den Live-Salons. Denn in diesem Monat, im Juni, findet auch wieder ein Live-Salon in Frankfurt statt, der schon ausverkauft ist. Aber am Tag danach gibt es dann das, was wir auf der Bühne getrieben haben, dann auch zu hören. Dann gibt es noch für die Leute, die schon bei Patreon sind, die Möglichkeit, über Patreon abzuschließen. Und du erklärst noch, wie das über Apple geht, wenn man Apple-Kundin ist.
Das ist am einfachsten, wenn man eh schon über Apple-Podcasts hört, was hier irgendwie, also mehr als die Hälfte der Leute hören uns über iPhones. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen elitär. Ach, das hätte ich nicht gedacht. Ja, die iPhones sind ja auch sehr gute Geräte, wir werden ja gleich aufgeklärt. Da taucht ja der Salon einfach im regulären, also Apple Podcasts App-Feed auf. Dann klickt man einfach. Aber ganz wichtig, man kann auch sein Steady-RSS-Feed, der billiger und vollständiger und so weiter ist, in der Podcasts App abonnieren von Apple.
Man muss nicht dafür sorgen, dass Tim Cook noch mehr als 700 Millionen am Tag verdient. Das reicht ja auch dann vielleicht. Aber wir können sagen, mit deinem Thema Apple sprechen wir jetzt wirklich 50 Prozent des Publikums dann direkt an, weil alle einen iPhone besitzen. Heute ist heute ist Apple Podcast. Und ich kann jetzt ja auch mitreden. Ich habe ja eins und habe schon ein bisschen damit rumprobiert, wie gesagt, ohne Social Media oder so. Aber ich bin sehr gespannt, was du jetzt über vor allem ja die Hardware uns erzählen wirst. Also dann sehen wir uns gleich im Salon.
Bis gleich. Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Was folgt eigentlich auf den Sommer?
Naja, eigentlich der Herbst, würde man sagen, aber vielleicht ist doch alles ein bisschen anders.
Was heißt anders? Was ist zu erwarten?
Nun, Toni Blair hat einmal zur Globalisierung gesagt und das wird gleich im Buch her zitiert, dass die Globalisierung nicht eine Frage von ist man dafür oder dagegen sei, nicht eine Frage von für und wieder, sondern das sei nun einfach so, wie der Herbst auf den Sommer folgt. Nun kann man sich aber fragen, stimmt das eigentlich? Also ja, für die Jahreszeiten mag das so sein, wenngleich die sich ja immer mehr angleichen, wie wir alle wissen. Aber in der Ökonomie scheint wohl dieser Vergleich mit der Natur nicht mehr möglich, denn irgendetwas hat sich ja gerade verändert. Und davon berichtet dieses Buch über das, wir reden Geoökonomie von Milan Babić. Der Untertitel lautet Anatomie der neuen Weltordnung. Bei Geoökonomie denkt man natürlich sehr schnell an Geopolitik und das ist auch quasi der Begriff, von dem sich dieses Buch abgrenzen will. Geopolitik ist also das, was wir die ganze Zeit erleben, wenn wir über die Strategien von Putin, Xi oder sonst was, sonst wem reden. Wenn wir also nur überlegen, wem hilft was meditärisch, was ist sicherheitsarchitektonisch gerade das eigentlich Wichtige. Gibt es also jetzt nur noch Primat des Politischen und das Ökonomische ist komplett hinten angestellt. Man kann mitunter ja den Eindruck bekommen, dass dem so sei. Aber man kann aber auch sagen, dass die Globalisierung ja nicht im Ganzen zurückgedreht wird. Es ist ja nicht so, dass man jetzt plötzlich sagt, wir machen gar keine Ausnahme, wir machen totale Autarkie. Auch Trumps Politik sieht ja so aus, dass er zwar harte Bandagen ankündigt, sie zum Teil wieder zurücknimmt, aber bei China besonders hart bleibt. Dann aber zugleich ja in die Arabischen Emirate fährt, um dort Deals zu machen, die man früher nicht für möglich gehalten hätte. Also dort eigentlich die Globalisierung vertieft und intensiviert. Und diese Prozesse können wir eigentlich überall beobachten, sodass jetzt die These von Milan Babić ist, nein, wir leben im Zeitalter der Geoökonomie. Und das bedeutet aber auch ganz klar, dass es nicht mehr ist, wie Toni Blair dachte oder auch Schröder und Clinton gedacht haben, dass damit der Neoliberalismus alternativlos ist, sondern das neoliberale Zeitalter, das einfach sagte, wir treiben so viel Handel wie möglich, wir senken die Zinsen, wo es nur geht, und Handel an sich ist gut. Dieses Zeitalter ist tatsächlich vorbei, weil jetzt schon das geopolitische mit hinein spielt. Und damit sagte natürlich auch, dass wir ein Ende des Neoliberalismus erleben. Man könnte jetzt anfangen zu jubeln, aber keineswegs wird damit die Welt einfacher.
Genau. Ich finde auch, hier sollten wir mit Rampeln einsteigen, wie du jetzt. Denn ich fand es auch überraschend, hat er ja auch erst in der Ankündigung so gespielt, mit diesem Widersatz Geopolitik, Geökonomie, und dachte, okay, das markiert jetzt so Zeitalter, hier gibt es so eine Zäsur, Geopolitik ist nicht mehr jetzt Geökonomie, ganz so ist es ja nicht. Ich finde auch, das sollte man gleich am Anfang so markieren, um das Buch dann besser aufzuschlüsseln, gerade wenn man es jetzt nur über uns hört und nicht selber liest. Denn diese Zeit, in der die Globalisierung als so eine Naturgewalt wie Tony Blair und eben auch Bill Clinton, also Bill Clinton hat gesagt, es ist eine Naturgewalt, und Tony Blair hat dieses Jahreszeiten-Ding gemacht. Und er beginnt ja auch mit Gerhard Schröder. Die Globalisierung bedeutet nicht das Ende der staatlichen Handlungsfähigkeit. Wichtig ist, dass wir, unsere nationale Politik, den Bedingungen der Globalisierung anpassen. Regierungserklärung 1999, und wir kennen ja die marktkonforme Demokratie von Merkel dann später, relativ früh, 2005, 2007, so. Und das markiert heute ein Zeitalter der Globalisierung, in der alle politischen Bestrebungen, die es gab, transnationale Organisationen aufzubauen, Welthandelsorganisationen, Schiedsgerichte, Währungsräume, Binnenmärkte, wie auch immer, ausschließlich auf mehr Globalisierung, Vergrößerung der Synergieeffekte, mehr Gewinne, also so Win-win-win Logik, irgendwie.
Das, was Jake Sullivan dann kritisiert hat, wir haben das ja im Podcast das letzte Mal gehört, wo er sagte, der Washingtoner Konsensus ist jetzt obsolet geworden, wir brauchen einen neuen Konsensus.
Einzelne Länder fühlen sich, sagen wir mal, ausgebeutet im schlimmen Wortschatz, weil wir Trump den ja auch so benutzt und sagen, das war ja gar nicht nur win-win-win. Und gleichzeitig, und das ist dieses große Phänomen, Geoökonomie ist, wenn die Errungenschaften der Globalisierung, also der Institutionalisierung der Globalisierung, genutzt werden, um gezielt Schaden zu verursachen, wieder ein partikularistisches Interesse zu nutzen, Länder vom SWIFT Zahlungsverkehr auszuschließen, damit es ihnen schlechter geht. Sanktionen. Und das fand ich relativ früh als Erkenntnis aus dem Text für so einen jungen niederländischen Autor, Jahrgang 1990, mit Professuren Amsterdam, einen sehr nüchternen, nicht übertriebenen, sehr guten Einschlag in so eine Zeitdiagnostik, die mit einem großen Begriff daherkommt, aber konzeptionell, sagen wir mal, unter der Wolkendecke bleibt und uns wirklich was erklären kann. Und da ist das Buch sehr gut. Von daher, genau, er steigt mit diesem Zeitalter der Globalisierung als Naturgewalt ein. Clinton Blair, Gerhard Schröder, dieses wurde ja auch so gefeiert, also schon in Praxis, das hat ja gar keine Geschichtsschreibung abgewartet, die sind ja schon währenddessen. Ich weiß zum Beispiel, Gerhard Schröder, also sein erster Auslandsreiser als Kanzler, führte nach London, nicht nach Paris oder Polen, wie heute. Dass man so am gleichen Tag Polen, Frankreich. Also das waren andere Zeiten damals. Dann kam Brexit und so. Also das ultimative, ne wir machen es jetzt wieder geökonomisch, aber wir stellen uns selber auf die Seite, in der der Sperr fliegt, also das ist ja auch kommenden drauf. Total bescheuert sowas zu machen. Also sehr guter Einstieg in dieses Buch und sehr guter, finde ich sehr guter Kontrast zwischen so Geopolitik und Geoökonomie.
Du hast es jetzt gerade schön geschildert unter der Wolkendecke, denn wenn wir jetzt dieses Buch lesen, dann sollten wir nicht erwarten, dass wir jetzt die Theorie für alles bekommen. Es ist natürlich in unserer Anlage so, und ich ertappe mich ja selbst dabei, dass man, wenn die Zeiten sich wandeln, man gerne diese allumfassende Erklärung hätte, mit einem Begriff, der dann auch zugleich den Diskurs abschließt. Deshalb geht man dazu über, wenn immer eine Krise ist, zum Beispiel Francis Fukuyama anzurufen in der Hoffnung, dass er noch mal so eine These zum Ende der Geschichte aufrollt, die jetzt dann absolut zutreffend zu sein scheint. Und genau das bietet jetzt der Autor nicht an, sondern er sagt, das ist ein Begriff, der versucht, der Komplexität gerecht zu werden, bedeutet aber auch, man muss den in seine Offenheit denken. Heißt also, ja, es gibt sehr viele verschiedene Strömungen gerade. Und wenn wir jetzt mal über Dinge genauer nachdenken, dann merken wir auch selbst immer, dass das im Ganzen, sagen wir dann, immer häufig keinen Sinn ergibt. Aber man kann ja auch sagen, na ja, es gibt verschiedene Sinnangebote, beziehungsweise es gibt ja durchaus widerstreitende Kräfte, auch innerhalb eines Staates oder so. Also man kann natürlich sagen, Trump macht Protektionismus. So, aha. Aber zugleich sehen wir, Trump ist also sehr daran interessiert, lauter Deals zu machen. Also wirtschaftliche Verflechtungen zu verstärken. Trump wirtschaftet in die eigene Tasche. Stimmt. Aber er schadet auch der heimischen Industrie damit, wenn er jetzt zum Beispiel Apple oder Mattel, dem Spielwarenhersteller oder so, irgendwelchen Druck macht. Und dann merken wir plötzlich, ja, das ist also ein sehr vielstimmiges Orchester, das wir da erleben. Und das können wir natürlich auch für die EU, oder können wir auch für China sehen. Denn ja, China versucht, seine Binnenwirtschaft zu stärken. Aber ist es deshalb sinnvoll, so lange in einem Lockdown zu fahren? Ist es deshalb sinnvoll, selbst plötzlich in den Zeugkrieg mit einzusteigen? Also wir finden die ganze Zeit widersprüchliches Verhalten. Oder man könnte sagen, ja, die Komplexität bedeutet eigentlich, die heute erfahren wird, weltwirtschaftlich. Und das liegt durch diese neoliberale Institutionalisierung, die da stattgefunden hat, liegt darin begründet, dass also heute die ganze Zeit ein jedes Handeln auch wiederum als ja sein Gegenteil betrachtet werden muss. Beziehungsweise die Widersprüche werden quasi automatisch produziert. Also du kannst gar nicht anders sehen, sondern du sagst, wir machen jetzt eine Mauer drum, versuchen Nordkorea zu spielen. So dann kann man sagen, jetzt haben wir uns de-coupled. Aber alles andere, was nicht jetzt in Richtung Nordkorea direkt geht, bedeutet eigentlich die ganze Zeit ja die Risking, aber auch wieder tiefere Verflechtung, neue Abhängigkeiten. Denn das haben wir ja schon gesehen, um ein Beispiel noch zu nennen. Als man in Deutschland beschlossen, man will jetzt nicht mehr von russischer Energie abhängig sein und man ja erst noch das lange laufen ließ, weil man es doch noch eine Weile braucht und so. Auch das zeigt ja schon, also so direkte Cuts kann man schlecht machen. Haben wir direkt, ich habe damals gesagt, unser autoritäres Portfolio erweitert. Wir haben nämlich plötzlich Aserbaidschan und Katar und weiß ich nicht, wen alles dazu genommen. Das heißt, auch da sehen wir plötzlich nicht eine Loslösung von Abhängigkeiten, sondern eigentlich eine Vertiefung und zugleich Diversifizierung.
Ja, die Geschichte hätte man auch ganz anders schreiben können, statt Habecks Heizhammer, dass man so eine Idee von Putin, von dem kaufen wir nicht mehr. Also fliegen wir nach Katar, machen da einen Kotao und dann passiert aber der 7. Oktober. Ja, also sozusagen von einem historischen Fettnäpfchen ins nächste getrampelt, aber man ist ja wohlwollend damit umgegangen. Also sich von diesen großen Zäsuren, also ich sage immer Zäsuren erkennen und so ist ja auch wichtig, aber daraus die Ableitung zu groß zu machen, da hat uns ja Frano Ostratchi mit seiner Dissertation zur Diagnosegesellschaft und er ist sie dann durchgegangen. Also immer wenn jemand so eine große Diagnose stellt, ist das selber schon wieder Anlass für eine Diagnose. Irgendetwas stimmt doch hier nicht in der Bearbeitung dieser. Und so zitiert er hier auch Historiker Quinn Slobodian, der eben diese rechtlichen, sozialen, unpolitischen Absicherung des freien Spiels der Marktkräfte, den sich die Politik verschrieb. Also, man ist ja aus den Zitaten so abzuleiten. Und hier ist eben ganz wichtig, rechtliche, soziale, unpolitische Dimensionen kriegt man nicht auf einen Nenner, sondern da muss man sozusagen ein bisschen ins Detail gehen. Und deswegen beginnt er mit einem empirischen Verweis nach dem Gerede über die Globalisierung und ihre faktischen politischen Organisationen. Haben wir heute ganz klar Handelskriege. Wir haben eine geopolitische EU-Kommission. So hat sie Ursula von der Leyen 2019 angekündigt, wie er schreibt. Wir haben seit 22 wieder Territorialkriege. Alles das in einem zirkulären Verhältnis. Denn dadurch wurde überhaupt erst klar, ach so, man kann solche Sanktionen machen. Man kann, ist ja die aktuelle Diskussion, gefrorene Werte von Russland vielleicht fruchtbar machen für andere Sachen und so. Deswegen ist ja auch witzig, dass heute Friedrich Merz in Washington ist und gestern Lindsey Graham ein Interview in der FAZ hat. Also, dass da so Wege bereitet werden für so, ja, ja, das kann man schon machen. Also, wir können jetzt sogar die Assets, die wir da eingefroren haben, man muss es nur Trump ordentlich vorbereiten, dass Merz da kommt und sagt, nee, das ist doch euer Plan, euer Senator hat das doch bei uns hofffähig gemacht als Idee und ich spiegele das doch nur zurück, in der Hoffnung, dass Trump dann irgendwann mal so mitmacht, so mit solchen Sanktionspaketen. Also, in deren Sicht, ja, hier sieht man einfach die fair, es gibt ja kein gutes deutsches Wort, weaponisation von dem ganzen Zeug, also, dass man einfach alles, was da ist, dann irgendwie dual-use-mäßig zu einer Waffe macht. Weshalb er mit zwei großen Ideen beginnt. Die Staatsmacht ist zurück und damit auch die geopolitische Auseinandersetzung. Diese, wie er es nennt, geopolitische Vision einer post-neoliberalen globalen Ordnung ist jetzt im Entstehen. Er wird das dann später groß Interregium nennen. Also, er verwahrt sich komplett gegen, so ist es jetzt, das ist der Begriff dafür, sondern, ne, ne, wir verabschieden hier einfach eine alte Ordnung, also Globalisierung als Win-win-win und alle profitieren, vom einzelnen Mitarbeiter bis zur politischen Klasse, die endlich befreit davon ist, sich noch um irgendwas zu kümmern, weil sie nur noch Markt organisiert, sondern, nein, der Staat ist zurück, die Auseinandersetzung ist zurück und es ist ein großes Durcheinander.
Ja, es ist ein Interregnum, bedeutet aber auch, es ist endlich, es wird jetzt nicht ewig so weitergehen, davon geht er aus. Allerdings habe ich mir gedacht...
Aber man kann nichts darüber sagen.
Das kann man so sehen, ja, also irgendwann kommt was anderes, aber die Frage ist, ob es noch mal im Ganzen eine Hegemonie ergibt, beziehungsweise ist nicht, wenn diese Hegemonie sich auflöst und nicht eine neue danach kommt, und die wäre ja dann zum Beispiel chinesischer Natur, wäre das dann eine, bei der wieder ein ruhigeres Fahrwasser eintritt, egal wie sie dann gestaltet ist. Also man kann natürlich auch sagen, vielleicht geht es jetzt einfach über Ewigkeiten so weiter.
Genau, also das kann man ja schon mal fassen, denn hier kann man ja auch ein bisschen, da muss man gar nicht zu eng am Text bleiben. Wir haben schon häufiger betont, es war eine besondere Konstellation, dass Marktwirtschaft und Demokratie in der westlichen Welt so im Gleichschritt coevoluierten, für alle Wirtschaftswachstum und Biografie bedeuteten, Dach über dem Kopf. Und das Ganze noch angefüttert war mit Verweis auf George Clooney, einer Hollywood-Geschichte, die uns das vorlebt, die uns zeigt, an wen wir uns orientieren sollen und wo wir unsere nächsten kulturellen Ideen herbekommen. Und im Grunde wird das nächste große, diese nächste große Gemengelage gesucht. Aber allein nur in der wirtschaftlichen Dimension zu denken im Sinne von, das ist jetzt das chinesische Jahrhundert, weil die uns so toll die Produkte herstellen, während wir gleichzeitig uns aber immer fürchten vor China, statt einfach zu sagen, Amerika ist mein Hoffnungsland. Ich brauche das amerikanische Telefon, den amerikanischen Film und so. Das funktioniert nicht. Also China ist hier nicht gut aufgestellt, wie er sagt, um das Interregium zu beenden mit einer schlagkräftigen Idee, die auf allen Dimensionen uns wieder einfängt und Orientierung gibt.
Also was er meint, die Softpower, die ist einfach nicht da. Weil in den USA hatten wir diese Softpower, die selbst bei denen, die, sagen wir, sogar anti-amerikanisch eingestellt war, immer noch da war. Also am Ende war es doch auch die amerikanische Rockmusik, die in der DDR gern gehört wurde. War es auch in Kreisen, die die USA hart kritisiert haben für Vietnam und folgende Kriege? Immer doch die amerikanische Kultur, an der man sich ausgerichtet hat. Sehr stark zumindest in der Popkultur. Und man kann dies allerdings bislang nicht feststellen bei irgendeiner anderen Region. Also wir haben jetzt nicht eine generelle Ausrichtung hin zur chinesischen Popkultur oder so. Auch wenn die einen gewissen Einfluss jetzt hat und wir haben natürlich auch andere Regionen, die Kultur produzieren und das wird wichtiger. Aber man hat nicht damit gleichzeitig verbunden, so eine Lebenswelt, der man gerne nahe sein möchte. Also man versucht nicht, den American Way of Life jetzt in dem Sinne zu modellieren, zum chinesischen Weg, den man gehen möchte oder ein anderes Land zu nennen, wäre auch da nicht möglich. Und das bedeutet also erst einmal, dass wir über wirtschaftliche Kennzahlen sprechen. Und diese natürlich ganz erstaunlich, wenn man da auf China blickt. Bedeutet aber noch nicht, dass wir jetzt eben in dieses chinesische Zeitalter eingetreten sind. Zumindest kulturell sieht auch nichts danach aus, als würde das in naher Zukunft kommen. Und was ja auch interessant ist, wenn man sich chinesische Blockbuster der Zehnerjahre ansieht, darauf geht er jetzt nicht ein, aber das sei nur angefügt, dann ist ja auch da interessant, dass die sich häufig, bei allem chinesischen Nationalismus, den sie vertreten, an amerikanischen Vorbildern orientieren. Also nicht eine eigene Ästhetik dort hervorgebracht haben, sondern vielmehr, um vielleicht auch am Weltmarkt gängig zu sein, aber sicher auch um das eigene Publikum zu begeistern, haben sie sich dann an dem amerikanischen Film stark orientiert.
Also die Sehgewohnheit bleibt intakt, aber es kann eben sein, dass es einfach nur was Tradition ist. Denn wenn wir selbst in Texas erleben, dass Romeo und Julia jetzt aus Schulbibliotheken verschwindet, weil da illegitime Liebe thematisiert wird, dann sieht man, mit dem Thema Softpower ist Amerika auch gerade nicht groß im Angebot.
Nee, also überhaupt nicht. Das ist ja eine große Krise jetzt gerade auch.
Es geht sich nicht darum, was als nächstes kommt, sondern wir sind in irgendeiner Region, weil wir etwas abgebaut haben. Und jetzt habe ich ja eben schon gesagt, er sagt, es sind zwei große Ideen, die Staatsmacht ist zurück und damit die geopolitische Auseinandersetzung. Aber er möchte das geoeconomisch interpretieren. Er möchte nicht davon ausgehen, dass die Staatsmacht zurückkommt, anstelle der Marktmacht, der Globalisierung, sondern die Globalisierung bleibt intakt, zitiert er von JP. Morgan Chase aus einer großen Deglobalisierungsstudie, also die auch mal, da findet ja eine Deglobalisierung statt. Und wir sehen ja auch, dass, wenn man genauer hinschreibt, wie er schreibt, wir leben nicht in einer zeitflächendeckenden Deglobalisierung, wo ökonomische Gefahren und Abhängigkeiten lauern, diversifizieren Firmen ihre Lieferketten und vertiefen somit teilweise ihre Integration in die Weltwirtschaft. Was ja bedeutet, Apple, die bisher viele Anstrengungen, wir kommen nachher drauf, gemacht haben, um in China ein bisschen noch unabhängig zu sein von einzelnen Unternehmen, sagen sich jetzt plötzlich, wir müssen von China unabhängig sein. Das ist schwer genug. Diese Rückkehr nach Amerika, die Trump sich wünscht, ist völlig außer, also das geht gar nicht. Stattdessen Vietnam, Indien und so weiter. Es ist also noch mehr Globalisierung. Durch das, was wir jetzt immer so als Deglobalisierung beschreiben, weil wir uns zu sehr an der Semantik der Politiker aufhalten und zu wenig die strukturellen Effekte sehen, die daraus folgen, wenn da so ein Theater stattfindet. Also eigentlich kriechen die Unternehmen, die sich es leisten können, jetzt gerade in die Welt und versuchen da einfach Schutz zu finden. Es ist sehr viel Schutz in Indien und Vietnam zu erwarten, vor chinesischer Einflussnahme. Aber da man die Produkte in Amerika verkaufen möchte, hat man immer die amerikanische Zeugschranke. Also das eigentliche, wovor sich das amerikanische Unternehmen in Schutz bringen möchte, ist amerikanische Politik. Und das ist sozusagen Antrieb, sich jetzt richtig global zu vernetzen und da die Spinnweben aufzuspannen. Also in der Ansicht, er hat sich ja wirklich eine große Fragestellung gestellt.
Und er zitiert ja auch direkt Jake Sullivan. Er sagt, wie der nationale Sicherheitsberater Joe Biden, Jake Sullivan erläuterte, ist es in dieser neuen Ära des geoeconomischen Wettbewerbs eine strategische Kernaufgabe, einen Balanceaktie zwischen restriktiven Instrumenten, die wirtschaftlichen Schaden zufügen und positiven Instrumenten, die gegenseitigen ökonomischen Nutzen in Aussicht stellen, zu ermöglichen. Diese Ambiguität der geoeconomischen Ordnung, zunehmende Konflikte bei gleichbleibender und vielleicht sogar vertiefter globaler Verzahnung, ist ein Ergebnis ihrer Genese aus der neoliberalen Globalisierung heraus. Interdependenz ist für die Möglichkeit, geoeconomische Konflikte auszutragen zentral. Ihr Rückbau im Sinne von De- oder Ent-Globalisierung ist daher unwahrscheinlich. Also das, was jetzt in den vergangenen 80 Jahren passiert ist mit der Globalisierung, es gab natürlich schon länger Globalisierung, aber wo sie auch dann nach und nach das neoliberale Gewand bekam, die Institutionalisierung von der Welthandel zur Organisation bis hin zu Zahlungsdienstleistungen wie Swift, all das hat natürlich dafür gesorgt, dass die Verflechtung so stark ist und die gegenseitigen Abhängigkeiten so stark sind, dass man gar nicht heraus kann aus diesem, sondern man kann jetzt anfangen mit diesen Instrumenten, die man hat, das Ganze so umzugestalten, dass man damit Feinde treffen und Freunde erfreuen kann mit. Die Frage ist dann natürlich, wenn es also nicht eine Entglobalisierung ist, wird dann mit dieser Geoökonomisierung plötzlich das Ökonomische doch, also im Sinne von wie viel BIP bringt es, in den Hintergrund getränkt. Und das ist ja schon offenbar der Fall. Also Geoökonomie meint ja jetzt nicht, dass man sagt, und am Ende ist es immer noch eine Kosten-Nutzen-Rechnung im Sinne von, wer macht das billigste Produkt, wo können wir am meisten mit unseren Direktinvestitionen Rendite machen, sondern es ist eine Kosten-Nutzen-Rechnung, die auch fragt, hilft das der staatlichen Sicherheit oder schadet es? Ist dadurch möglicherweise die Klimafrage in einer Weise berührt, wie es uns unrecht ist? Sorgt das vielleicht dafür, dass mögliche Rivalen in Zukunft von uns erst wirtschaftlich ermächtigt werden? Rivalen zu werden. Das heißt also, die Kosten-Nutzen-Rechnung, die jetzt da ist, ist sehr viel ausdifferenzierter. Oder die Excel-Tabelle, die man machen muss, hat sehr viel mehr Spalten plötzlich, als wenn es nur darum geht, in der alten Globalisierungsordnung des Neoliberalismus zu sagen, ja, was Wachstum bringt, ist gut, Zölle runter, Exporte rauf, Importe rauf, was immer ihr machen wollt, legt los.
Also das hätte auch ein großer Themeneinschlag werden können, Kosten-Nutzen-Rechnung, denn die aktuelle Diskussion und genau darum geht es ihm ja, dreht sich ja so, dass wir sagen, okay, wir hatten bisher eine Globalisierung, die einfach Win-win-win für alle ist, vor allem für die Unternehmen. Die Politik hat sich darauf beruht zu sagen, ja, wir schaffen euch ein Marktumfeld mit niedrigen Steuern und so weiter, dass ihr da möglichst gut weltweit ausschwärmen könnt. Und jetzt stellt die Politik plötzlich fest, dass sie ja selber auch eine Rationalität hat, politische Anliegen, die man fruchtbar machen kann, indem man diese, und das ist eben ein toller Satz, Interdependenz ist die Möglichkeit, überhaupt geoeconomische Konflikte jetzt austragen zu können. Also nur weil die eigenen Unternehmen, die man durch Hauptsitze in Berlin oder Washington oder wie auch immer da im eigenen Land, hat man die Möglichkeit, sie zu benutzen, woanders Schäden anzuführen. Er kommt ja darauf, dass die Antwort auf die kriegerische Intervention von Russland in der Ukraine eine geoeconomische, und zwar rein geoeconomische Antwort war, der EU und Amerikas. Alle Mittel, die diese politischen Entitäten genutzt haben, sind ökonomischer Natur und sie werden eben jetzt geoeconomisch genutzt. Wir haben Sanktionen, Entkopplungen, wirtschaftlicher Druck, der gemacht wird und im Grunde haben wir ja eine Diskussion, die sich fragt, schaden die Sanktionen auch den anderen mehr als uns, weil dann sind sie für uns gut. Dann ist der Schaden für uns gut. Und das wäre einfach vor Jahrzehnten gar nicht möglich gewesen. Aber heute ist es einfach Stand der Dinge, dass man die Globalisierung so selbst zur Waffe macht. Was eben bedeutet, erst wenn es hart auf hart kommt, stellt man fest, wie wichtig eigentlich einzelne Unternehmen sind. Und dass sie dann selber auf Augenhöhe mit Staaten sind, schon allein, weil einige Unternehmen, Apple und so, mehr Umsätze und mehr Kapital und mehr Bevölkerung, jetzt schon gesagt, beschäftigt haben als ganze Staaten, ganze Länder. Auch Unternehmen werden nun zu Akteuren in einem globalen Wettkampf um politische Macht und politischen Einfluss. Wir haben also so eine Rückkehr der Politik auf einem Felde, wo sie bisher noch nie war. Bislang waren es immer kriegerische Auseinandersetzungen im Ausland, angetrieben von einer starken heimischen Wirtschaft, aber nicht angetrieben von Möglichkeiten über wirtschaftliche Verflechtungen, die man irgendwo sieht. Und jetzt werden diese Mittel genutzt und dann wird mal geguckt, was so passiert.
Ja, wir haben ja mal vor vielen, vielen Jahren hier im Salon, muss man fast sagen, also ziemlich, ich würde sagen, 2021 oder so müsste man noch mal nachschauen, über ein Buch gesprochen. Ich habe es allein vorgestellt und zwar Tools and Weapons von Microsoft Anwalt Brad Smith. Und ich sagte damals, es ist ein langweiliges Buch, aber ein hochinteressantes Buch, weil das ja sagt, dass die Unternehmen jetzt mal von ihrem Libertären Silicon Valley Gehabe weg sollen und mit den Regierungen besser zusammenarbeiten sollten. Denn die Regierungsinteressen, zum Beispiel eine Anti-China-Politik, könnten ja auch die Interessen des Unternehmens sein bzw. könnten die Unternehmen dabei helfen, diese Politik auch wirklich umzusetzen. Bedeutet also, man muss mehr an einem Tisch gemeinsam sitzen. Und da hattest du damals gesagt, ja, das ist bestimmt langweilig, aber das ist wahrscheinlich so ein Buch, das so eine Grundlage ist, auf die wir immer wieder noch zurückkommen werden. Und tatsächlich ist das so, auch wenn Babić das Buch nicht zitiert, bedauernd seiterweise, ist das, glaube ich, etwas, was wir jetzt durchgängig sehen. Und auch bei Alex Karp haben wir das ja erlebt. Alex Karp ist ja niemand, der sagt, wir hören jetzt mit der Globalisierung auf, sondern er sagt, wie gestalten wir den jetzt nach unseren Ideen? Und das bedeutet dieses uns, also nach den Unternehmerideen und nach der aktuellen Regierung dann, also nach den Ideen der Trump-Regierung. Und bedeutet natürlich, dass man sich in die Geopolitik als Unternehmen direkt mit einmischt. Und das ist diese Verschiebung, die, glaube ich, mit Geoökonomie, wirklich also mit diesem Begriff sehr gut betrachtet ist, weil das andere, reine Geopolitik, bedeutet natürlich nur so Schachspielen. Also ich mache jetzt einfach nur den einen Zug, weil das im Kräfteverhältnis der strategische Realismus so und so erfordert. Und da ist jetzt eine Geoökonomie, die sagt, naja, aber diese ganze Struktur, die da mal geschaffen wurde, die ist ja noch da und die kann man ja nutzbar machen.
Ja, ich habe die Woche einen Reisebericht aus Japan bekommen von einer Freundin, die jetzt drei Wochen da war. Und da gab es einzelne Fotos, die auch noch mal verdeutlichten, wie sehr man eigentlich in Zeitaltern denken kann und sollte. Und sei es nur heuristisch, aber dass man sich mal was klarmacht. So und das wird ja in diesem Buch auch gemacht. Also in Japan ist das ganz auffällig. Es gibt so eine Kipppunktzeit vor 300 Jahren, als Japan geeint wurde. Kennen wir in Europa auch, Kleinstaaterei und so weiter. Und dann gibt es so große Reichsformungen, wie auch immer. Und die Schlösser, also sie heißen Schlösser, sie sehen mehr aus wie Paläste und sind nicht vergleichbar mit unseren Burgen im Rheintal oder so, sondern es sind diese geschwungenen Dächer. Jedes Stockwerk schwingt so aus wie so ein Tannenbaum. So, bevor der Einheit Japans, als dann Ein Shogun einfach gesagt hat, wir machen jetzt die friedliche Einheit oder die nahezu friedliche Einheit, waren die alle schwarz. Und die bauten danach, um die friedliche Zeit zu verdeutlichen, sind weiß. Und zum Teil hat man diese Gebäude umgemalt. So, und manchmal finde ich, ist es ganz gut, so in diesen strengen Zäsuren zu denken, dass man es wirklich sieht, um wahrzunehmen, okay, wir haben ein Interregium, wir wissen nicht genau, aber es ist anders als vorher. Und die Zeit vorher wird von ihm gut abgehandelt, denn das Interregium jetzt schließt ja an, an eine neoliberale Globalisierung. Wir haben also eine Periode von den 1980ern bis zu den 2010er-Jahren, da ist ja auch der Einstieg ins Buch, in dem die Nationalstaaten die Weltwirtschaft für sich erkennen. Ich finde, da schlummert auch noch eine große zweite Kolonialisierungsdebatte drin, die auch zu arbeiten ist, die eben nicht über Menschen, Sklaven und so weiter, sondern über diese Ausbeutung. Wir sehen das nachher auch bei Apple, also es ist ja grotesk, unter welchen Bedingungen da gearbeitet wurde in China. Auch weil die chinesische Regierung das natürlich zugelassen hat, aus eigenen rationalen Gründen, auch eigener Punkt der Geoökonomie. Davor 45 bis 1970. Also wir haben auch hier Zeiten, in denen die Häuser schwarz gemalt wurden und dann weiß gemalt wurden und dann nochmal besonders schön weiß gemalt wurden. Und jetzt haben wir wieder diese Zeiten. Und die Frage ist immer, was bleibt? Welche Zäsuren sind heute besonders wichtig? Und bei ihm ist auch ganz entscheidend, Eintritt Chinas in die WTO 2001. China unterwirft sich dem westlichen Standard. Wir werden aber nachher hören, wie das nur auf der Schauseite stattfand und eigentlich anders regiert wurde, weil die Chinesen schon Geoökonomie in diesem Stile, also wir nutzen die Instrumente und die Verflechtung aber für uns, gemacht hatte, wie er das heute empfiehlt. So und im Big Technology Podcast war Anthony Scaramucci, der für elf Tage damals bei Trump, so im italienischen Mafia-Einschlag Kommunikationsdirektor war. Und der erinnert sich in diesem Podcastgespräch an diese Zeit, als er an der Wall Street war und die alle sagten, China, geiler Markt, geiler Absatzmärkte, geile Werkbänke, die machen alles für uns, die müssen sofort in die WTO, weil dann haben wir sie gezammt. So und er sagt heute ausdrücklich, das war damals ein Fehler, die hatten Recht, wir lagen falsch, jetzt liegt Amerika am Boden, weil wir damals an der Wall Street diesen gigantischen Fehler gemacht haben, zu sagen, wir diktieren euch einfach die WTO-Regeln und dann macht ihr mal und dann guckt aber keiner so genau hin. Und viel zu spät sieht man so, was hat Apple da gemacht und so. Also hier schließen sich einfach mehrere Kreise, wo ich sagen würde, ja, hier müssten wir jetzt im japanischen Zeitalter wirklich Häuser weiß, schwarzgrün und blau malen, um das mal zu verdeutlichen, was war, wie wirkmächtig diese Grundprinzipien waren. Also Kriege, völlig klar. Zig Millionen Tote ist ein anderes Zeitalter als 45 bis 1970. Demokratie und Marktwirtschaft, alle profitieren, Wirtschaftswunder, jeder kriegt sein Haus, allen geht's gut. Dann Erfindung Weltwirtschaft, Containerschifffahrt und so weiter. Ich glaube, das wird in unserer Geschichtsschreibung, weil wir immer so sehr auf politische Personen fokussiert sind. Dann kommt die Hitler Biografie, dann kommt die Adorno Biografie und so. Wird das immer so ein bisschen übersehen, einfach wo die eigentlichen Kräfte walten und die, dass die politische Geschichte vielleicht mehr so ein, okay, das ist so die Schauseite, da wird das Narrativ sozusagen von denen mitgeliefert. Da muss nicht erst ein McGee mit 200 Leuten reden, um mal einen roten Faden zu finden, sondern da läuft immer alles so im biologischen Rhythmus irgendwie. Das führt uns in die Irre. Der Ansicht finde ich, dass hier so ein Jahrgang 1990, ich weiß gar nicht, was er ist, Historiker, Politiker, Wissenschaftler, Ökonomer, uns das mal so vor Augen führt und dann einfach sagt, Krise 2008, ihr habt es alle gefühlt, ja, das ist die Zäsur. Danach wurden die Häuser schwarz gemacht, so ungefähr.
Und bis dahin ist sehr viel passiert. Also von 1990 bis 2008 ist der Welthandel enorm gewachsen. Der Welthandel nahm zwischen 90 und 2008 von 38 auf 60 Prozent des globalen Protoinlandsprodukts zu. Direkte Investitionen wuchsen in hohem Maße. Man hat auch eine Weltbevölkerung, die aus der Armut, aus absoluter Armut gehoben wird, zumindest zu einem großen Teil, von circa 38 Millionen im Jahr 1990 auf etwas, Entschuldigung, von circa 38 Prozent im Jahr 1990 auf etwas unter 19 Prozent 2008. Also man hat eigentlich die Armut halbiert. Und das ist natürlich auch ganz viel mit der chinesischen Entwicklung verbunden. Und dann haben wir auch generell eine unglaubliche Steigung, das durchschnittliche BP pro Kopf stieg von circa 6.800 US-Dollar im Jahr 1990 auf 9.200 im Jahr 2008. Also das heißt, es gibt schon eine Erfolgsgeschichte dieser Globalisierung. Bedeutet natürlich auch, dass mit China als Gigantem dann plötzlich ein Akteur auftritt, der für eine westliche Ego-Monie insofern gefährlich werden kann, als die wirtschaftliche Macht. Und wann so groß ist, dass man nicht mehr die Regeln diktieren kann, sondern China selbst beginnt, Regeln aufzustellen oder alternative Verflechtungen versucht, wie zum Beispiel die Belt and Road Initiative oder andere Formen der Handelsbeziehungen, die nicht mehr nach dem westlichen Prinzip sortiert sind.
Ja, so, und jetzt haben wir diese Erfolgsgeschichten von damals, die ganz klar Erfolgsgeschichten sind und hängen in einer Zeit fest, geplagt von keiner Antwort auf die Klimakrise und einem falschen Populismus. Das ist eigentlich super interessant, wie er das hier schreibt. Wir haben ja häufiger schon angemahnt, wir bräuchten mal einen linken Populismus oder sowas, oder einen grünen Populismus oder wie auch immer. Er schreibt jetzt immer mal so vom falschen Rechtspopulismus, als ob es einen richtigen Rechtspopulismus gäbe, meint aber eigentlich, weil er häufig auch vom falschen Populismus schreibt und trotzdem sagt, nee, da steckt schon was drin. Es ist halt nur der falsche Populismus. Also er kritisiert nicht den Populismus, sondern den falschen Populismus, aber relativ häufig im Text ist so vom falschen Rechtspopulismus die Rede. Also da hätte man ein bisschen sorgfältiger, glaube ich, redigieren müssen. Ich glaube, er meint, dass so wie ich es jetzt deute, Populismus ist nicht grundsätzlich eine falsche Antwort, aber der Rechtspopulismus ist falsch. Irgendwie so. Aber das sind die zwei großen Sachen, die uns plagen. Was jetzt für mich bedeutet, als erstes großes Leseerlebnis. Ja, das ist die Herausforderung. Also wer dem Rechtspopulismus begegnen möchte, auch mit einem Verweis auf, wir sollten mal die Klimakrise angehen, muss sich mit diesen Zeitalter, Geoökonomie, was war, was ist nicht mehr, was ist dieses Chaos, so befassen, wie er das aufschreibt. Ansonsten sieht man es einfach nicht und hängt sich nur wieder an die Hoffnung, dass Alexander Dobrindt dann auch mal was gegen, was weiß ich, die Reisburger macht und so. Und denkt, da steckt jetzt Hoffnung drin, dass man so eine Reisburger, irgendwelche Könige verbietet oder sowas. Damit ist er ja ins Amt gekommen quasi. Das sind ja die ersten Zuckungen, die wir da sehen. Aber das ist ja nun nicht auf Augenhöhe.
Er spricht ja dann in dem ersten Kapitel über den Neoliberalismus, was er eigentlich bedeutete. Er sagte zunächst einmal, der Neoliberalismus war nie eine Abwicklung der Staaten, sondern die Staaten haben zur Durchsetzung des Neoliberalismus geführt. Also die mussten das ja auch erst ermöglichen. Das bedeutete eine Ausdehnung der Finanzmärkte, auch eine Internationalisierung der Finanzmärkte. Bedeutete Shareholder Value Kapitalismus. Also dass nur das, was ja Profit für ein Unternehmen bringt, auch gut ist. Das ist Wall Street mit Michael Douglas. Gear ist gut. Das ist das Prinzip. Dazu kommt aber bei diesem Exzess dann eine fiskalische Disziplinierung der breiten Bevölkerung. Austeriketspolitik. Bitte spart jetzt mal. Und vor allem spart man beim Sozialen. Auch das führt natürlich dann, dass der falsche Populismus so erfolgreich ist. Wettbewerbsfähigkeit ist das Einzige, was zählt. Und bedeutet also, wer kann günstiger produzieren. Deswegen hat ja dann die Agenda 2010 mit Gerhard Schröder den größten Niedriglohnsektor in Europa geschaffen. Nämlich in Deutschland, wo man denkt, das müsste doch eigentlich das Hochlohnland sein. Warum brauchen wir da einen Niedriglohnsektor? Na ja, wegen der Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und auch, weil die Ratingagenturen uns dann vielleicht besser bewerten. Zweitens kommt dann Deregulierung und Flexibilisierung hinzu. Das bedeutet aber ja nicht, dass Regeln einfach wegfallen, sondern man hat eben neue Regeln. Und das ist dann sowohl auf die Finanzmärkte bezogen, wie auch natürlich auf Kredite, die genommen werden können. Was dürfen Banken eigentlich an Kreditgeschäften zulassen? Man lockert immer weiter, immer weiter, bis es dann so ist, dass seit 1999 es US-Banken erlaubt, wieder wahr beides unter demselben Dach zu betreiben. Und zwar wurden etwa Schranken für den Kapitalverkehr nach und nach abgebaut und die Macht multinationaler Finanzunternehmen somit schrittweise erhöht. Die finanzgetriebene Deregulierungsagenda fand in der Aufhebung des Glass-Steagall-Acts in den Vereinigten Staaten durch Präsident Clinton ihren Höhepunkt. Das 1933 während der Großen Depression erlassene Gesetz sah eine strikte Trennung zwischen privaten Kreditgeschäften und spekulativen Investmentbanking vor. Das hebt man auf, braucht man nicht mehr, ist nur eine Schranke, die uns hindert. Babić schreibt, das führt dann zur Weltfinanzkrise 2008, diese Deregulierung. Und man lässt, das ist dann der dritte Punkt der Neoliberalisierung, man erlässt lauter Gesetze, die bedeuten Zölle runter, mehr Direktinvestitionen, möglichst wenige Schranken für Kapital- und Warenverkehr, hat dann natürlich auch eine Internationalisierung der Börse damit vorangetrieben und eine wirklich globale Konzernbildung, die auch jetzt eben so weit fortgeschritten ist, dass jetzt auch ein Donald Trump so viel Dekrete er auch unterschreiben möchte, nicht sagen kann, und jetzt kommen all die Unternehmen bitte zurück, sondern ja, es sind solche eigenmächtige oder am Start auch immer noch gebundene, aber aber Konglomerate entstanden, bei denen man sagen kann, das kann gar nicht mehr so wieder zu schließen sein. Babić spricht von transnationalen Opportunitätsräumen und diese Opportunitätsräume sind schwer wieder zu schließen. Fragt sich nur, wie bröckelt dann die neoliberale Ordnung wann genau? Und er sagte, na ja, es gibt dann verschiedene Faktoren, die dafür sorgen, dass sie bröckelt. Und man muss eigentlich sagen, das ist so eine permanente, ja, man muss eigentlich von von von Kräften sprechen, die sich gleichzeitig zum Teil widerstrebend ereignen. Also für ihn ist immer wieder klar, dass es nicht diese eine Schnittstelle gibt, mit der sich alles ändert. Und genauso gibt es auch nicht die eine politische Maßnahme, bei der man jetzt sagen kann, und das war das Ende der Neoliberalisierung.
Genau, also da ist ja historisch, er geht ja auch durch. Margaret Thatcher war ja Jahrzehnte vor das Ende dieses Glass-Steagall-Acts, wo dieses Trendbankensystem wieder aufgehoben wurde. Dann hat es nur zehn Jahre gedauert, bis 2008. 2008 ist aber dann schon auf einen Gemütszustand gestoßen, in den es plötzlich hieß, ja ja, Demokratie, Demokratie, aber die Rating-Agentur sagt. Ja, so. Und das war dann alles schon etabliert und wurde da angewandt. Und dann hat man diese riesige, nee, wir müssen hier Standortpolitik machen, wir müssen ja auf dem Weltmarkt gut funktionieren, da können wir jetzt nicht Rücksicht auf die Einzelnen nehmen. Und da hat sich das ganze politische Geflecht aus. Die Politik regiert, weil sie ein Mandat hat, das Beste für die Bevölkerung, Gemeinwohl und so weiter. Und die FED kriegt ja noch dieses Mandat für Arbeitsmarkt. Wenig Arbeitslosigkeit ist hier das zweite große Mandat, neben Geldstabilität. Und dann heißt plötzlich, nee, also wir kümmern uns hier nur um den Standort. Wenn wir sehen, dass die Globalisierung über die Stränge schlägt, dann müssen wir genauso billig arbeiten wie die Chinesen. Und dann ist der Druck einfach da. Und über diese Schaffung, diese Niedriglinien und Sektar, ist ja eh diese große Konkurrenz. Also das ist ja dann schon sozusagen eine Landschaft, auf die verwiesen wird mit so politischen Ansagen. Und damit stecken wir jetzt in der Patsche. Die neoliberale Ordnung, wie wir sie hatten, bröckelt. Und dann kommt auch noch der 11. September. Und Adam Toos sagt, wir sind in einer Sackgasse der neoliberalen Globalisierung. Ja. Das ist das Interrelium. Wir sind in einer Sackgasse gelandet.
Denn das ist ja der Punkt, auf den er immer wieder zu sprechen kommt. Und das erinnerte mich auch an eine Salon-Lektüre. Wir haben es mit einer eigentlich sinkenden Produktivität zu tun. Wir haben Überkapazitäten in der Welt. Das heißt, es ist merkwürdigerweise so, dass zwar das eigentlich nach einer Erfolgsgeschichte aussieht, aber plötzlich werden Waren nicht mehr genügend nachgefragt. Ist also das mit dem Wirtschaftswachstum für viele auch lange schon in die Krise geraten und man hat nur noch so ein bisschen Wachstum. Und auch China als der große Antriebsmotor lässt nach und nach doch spüren, dass das nicht mehr so steil bergauf nur geht, sondern eher kontinuierlich langsamer. Und dass man also sagen kann, dass also das Wachstum, das der Neoliberalismus versprochen hat, lange Zeit galt, aber plötzlich nicht mehr. Und zwar nicht im Sinne von D-Crows, man hat sich irgendwie entschieden vom Wachstum abzurücken, sondern es stellt sich nicht mehr so richtig ein. Und wir haben mal über dieses Buch, auch bei Sokamp erschienen, von Aaron Benanuff gesprochen. Der macht auch schon die ganze Zeit diese Überkapazitäten in aller Welt deutlich. Und dass diese Waren ein Abnehmer suchen, Autofriedhöfe und da stehen sie rum und man weiß nicht wohin damit. Ja, also was ist da eigentlich los? Ja, ja. Und das ist ja interessant, dass also da nicht nur Fehleallokationen im Kapitalismus stattfinden, sondern dass es offenbar eine weitreichendere Krise gibt, die sich dann also noch zu verschärfen droht, wenn jetzt andere Schranke noch hinzukommen. Bedeutet also im Ganzen gesehen, dass das neoliberale Versprechen vom ewig wachsenden Kuchen sich nicht mehr einlöst. Jetzt werden viele sagen, von den wachsenden Kuchen haben wir eh alle nicht profitiert. Doch in gewisser Weise haben wir auch profitiert davon, nicht so stark, wie wir es hätten tun müssen. Und da gab es eben dann nicht den Trickle-down-Effekt, da hätte man Radikale umverteilen müssen, da hätte es aber machen können. Jetzt aber stehen wir eigentlich vor der Situation, dass der Kuchen nicht mehr entsprechend schnell wächst. Was bedeutet das denn eigentlich? Na ja, da nehmen Verteilungskämpfe zu und wird plötzlich aber auch das Wachstum, weil es sich eh schon nicht mehr einstellt, nicht mehr als das Premiere von Staaten angesehen, weil auch die sich sagen, wir rechnen ja jetzt nicht mit 5% BEP-Wachstum. Also ist das gar nicht mehr für uns die wichtigste Kategorie. Ich hatte ja im letzten Podcast diesen Clip gespielt von Donald Trump, der sagte, dann kriegen die Kinder halt nur noch zwei Puppen statt 30. Bedeutet ja nichts anderes, als zu sagen, Wirtschaftswachstum ist jetzt für uns gar nicht so entscheidend.
Ja, so und jetzt ist hier wahnsinnig interessant. Also wir haben 2001 Terror, 2008 noch mal Terror und 2016 schon die erste große politische Reaktion darauf, nämlich Take Back Control und Make America Great Again. Also Protektionismus, Rückbezug, so ein Wunsch nach Renaissance, aber bloß nicht drüber reden, weil ist nicht auflösbar inhaltlich, ist einfach nur so ein politisches Versprechen, das nicht aufgeht. Und die dramatische Zeit und deswegen ist es so gut, wenn man sowas in solchen Büchern so spontan historisiert bekommt, man wünscht es einfach, jeden Tag ist Tag eins, Tagesschau zu gucken. Wobei die Tagesschau ist gut, sagen wir mal, Tagesthemen. 2001 Terror, 2008, es erreicht uns alle, also diese Art von Krise.
Mobilien, Finanzkrise.
Genau, jetzt muss der Gürtel enger geschnallt werden. Man verspricht uns noch, dass die Einlagen sicher sind, wie auch immer. Dann nochmal acht Jahre später Brexit und Trump im selben Jahr 2016. Und wir sehen ja 2024 nochmal. Und der Brexit ist immer noch nicht überwunden.
Und dazwischen noch Corona.
Genau. Also es gibt hier keine Verbesserungsgeschichte. Wir sind einfach nur so eine, wir graben uns jetzt ein in protektionistischen Ideen. Und selbst wenn sie zehn Jahre lang gescheitert sind, und man feststellt, ach so, 2014, nachdem Trump schon mal das angegangen hat, und dann eigentlich auch von den, auch wenn sie es nicht offen sagen, aber Republikanern so anerkannt wurde, ja ganz so schlecht war das nicht, was Biden gemacht hat. Trotzdem noch mal umso mehr den dummen Protektionismus. Und Brexit, sagt er hier, ist das Negativbeispiel dafür, wie man sich so einen Wohlstandsverlust einfach durch eine politische Verwirrung selbst an den dringen kann. Und hier ging es erstmal darum, die neoliberalen Ideen, die man hatte und gelebt hat, zu verdrängen. Sie verschwinden aber nicht. Also nutzt man sie zumindest zum eigenen Vorteil. Also haben wir jetzt als großes politisches Projekt eine strategische Selektivität auf die bisherigen Errungenschaften. Also Trump nutzt einfach die Möglichkeit zu sagen, ach so, alle Sachen kommen von außen nach Amerika geliefert. Ja, dann ist die Grenze jetzt mein neues politisches Gefechtsfeld. Und dann kommt einfach ein Zoll. Das wäre gar nicht anders möglich, wenn nicht alles im Ausland hergestellt würde, was Amerika braucht. Nur das ist halt von der Anlage her genauso dumm wie Brexit. Also es ist einfach nicht konstruktiv. Und wir hören ja nachher, wie also prinzipiell es einfach völlig ausgeschlossen ist, dass über Zoll-Motivationen so eine Geschichte wie Apple 25 Jahre in China auszubeulen, das ist einfach, geht überhaupt gar nicht. Also wir haben eigentlich die negativsten Sachen, die wir heute an der Globalisierung immer kritisiert haben, Finanzialisierung, Deregulierung, Flexibilisierung, das plötzlich importiert wird als Fragmentierung und Regionalisierung, Popularisierung, dieser Protektionismus, der sich nicht auszahlt, dass wir plötzlich die Inflation da zuerst nicht unter Kontrolle haben, dann haben wir sie unter Kontrolle und dann machen wir als nächstes ein Zollkrieg, der auch nur alles wieder teurer macht. Als würde man sich die negativen Sachen der Globalisierung nach Hause holen, weil man versucht, sie zurückzudrehen, aber sie lässt sich nicht zurückdrehen, aber die negativen Sachen kommen dann trotzdem bei einem an.
Ja, und dann machen wir auch weiter in dem Fahrwasser.
Also hier wird wirklich deutlich, wie es einfach dümmst möglich gerade ist. Plus, dass jetzt die asiatische Seite noch ihre eigene Globalisierung organisiert. Er kommt auf die Asiatische Infrastruktur Investitionsbank AIIB zu sprechen, die 2015 gegründet wurde, also sozusagen bereit steht für, ja, wenn die sich jetzt mit Brexit und Trumpismus aus dem Spiel nehmen. Das heißt noch lange nicht, dass deswegen das Spiel dann endet. Und große Ärger darüber, dass Deutschland dieser Bank zum Beispiel auch beigetreten ist. Also Frankreich, Großbritannien machen Geschäfte mit dieser asiatischen Investitionsbank. Amerika nicht, da gibt es natürlich große Streitereien. Und der Inflation Reduction Act wird hier nochmal genannt als, ja, da hat noch immer jemand versucht, eine konstruktive Wende zu machen, aber es versandete und er wurde aus dem Abjagd.
Na ja, aus der westlichen Perspektive eine konstruktive Wende, nämlich aus der anderen nämlich gar nicht. Er schreibt ja hier, die AIIB wird als Teil der Projektion chinesischer Wirtschaftspolitik und geökonomischer Interessen und nicht nur als rein globale Institution im Sinne etwa der Weltbank gesehen. Doch nicht nur China trägt als ein geökonomischer Hauptakteur zur Fragmentierung und Regionalisierung der globalen Ordnung bei. Der zuletzt beschlossene US-amerikanische Inflation Reduction Act wird insbesondere in Europa als protektionistisches Instrument im globalen geökonomischen Wettbewerb bewertet. Beispielsweise fasst der wichtige Think Tank Bräugel mit Sitz in Brüssel die Menge und Art an Subventionen für die US-amerikanische Entwicklung und Skalierung klimafreundlicher Technologien in Teilen als klaren Bruch globaler Handelsregeln auf. Also hier könnte man jetzt also mit demselben Argument oder hätte mit demselben Argument Zölle gegen die USA heben können, wie man das dann mit China gemacht hat, weil man da auch sagte, ja, die subventionieren ohne Ende. Das ist ja nicht mehr Level-Playing-Field, auf dem wir uns eigentlich bewegen wollen. Und natürlich gibt es auch eine Geopolitisierung der EU. Dazu sagt er, so sind die Europäische Union und ihre Mitgliedstaaten auf dem Weg, bestimmte Formen wirtschaftlicher Interdependenz einzuschränken oder komplett herunterzufahren, wie etwa die Möglichkeit chinesischer Direktinvestitionen in europäische Infrastruktur. Zugleich will die EU auch künftig ein globaler Handels- und Investitionsriese bleiben, wie beispielsweise die 2021 veröffentlichte Leitlinie der offenen strategischen Autonomie vorgibt. Dort wird die Relevanz offener Märkte und Handelsabkommen mit Regionen wie Lateinamerika oder dem Indopazifik betont, aber eben nicht mit der geökonomischen Konkurrenz aus China oder Rostad. Vergleicht man diese Selektivität mit früheren Politikern der EU wird die strategische Dimension mehr als deutlich. Bis weit in die 2010er Jahre trat die Union noch stets als größter Befürworter eines globalen Level-Playing-Fields ein. Das bedeutet also, egal wo wir hinschauen, wir finden überall eine Geopolitisierung. Und dann kommt er noch, das fand ich besonders aufschussreich, auf die Staatsfonds zu sprechen, denn auch die sind absolutes Zeichen davon, dass ja, Geopolitik eine Rolle spielt, aber im Sinne einer Geoökonomisierung. Er sagt, so haben etwa die Monarchien des Nahen Ostens, wie Katar oder Saudi-Arabien, ihre aus fossilen Gewinnen gespeisten Staatsfonds in globale Aktien- und Immobilienmärkte integriert. Diese Anpassung an die Regeln globalisierter Finanzmärkte verschafft ihnen nun zuvor nicht verfügbare Machtressourcen. Das ist also etwas, dass darüber plötzlich Politik gemacht werden kann. Sie sind, schreibt er, auch politische Player. Sie unterliegen staatlicher, manchmal auch parlamentarischer Kontrolle und handeln nach politisch beschlossenen Investitionsmandaten. Sie stellen neue Staatsapparate dar, die sich unter den Bedingungen neoliberaler Globalisierung herausgebildet haben und nun die geoökonomische Ordnung mit ihrer Macht und ihren Handlungsspielräumen entscheidend prägen.
Er nennt dann auch die Zentralbanken, die zwar klassische Akteure sind, aber sieht man ja bei Trump die großen Versuche, da Powell jetzt loszuwerden und um das auch noch kontrollieren zu können. Die Entwicklungsbanken, die ja sowieso schon immer ihr eigenes, particuläres Geschäft getrieben haben, sich also da auch instrumentalisieren lassen. Er charakterisiert ja dann im Folgenden den Staat als ein neu sich nach außen wendenden Staat und sagt, die Abhängigkeiten zu instrumentalisieren, globale Revalitäten in einem geoeconomischen Wettlauf um Macht zu verschärfen, Einflusssphären abzustecken und technologische Überlegenheiten anzustreben, erinnert stark an vorangegangene Phasen globaler Konflikte.
Ja.
Also hier droht auch einiges und die alle versuch, das irgendwie politisch einzuhägen, also wir haben uns jetzt ja lange lustig gemacht darüber, dass die Personenauswahl nicht besonders glücklich ist, egal nach welchem Politikmodell, Merz, Trump und so weiter oder das, was in Frankreich droht. Die regieren ja dann trotzdem und verschmelzen dann zum Beispiel diese politische und ökonomische Macht in Amerika. Er verweist auf die zweite Amtszeit schon Donald Trumps, die sich jetzt in diesen neuen Technonationalismus zeigt, weil so wie die Norweger ihren Staatsfonds haben, unter Einfluss nehmen oder die Kataris ihren Öl, Geld da jetzt einfach anders investieren, weiß halt Donald Trump zum einen macht er diese materiellen Zölle auf Güter und sagt, da ist ein gigantisches Handelsdefizit. Und dann wird immer so belächelt. Ja, der übersieht ja voll diesen Dienstleistungssektor, dass wir alle abhängig sind von Word und Google und so weiter. Und gleichzeitig denkt man sich so, aber das übersieht der doch nicht. Der stellt die doch in die erste Reihe seiner Amtsentführung und macht da voll den technokratischen, also technokratischen Nationalismus und so weiter. Also es ist schon, wenn man das so ein bisschen abgedroschen, spontan historisiert, also nicht nach Nachrichtenlogik aufgeschlüsselt bekommt, wird einem schon so ein bisschen bange, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, ja. Also für alle, die jetzt sagen, endlich der Neoliberalismus ist vorbei. Ja, schön, kann aber auch immer schlimmer werden.
Bislang sind die Antworten nicht so hoch.
Das ist ja das große Problem, dass ich habe mit Akteuren wie beispielsweise Ulrike Herrmann oder auch Albrecht von Lucco oder so, die finden das Moment irgendwie alle ganz toll, dass endlich mal wieder der Staat durchgreift und dann kommt Pistorius, der hält auch noch eine Rede und sagt noch mal, was Tacheles ist. Diese ganzen Leute haben natürlich sich auch abgearbeitet an dem Neoliberalismus zu Recht auch sehr häufig, haben diese Marktlogiken kritisiert, die wir ja auch kritisieren. Nur weil denn eine Logik nicht mehr greift und nicht mehr da ist, bedeutet das ja nicht, dass die Gesellschaft sich irgendwie über einen Automatismus hin zu einem besseren verwandelt, sondern kann natürlich bedeuten, dass uns jetzt eine ganz andere, noch viel schlimmere Politik droht, bei der man sagt, Mensch, das war aber noch schön, als wir uns über Banker aufgeregt haben, die ein bisschen korrupt waren, darüber aufgeregt haben, dass mal wieder die Reichen keine Reichensteuer bekommen. Es kann natürlich auch ganz anders kommen. Und das sagte er hier ganz klar. Der geökonomische Staat ist keineswegs ein unproblematisches Projekt und ist mit enormen Risiken verknüpft. Eskalation und Wohlstandsverluste sind realistische Aussichten für eine vom Aufstieg des geökonomischen Staates geprägte Politik im 21. Jahrhundert.
Ja, bei der Wahl der Mittel und der Art der Diskussion, nämlich immer eng an Sehgewohnheiten, damit alle wissen, worüber man redet, macht er hier einen ganz wichtigen Punkt bei der grünen Industriepolitik, die nämlich an ihren eigenen Ambitionen scheitern könnte um durchaus den Weg aufzumachen für noch mehr Protektionismus und noch mehr nach innen gerichteten wirtschaftlichen Nationalismus, Babydrill und so weiter und so fort. Und da habe ich jetzt auch die Woche wieder gedacht, ja, das muss man alles wahnsinnig ernst nehmen, denn wir haben jetzt drei Jahre lang eine Diskussion zu Free the Leopard, schickt die Panzer, schickt die Flugzeuge, macht Kram. Und dann stellt sich raus, nee, Nachrichtenlage ist, da sind LKWs, russische LKWs von Russen über russische Straßen gefahren worden. Keiner wusste, was geschieht. Dann ging da oben Dach auf und dann kam eine 800-Euro-Drohne rausgeflogen und zerstörte ein fünf Millionen schweres Flugzeug.
So.
Und selbst das muss man ja noch mal weiter denken. Das ist ja nur die Ansage, das geht. Wir können damit Kriegsmittel zerstören. Nur, man kann die Drohne auch woanders in Russland hinschicken. Also man kann die auch in Industrieanlagen oder was auch immer auf Heizkraftwerke und so.
Das ist das Huty Problem, wie Adam Truss sagt. Diese Verkleinerung des Krieges und Verbilligung des Krieges bedeutet natürlich auch, dass jeder, der ein bisschen Geld auf Seite gelegt hat, jetzt plötzlich auch einen Krieg führen kann.
Genau.
Das bedeutet eine andere Bedrohungslage plötzlich.
Mit ganz wenig kann man ganz schön viel kaputt machen. Und wenn wir aus so einer Status Quo Stabilität herauskommen, wird es brenzlig. Und das, was wir jetzt gesehen haben in den Nachrichten, das sind alles Schiffriss, also LKWs, Drohne, Flugzeuge zerstört. Das ist auch mit sehr vielen anderen, also diese Interdependenzen und so weiter, die man jetzt versucht zu nutzen. Im ersten Anlauf sind alle beeindruckt davon, was das geht. Wir können das SWIFT-System einfach, also Iran, da rausnehmen und dann kann gar keiner mehr eine elektronische Überweisung mit dem Iran machen. Ja, ja, das geht. So, nur da stehen halt alle da und denken, ach, das geht.
Ja.
Und dann plötzlich wendet sich das Blatt und es wird so eingepreist in politische Kalkulation, in so Kabinettssitzungen, wie auch immer. Und dann hat man plötzlich mit gefährlichem Fahrwasser zu tun.
Ich hörte einen Podcast mit einem Ökonom, der über diese Zölle sprach und was dann Europa tun könnte. Und der schlug beispielsweise vor, Europa könnte ja auch PayPal einfach abstellen. Und ich bin direkt zusammengezoggt, weil für uns natürlich als Podcaster, die wir ja in diesen Bezahlungsdienstleistungsdingen drin sind, dann hätten wir ein großes Problem. Da müssten wir irgendwann sagen, wir können das jetzt mit dem Abo nicht mehr alles so machen. Also, man gibt es auch andere Möglichkeiten als über PayPal. Aber PayPal ist schon wichtig für digitale Bezahlung. Soll ich dann sagen, schickt Briefumschläge mit Geldscheinen drin? Also wir sehen dann plötzlich, was das eigentlich bedeutet, wenn man sich auf dieses Spiel einlässt.
Es gab ja diesen frühen Film Das Netz, wo auch jemand plötzlich feststellt, ach so, ich bin abgemeldet. Es gab eigentlich noch gar kein Internet und die haben schon mal gezeigt, wie man so eine Biografie einfach hart cutten kann, indem man das kaum vorhandene Internet ausschaltet und plötzlich strandet man da einfach zivilisatorisch. Dieses Degrowth-Kapitel, wann immer es auftaucht, erwähnen wir es kurz. Es gibt hier auch eins, wir werden gewarnt. Das Ende des Wachstums als Konzept der Moderne wirft allerlei ökonomisch relevante Fragen auf. Produktion und Konsum, gerechte Verteilung, Chancen und Risiken folgt nicht den falschen Ideen, nur weil sie so gut klingen. Organisation und Planung einer Postwachstumsgesellschaft sind daher wichtig, auch wenn Wachstum als Metrik nicht einfach verschwinden wird. Also der Ökonom gibt uns hier kleine Hinweise, so einfach ist das alles nicht.
Ich finde es immer ganz erstaunlich, dass man da von einem Komitee liest, obwohl man sich ja mit Politik beschäftigt, von dem man dann doch eigentlich noch nie gehört hat. Kanntest du das Committee on Foreign Investment in the United States? Nee, so, ich auch nicht. Und dann liest man da aber plötzlich, Investitionsprüfungsmechanismen schränken die Spielräume für Direktinvestitionen signifikant ein. Also es geht darum, wie jetzt verschiedene Länder versuchen, diese Direktinvestitionen anders zu regulieren. Wir hatten ja hier diese Debatten, wenn chinesische Unternehmen plötzlich deutsche Unternehmen kaufen wollen. So, dann gibt es jetzt in den USA dieses Committee und das galt lange Zeit als zahnloser Tiger. Der Ausschuss war 1975 von Präsident Gerald Ford als Reaktion auf das Öl-Embargo arabischer Länder in Folge des Yom Kippur Krieges zwei Jahre zuvor eingerichtet worden. Er wird vom Finanzminister geleitet, in ihm sind mehrere Ministerien vertreten. Auf Empfehlung des Committees kann der amerikanische Präsident zwar spezifische Investitionen verbieten, doch in potenzielle dienstinvolvierte Firmen sollten sich lange Zeit freiwillig bei dem Komitee für eine Prüfung anmelden. Nur wenige Investitionsversuche scheiterten an der ultimativen Maßnahme des Ausschusses. Acht der insgesamt neun Vetus wurden nach 2012 ausgesprochen. So untersagte beispielsweise Joe Biden Anfang 2025 die Übernahme des Stahlproduzenten US Steel durch den japanischen Konkurrenten Nippensteel nachdem das Komitee keinen internen Konsens über diesen umstrittenen Fall herstellen konnte. Die Zahl der untersuchten Fälle ist seit 2005 rasant angestiegen, bis 2018 umsatte 358 Prozent. Das Jahr 2022 hält mit 440 Prozent den bisherigen Rekord an untersuchten Fällen. Die erste Trump-Regierung folgte diesem Trend zur Verschärfung. Also er schreibt dann mal so gerade auf zwei Seiten auf, da gibt es so ein Komitee und die sind jetzt plötzlich nicht mehr einfach so da, um mal pro forma zu prüfen und dann doch alles durchzuwinken, sondern plötzlich wird das richtig relevant. Bedeutet auch, sagt er dann, dass wenn so Mechanismen in sich installiert werden, um Direktinvestitionen oder Zukäufe zu erschweren, Unternehmen gar nicht mehr versuchen, das zu tun oder Investoren gar nicht mehr versuchen, weil sie schon wissen, dass sie eher an so einem Komitee scheitern werden. Bedeutet also, dass hier ein De-Risking schon deshalb stattfindet, weil die vorher sagen, naja, da werden wir eben mit unserem chinesischen Unternehmen nicht draufkommen, also probieren wir das gar nicht. Das heißt, hier passiert auf der geoökonomischen Ebene verdammt viel, ohne dass man da jetzt viel von mitbekommt sonst.
Ja, ich fand ja auch interessant, dass es in New York ein Bundesgericht für Handelsfragen gibt, ganz spezifisch. Das von vielen, da habe ich auch so einen deutschen Podcast gehört, kannest du das Gericht? Nee, kann ich nicht, habe ich noch nie gehört. Und die machen aber plötzlich einen Beschluss, dass der Trump einfach verbietet, dieses Notstandsgesetz anzuwenden. Weshalb diese ganzen Zölle erst mal nicht gelten sollten. So, und dann ist der Entferner ist, ah ja, wir haben da so ein Gericht und ja, typischerweise befasst sich das nicht mit präsentialer Politik, so, aber in dem Fall dann doch, um einfach zu sagen, nee, das kann nur der Senat machen. Hier liegt kein Notstand vor und so weiter. Und dann hat man plötzlich aus so einer völlig, ach ja, okay, Richtung so eine Eskalation. Ja, am Ende wird es aber beim Supreme Court landen. Ja, also völlig neuer Einflug schneisen in so juristische Diskussionen, wo es plötzlich abgehandelt wird. Also, immer wieder Überraschungen, die kommen. Er kommt ja dann auf die Politik zu sprechen. Die Growth immer schwierig in der beschriebenen Problematik, ja. Also wir müssen irgendwie aus die Klimafragen lösen.
Er sieht das ja als eine ganz existenzielle Krise an, da ist hier kein Autor, der sagt, Klimawandel lösen wir immer mal später.
Also da schlägt Volljahrgang 90 durch.
Das ist absolut das Entscheidende. Und er erwähnt ja auch hier China im Jahr 2023, installierte China mehr Solarkapazität als die USA in ihrer gesamten Geschichte. Also über diese Dimensionen sprechen wir jetzt gerade. Und das bedeutet ja auch, wenn wir jetzt über diese Geoökonomie sprechen, wie könnte denn eigentlich eine vernünftige, also das beantwortet er jetzt nicht, aber wie würde eigentlich eine vernünftige Politik aussehen? Also man kann natürlich sich fragen, was, wenn es nicht in dieser Weise konfrontativ a la Donald Trump sein soll, wie findet man da eigentlich einen vernünftigen Weg, also damit zu agieren? Weil das ja so hochkomplex ist, dass man jetzt auch sich schwer tut, da eine Antwort zu finden und sagt, ja wir halten am Washingtoner Consensus fest oder so. Das wäre ja nicht denkbar.
Er macht es ja über Bande, aber da finde ich es schon sehr deutlich. Also zum Klima sagt er solche Überlegungen, also Degrowth und so weiter, sind immens wichtig, da die Persistenz einer wachstumsorientierten globalen Ordnung ohne entsprechendes Wachstum, also wenn man einen Segenwunder hat, der nicht entsprochen wird, ihre Legitimität zu verlieren droht und so populistisch in ihren reaktionären Kräften Aufwind verliehen. Er sagt, jetzt könnte er, aber er ist ja recht deutlich geworden vorher im Text, wie wichtig ihm das ist. So, also das wäre da jetzt zum nach 2016 und allen Erfahrungen noch mal in die Trump-Richtung abbiegen. Und auch in Polen gab es jetzt wieder so einen ganz knappen Sieg von solchen, wo einfach nur, nee, wir machen idiotische Politik. Wir sind einfach nur dagegen, wir finden es alles scheiße. So, und jetzt kommt ja sein großes Politikkapitel, also Abschnitt 4 im Buch, wo er darauf verweist, diese Ordnungsprinzipien aus der historischen Herleitung. Also, dass wir mal ein Zeitalter hatten, in dem Demokratie und Marktwirtschaft mit dem Volk und für das Volk organisiert wurde und darauf eine neoliberale Globalisierung, die das Volk nur noch so als Schwungmasse brauchte und eigentlich immer so belehrend. Wir erklären euch das jetzt mal. Wir geben euch nicht wirklich eine Handlungshoheit, sondern Regierungserklärung. Wir müssen jetzt Deutschland in den globalen Weltmarkt führen und der globale Weltmarkt ist aber nicht deutsch. Deswegen greifen da politische Folgen nicht so wie wir. Also da ist einfach keine Demokratie. Man hat also das Volk schon verabschiedet, bevor man jetzt eine Herausforderung hat, die man eigentlich mit dem Volk für das Volk, ja das Volk ist wütend. Darauf müssen wir reagieren. Und das ist natürlich ein starker Hinweis, finde ich, dass wir die Entgrenzung des politischen Gedankentums und diese Verabschiedung, dieses Wegschieben des Volkes und alle Anliegen, die davor getragen werden, schon absolviert haben. Das ist nichts, was jetzt passiert, sondern das ist auch schon eine Hinterlassenschaft aus dem vorherigen Zeitalter. Er kommt hier auf Martin Wolf, ich kenne ihn nicht, der legendäre Kommentator der Financial Times, der schon von schwieriger, aber wertvoller Vermählung komplementärer Gegensätze, also Demokratie und Kapitalismus zu verkoppeln, war ein Wunder. Eigentlich bräuchten wir jetzt wieder ein Wunder, es daraus zu lesen, um das Volk da wieder einzufangen, ein echtes Angebot zu machen. Ich erinnere immer wieder gerne an Osla van der Leyen, kommt ins Amt und sagt, Klima ist wichtig, weil das ist die Wachstumsstrategie. Da können wieder alle partizipieren. Und gleichzeitig gucke ich aber auf Arte, diese Doku über Moneyland, 90 Minuten über die Deutsche Bank, wo einfach klar wird, 2008 und die Folgen hat einfach 16 Billionen Dollar gekostet, den westlichen Demokratien. Also Geld, das einfach in den Haushalten und in den Kalkulationen, ne, ne, wir sind jetzt so verschuldet, das können wir alles gar nicht mehr machen und so. 16 Billionen Euro wurden einfach rausgenommen. Und das war sozusagen, ist die Ziffer an diesem, das Volk spielt hier keine Rolle. Das möchte was, kriegt es aber nicht. Das äußert Wünsche, wir können die leider nur enttäuschen. Es finden Wahlen statt, sorry, aber wir wissen, morgen seid ihr alle unzufrieden und so.
Das ist das Erstaunliche sogar jetzt, das ist vielleicht noch mal eine neue Dimension. Wenn man die Wahlprogramme liest, ist das sogar schon so. Also sonst hatte man ja noch in den Wahlprogramm eine Versprechungen, die sich nicht einlösten, sondern jetzt haben wir nur noch Wahlprogramme gehabt. Ich habe sie alle gelesen, in denen stand, überhaupt wird weniger, wird unangenehmer. Wir versuchen es mal, dass es sicherer wird, aber so genau wissen wir auch noch nicht, wie. Und das ist ja tatsächlich extrem frustrierend, dass sich da nichts einstellt. Plus dann noch ein nicht mehr wachsender Kuchen, von dem offenbar auszugehen ist, bedeutet also, wenn nicht radikal umverteilt wird. Und so viel ist ja dann auch nicht da, um dauerhaft zu suggerieren, dass der Kuchen wächst, sondern irgendwann müsste der Kuchen wachsen, um besser umverteilen zu können. Also das führt tatsächlich in eine Sackgasse. Also anders kann man das gar nicht beschreiben. Und diese alten Paradigmen, die funktionieren nicht mehr. Er zitiert hier den New York Times Kolumnisten Thomas Streetman, der sagt, noch nie haben sich zwei Länder bekriegt, in denen McDonalds-Fialen waren. Kann man heute auch nicht mehr sagen. Dann wird irgendwo der McDonalds sich dicht gemacht. Dann gibt es in Russland kein McDonalds mehr.
Keine Ahnung, wie das jetzt da gerade ist. Wird da ein bisschen umkodiert und dann macht man anderseitig weiter. Das heißt, man ist da in einer Situation, wo die Politik Wachstum nicht mehr versprechen kann und das auch eigentlich nicht mehr tut. Und wir haben das mit Trump dann gerade gesehen. Der dann sagte, ja, da muss man mal verzichten. Und andere sind ja in dieser Verzichtslogik schon drin. Und hat aber auch sonst nicht irgendetwas anzubieten. Das ist ja auch nochmal interessant in dem Punkt, was er zur FDP sagt. Er hat dann nochmal so einen Absatz zu und sagt, ich vertrete hier also die Auffassung, dass Politik und Ideologie in geoökonomischen Zeiten eine instabile und offene Anpassung an sich rapide verändernde Realitäten in der globalen politischen Ökonomie reflektieren. Typisch neoliberale Ideen wie die Senkung von Unternehmenssteuer, der Rückbau von Wohlfahrtsstaaten oder die Unterordnung demokratischer Prinzipien zugunsten globaler Märkte werden zwar noch vereinzelt vertreten, aber kaum noch als kohärentes Wahlprogramm vorgetragen. Ebenso saßen bis Mitte des letzten Jahrzehnts überzeugte neoliberale politische Kräfte in wichtigen Industriestaaten wie Deutschland, den USA und Großbritannien an den Hebeln der Macht. Wo noch vereinzelte Stimmen mehr einen schlanken Staat oder vertiefte globale ökonomische Integration fordern, sind sie diskursiv und machttechnisch schon nicht mehr bestimmend. Der Wahlkampf zur Bundestagswahl 2025 verdeutlicht diesen Wandel. Die noch am ehesten mit neoliberalen Kernbotschaften angetretene FDP flog aus dem Parlament. Jetzt kann man sagen, ja hurra, sagen wir auch. Aber das Angebot, das jetzt da ist, ist auch keines.
Genau und das Angebot ist aber in diesem Kapitel vollgerichtig. Also er zitiert Politikwissenschaftler Daniel Deutnay, EU, also Deutnay wahrscheinlich, und George G. John E. Kenberry, die ich alle nicht kenne, aber die in den 90ern schon darauf hinwiesen, wenn die staatsbürgerliche Identität und die liberale Weltordnung auseinanderfallen getrieben über diese wirtschaftlichen Entwicklungen, die politisch unterfüttert, untermauer, das ist uns das Wichtigste, bitte leiste deinen Beitrag. Dann ist völlig klar, dass sich eine identitätsstiftende Kraft entfaltet, die dann der Politökonom Steven Gill, den ich auch nicht kenne, als, warte, wie geht der Gedankengang? Also wir kommen aus einer neoliberalen Identitätsprojekts, das dann über kapitalistischen Fortschritt, globale Marktintegration, fortschreitenden Konsum, dann mit den Widersprüchen aufgeführt und es führt zu faschistischen Prädispositionen. So, sehr kompliziert. Also nicht kompliziert als Gedankengang, aber jetzt von mir ein bisschen mühsam herausgearbeitet. Ich habe ja sehr kritisiert, dass Isabella Weber es selber im Text nicht so deutlich sagte, aber in der Überschrift beim Freitag und bei Krautreporter und so stand, faschistische oder wir brauchen eine antifaschistische Wirtschaftspolitik. So, nun lässt sich das aber durchaus schreiben. Also man könnte auch, anders als meine Empfehlung, zu sagen, ne komm, wir machen mal nicht antifaschistische Wirtschaftspolitik, sondern wir sagen, wir wenden uns wieder konstruktiv der Bevölkerung zu und machen Angebote nicht nur in Sachen Konsum, sondern auch Perspektive des eigenen Lebens und so. Es ließe sich durchaus bei der Überschrift bleiben, faschistische Wirtschaftspolitik.
Antifaschistische.
Ja, oder dass man jetzt beschreibt, was gegenwärtig ist und sagt, das ist eine faschistische oder eine faschistisierende Wirtschaftspolitik. Dazu gibt es hier Denkangebote aus den letzten 30 Jahren. Also eigentlich aus der noch neoliberalen Zeit, in der die Globalisierung funktionierte und man aus dem Büro raus in die Bahn zum Stadion, zum Westernhagen-Konzert ging und dann abends bei RTL die Nachrichten geguckt hat und so. Alles angelegt. Also hier gibt es genug Autoren, wo man nachlesen kann, dass das, was jetzt gerade passiert, wirklich keine Überraschung sein sollte. Vor allem nicht, wenn man jetzt sagt, okay und dann kam März und sagte, ich halbiere die AfD und dann ist sie aber plötzlich verdoppelt. Und wenn dann März einfach sagt, ja, da ist die Ampel schuld. Nee, das sind hier größere Linien. Und das kann man rauslesen. Und das, was März jetzt im Angebot hat, wird die AfD weiter stärken.
Natürlich.
Also das wäre hier so ein klaren, aus der spontan historizierten, aktuellen Zeit abgeleiteten Weg, wirklich rein in diesen Faschismus, der eben jetzt wieder mit diesem, wie er ihn vorher beschrieb, handlungsfähigen, nach außen sich wendenden Staat, der im Grunde einfach nur sein Waffenarsenal gerade aufstellt, aus den Trümmern der Globalisierung. Also die Gemeckerlage macht keine gute Laune.
Ja, ich sehe aber auch nicht den Weg jetzt gerade. Also ich finde jetzt auch nicht, das will ich ihm jetzt auch nicht vorwerfen, aber Babić zeigt jetzt auch nicht einen Weg auf. Er macht so eine Minimaldefinition, was er von Politik möchte. Und er sagt, in einer geökonomischen Welt sei diejenige Politik funktional, die Gesellschaften wirtschaftlich, sozial oder sicherheitspolitisch resilienter gegen Kriseneinschläge macht. Und das ist ja schon eine Formulierung, die fast nur aus der Negation heraus also dann besteht. Also das heißt, da, wo es die Politik schafft, die Krisen abzufedern oder nicht die Bevölkerung so stark spürbar werden zu lassen, da ist sie eine erfolgreiche Politik. Und das ist aber noch nicht ein Projekt, das sich ja ins Positive wendet. Also es ist ja kein Projekt, das sagt, und dann können wir den und den Fortschritt erreichen oder so. Und ich würde sagen, dass mit dieser Minimaldefinition es nicht möglich ist, diese Entwicklung hin zum Faschismus abzuwenden. Also ich glaube nicht, dass wir da an einen Punkt kommen, dass die Leute sagen, ach, das ist aber schön, dass ich resilienter bin oder der Staat ist resilienter. Man kann natürlich sagen, ja sozialer Abstieg sorgt dafür, dass der Faschismus blüht. Ja, okay. Aber ich glaube, man muss schon noch mal ein anderes Projekt formulieren können. Und jetzt hat man natürlich die Situation, wenn man sagt, Wirtschaftswachstum ist so eine Sache, wird es nicht in dem Maße geben, wie wir das in den chlorreichen Jahrzehnten einmal hatten. Dann müsste man sagen, also was definiert dann jetzt Wachstum für uns neu? Würde natürlich bedeuten, das Leben besser zu machen, Europa in ein Museum zu verwandeln oder in einen großen Kinderspielplatz oder beides, oder was du auch immer da nennen willst. Dieses Projekt wird dabei ja auch nicht irgendwie vorangetragen und würde natürlich sich auch nur finanzieren, wenn man auf eine starke Kooperation setzt. Also dass wir jetzt zum Beispiel ja keine Ostwirtschaftspolitik mehr haben, damit meine ich jetzt nicht, wir fangen jetzt wieder an mit Russland da weiter zu machen, wo wir aufgehört haben, sondern sich natürlich auf eine Ostpolitik zu konzentrieren. Der Osten meint ja sehr viel mehr als Russland. Und zu schauen, wie man da wieder in eine wirkliche Kooperation miteinander kommt, das wäre ja etwas, womit man zumindest dem Geopolitischen in der Geoökonomie etwas ausweichen könnte bzw. es drosseln könnte. Und das ist ja ein Punkt, bei dem ich sage, wenn man jetzt diese geoökonomischen Verhältnisse erstmal als gegeben hinnimmt, dann sind wir ja verloren, weil wir ja dann nur noch über den nicht mehr größer werdenden Kuchen streiten und extrem viel an Ressourcen brauchen, um in diese sicherheitspolitischen Debatten uns einzumischen. Also bedeutet aufrüsten, bedeutet in einer Weise, auch Leute dazu zu bringen, sich verpflichten zu lassen. Bedeutet dann aber auch natürlich zu sagen, dass man die ganze Zeit für irgendwelche höheren Interessen sich zurücknehmen muss, verzichten muss. Also das ist mir ja jetzt keine Perspektive, bei der ich sage, die ist in irgendeiner Weise positiv. Und wenn jetzt Babić sagt, das sei so ein Interregnum und als solches sei das ja auch endlich, dann kann ich sagen, na ja, das ist so eine Aussage. Also alles ist irgendwo Interregnum. Aber das heißt ja dann nicht, dass es nicht auch in diesem Interregnum zur Katastrophe führen kann. Also das Dritte Reich war auch ein Interregnum. Aber nun ja, ging ja lang genug. Also die Katastrophe kann ja sehr schnell kommen. Von daher denke ich mir dann, wo führt uns dieser Begriff Geoökonomie noch hin, wenn wir sagen, dieser Keynesianismus nach 45 führt nicht weiter. Das sagt er ja auch. Also er sagt ja jetzt nicht, so die Wagenknechtüren zu sagen, wir müssen mal wieder dahin, wo wir in den 60er, 70er Jahren waren. Das sieht er auch nicht als Möglichkeit.
Also er sagt, wir hatten Zeitalter, in denen es auf mehreren Dimensionen in dieselbe Richtung ging und die waren deswegen relativ stabil. Und jetzt könnte man zum Beispiel auf dein Einwand sagen, ja, das Dritte Reich war vielleicht kein Interregium, weil es ist an der eigenen Dummheit gestolpert, zu viel kriegerische Expansion zu machen, weil inherent intern war das durchaus ein auf Dauer angelegtes Projekt, das die Bevölkerung ja so weit auch mitgemacht hat.
Ja, das stimmt.
Es wurde halt von außen dann zertrümmert, nachdem es anfing von innen nach außen Trümmerlandschaften zu erzeugen. Und jetzt ist ja die Frage, wie kommt man zu so was wieder zurück? Und das erste Angebot, das wir haben, und da macht er ja einen interessanten so eine Charakterisierung der Trump-Wähler. Also Trump regiert. Trumpismus ist das. Es ist aber nicht der Aufstand der Abgehängten, sondern es ist der Sieg der Superreichen. Es ist also genau das Gegenteil von dem, was versprochen wurde. Aber Wahlen werden ja davon, also der Erfolg in Wahlen hängt davon ab, was man verspricht und ob die Leute dem folgen. Dass nach den Wahlen etwas passiert, ist schön und gut, aber dann sind halt gerade keine Wahlen. So, man hat halt jetzt vier Jahre Trump. Und da schreibt er ja ganz interessant. Und da wird ja auch so ein bisschen aufgelöst, warum er immer so vom falschen Populismus schreibt. In dem Fall auch wirklich. Hier steht es im Text mal so, wie ich es mir durchgehend gewünscht hätte, nämlich falsch in Anführungszeichen und dann Populismus. So, die Diagnose des falschen Populismus wird dann deutlich, wenn die entsprechenden Parteien und Bewegungen Politik tatsächlich gestalten. Also wenn sie in die Regierung kommen und man plötzlich sieht, ach, mit diesem Personal und mit dieser Politik, und dann stellt man so nach drei Monaten fest, ah ja, Elon Musk geht jetzt und einen Tag später auf Twitter schlägt er schon aus gegen die zentrale gesetzestechnische Sache, die Trump da wichtig ist mit seinem Big-Beauty-for-Bill. So, was eben hier bedeutet. Der Aufstieg des falschen Populismus ist also nicht unbedingt, wie liberale Eliten gern behaupten, auf das Nichtwissen oder die Ignoranz oftmals weniger gebildeter Schichten zurückzuführen. Also wir dürfen nicht einfach sagen, die sind alle dumm, die Wähler. Vielmehr verschmilzt die materielle, politische und kulturelle Entfremdung, die haben wir ja beschrieben, der neoliberalen Jahre, mit den Disruptionen, Verlusten und Unsicherheiten der geoökonomischen Welt. Für seine Wähler überwiegt die revolutionäre Attitüde des falschen Populismus der Anspruch der Erneuerung, die heraufbeschworene Zerschlagung des als untragbar empfundenen Bestehenden und die rücksichtslose diskursive Zerfleischung des vermeintlichen gesellschaftlichen Konsens, seine fehlerhaften Problemdiagnosen und seine dokumentierte inhaltliche Substanzlosigkeit. Was er bedeutet? Wir haben es ja vorhin schon beschrieben. So wie die GUP überhaupt nur wieder erfolgreich wurde, weil sie mager zugelassen hat. Also mit einer Attitüde es vorgetragen hat. Und in jeder Diagnose man ja durchaus folgen kann. Aber halt die politischen praktischen Folgen einer Amtsführung in diesem Stil funktionieren halt nicht. So bräuchte man halt jetzt wieder eine revolutionäre Attitüde. Wir haben ja Abundance gelesen, die ein echtes Angebot macht, wo man eigentlich daneben steht und sagt, nee, wie soll denn das gehen? Ist das nicht viel zu teuer? Eine Billion für Familien, jedem ein Haus bauen, das Versprechen verwirklichen, egal wie, das ist die Aufgabe der Politik, ihm das Haus und so weiter. Aber diese revolutionäre Attitüde ist halt erforderlich. Und wenn man dann immer hyper-vogue daneben steht und sagt, nee, nee, das ist alles viel zu viel, das ist ja viel zu teuer und wer soll denn das bezahlen? Können Sie das mal bitte refinanzieren? Wo sind der und so weiter? Dann klappt es halt nicht. Sondern hier muss jetzt eine revolutionäre Attitüde hin, die genauso über die Stränge schlägt und anschlussfähig ist in der Bevölkerung und nicht wieder zertrümmert wird von Sandra Maischberger, die nochmal, aber sollten wir nicht und so weiter, muss man das hier nicht differenziert betrachten.
Das meint ja jedoch Inlandspolitik. Da sind wir ja noch nicht bei der Außenpolitik. Denn die Außenpolitik müsste ja dann eine sein, die auf solche Kooperativen setzt, dass man weiterhin zum Beispiel so gut Handel treiben kann, dass auch ein bisschen Geld ins eigene Land fließt. Also man kann ja nicht alles nur über Kredit machen. Ja, weil momentan wirklich nicht.
Naja, was heißt momentan? Also die EU ist halt so aufgestellt, dass diejenigen, die die Geschäfte da führen, sie ausprägen können, wie sie wollen. Und solange der Tür und Tor geöffnet ist, für...
Aber du meinst nicht, die momentane EU-Regierung, dass die darauf aus ist, uns Abundance zu realisieren?
Nein, aber die EU, wie sie ist...
Könnte das als Institution?
Die EU, wie sie ist, hat ja seit Jahren eine Diskussion zum Thema Arbeitnehmerrechte. Bis hin zu sozialpolitischen... Also sie hat ja gar keine sozialpolitische Dimension. Das ist aber ihr nicht aufgrund der Verträge versagt, sondern es ist einfach Tagesordnung.
Genau, das könnte sie sein. Wir wissen aber, da sind dann viele Nationalstaaten, zum Beispiel Deutschland, nicht so dafür, dass die EU diese Kompetenzen bekommt und deswegen findet das dann nicht statt. Aber ich sehe auch, dass das grundsätzlich in dem institutionellen Rahmen denkbar ist. Nur ich frage mich jetzt gerade, was daraus folgt. Also diese Idee von Abundance ist ja so eine sehr stark kainsianische eigentlich, dass man sagt, jetzt bauen wir, jetzt machen wir, jetzt bringen wir den Laden auf diese Weise voran, stärken damit auch die Binnenwirtschaft. Aber das würde ja tatsächlich eine politische Revolution bedeuten, die ich nirgends sehe. Also das meine ich jetzt nur.
Wir sehen doch gerade eine politische Revolution.
Auf der anderen Seite sehe ich das, aber ich sehe ja auf der Seite. Also ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich den Clip hier gespielt habe von Philipp Manow, der saß auf dem Podium und hat gesagt, er wurde von Journalisten gefragt, wie kann denn das überhaupt sein? Warum sind die Populisten so erfolgreich? Die haben doch nur Slogans und keine Lösungen anzubieten. Und dann sagte er, ja, aber die anderen haben halt nur keine Lösungen anzubieten.
Genau.
Und nicht mal Slogan zu nehmen.
Die Attitüde fehlt.
Und das ist ja der Punkt jetzt, wir haben hier über das Buch von Marc Schiritz diskutiert, zu dumm für die Demokratie. Und der würde ja sagen, ne, die Leute sind zu dumm für die Demokratie. Und deswegen müssen wir auch die Institutionen so resilient machen, dass sie auch vor der Demokratie, vor dem Volk beschützt werden. Und das ist ja eine ganz heikle Tendenz. Und das können wir ja auch in gewisser Weise schon in Rumänien und sonst wo erleben, wo man dann die ganze Zeit sagt, ne, da gab es Einflüsse von Russland oder so. Wir müssen mal aufpassen. Lieber wiederholen wir nochmal eine Wahl oder erklären sie für ungültig und all das. Ich kann ja diesen Impetus in gewisser Weise nachvollziehen. Und ja, es ist natürlich problematisch, wenn man Parteien wählen kann, die die Demokratie wirklich unterminieren wollen. Und das ist ja auch der Fall in Deutschland mit der AfD und all das. Aber was ja gleichzeitig damit ausgesprochen wird, mit diesem, wir müssen das ganze Resiliente angehen. Und das ist ja wirklich auch so eine EU-Geschichte bis hin zu Trusted Flagger und all dem. Bedeutet natürlich, dass sich die Revolution auf der anderen Seite, die du jetzt gerade ausgeweilt hast, auch völlig verhindere. Also es geht dann wirklich darum, eigentlich so vorzugehen, also das wollen jetzt gerade die Schützer der liberalen Demokratie, so vorzugehen, wie die Demokraten bei ihren Wahlkämpfen vorgehen, nämlich nicht Demokratie zuzulassen, sondern lieber zu sagen, wir dichten das ab. Was? Joe Biden soll senil sein. Wir werden der Presse erklären, dass das Gegenteil der Fall ist und wir ziehen das durch. Und genau diese Position ist ja gerade sehr stark, weil man sich hat in den Kontrast bringen lassen oder in dieses Alternativdenken, entweder liberale Demokratie. Und das bedeutet aber dann, alles gut finden bis hin zu Ursula von der Leyen oder autoritäre Regierung, China, Putin, Katar.
Also auf dem Papier.
Und das ist ja das große Problem, dem wir jetzt gerade sind. Weshalb alle revolutionären Rufe ja gleich eingehegt werden in dem Sinne, wo das gefährdet aber die liberale Demokratie.
Also ich nähe mich zunehmend, da wir ja immer wieder auf dieses, im Grunde ist es ja da, ich versuche ihn mal abzuspielen. Rutger Brechmann hat uns ja vor die Frage gestellt, warum kommen immer nur, wie wir jetzt von Jordan Peters in den Grundbegriff gelernt haben, psychopathische Parasiten, die ein System für ihren egoistischen Zweck missbrauchen, überhaupt nur noch an die Stellen, wo es große Entscheidungen zu treffen gibt. So, diese Frage allein so als, ja ja, das ist eine legitime Frage anzunehmen, hat ja schon so ein inhaltliches Anhängsel, dass wir von diesen Leuten, die also über ihren Egoismus, über überhaupt nur Methode schaffen, dass wir von denen keine Gemeinwohl-Inhalte erwarten können, was ja ganz einfach bedeutet. Und jetzt hat uns Babić hier die revolutionäre Attitüde untergejubelt. Wenn Kevin Kühnert im Fernsehen sitzt und vor einer Bundestagswahl sagt, ich finde, BMW sollte verstaatlicht werden, und dann kommt Sandra Maischberger und sagt, aber hören Sie mal und so weiter, dann muss man ihr sagen, Sie sind ja auch Fake News. Sie vergauceln ja dem Publikum vor, dass sie an ihrer Seite stehen, weil sie im Wohnzimmer immer so zwei Meter nahe Nähe aufbauen. Aber Sie mit Ihren 40.000 Euro im Monat, Sie lügen ja hier einfach. Natürlich wäre das genau richtig.
Ich vermute auch, dass das mehr sind als 40.000, ja.
Sehr viel mehr, dass sie ja 200 Sendungen pro Jahr jetzt selbst am hart über fair Sendeplatz. So, also die revolutionäre Attitüde ist kein Verweis auf die Inhalte, sondern ist ein Verweis darauf, mit welcher Attitüde man sie vorbringt. Und wenn dann, wir haben es ja gesehen, Heidi Reichinik bei Markus Lanz sitzt und sagt, ich finde dieser Mieterschutz ist irgendwie gut. Und dann kommt von Markus Lanz wieder Worte. Dann muss man einfach sagen, Herr Markus Lanz, Sie sind einfach in dem Falle kein psychopathischer, aber ein Parasit. Sie haben sich hier und Sie wissen selber nicht warum. Wahrscheinlich einfach, weil Sie gut aussehen und gerade Sätze sagen können, weil Ihre Hemmungshämmer im Gehirn gut funktionieren und Sie deswegen etwas längerfristigen Gedanken auf die Straße kriegen. Das ist Ihr Erfolgsrezept. Damit sind Sie zum größten Grundeigner in Südtirol geworden. Wir können mit Ihnen nicht ernsthaft über die Mieten reden. Hören Sie auf, Scheiße zu erzählen. Und dann muss man in die Beschimpfung rein und mit ausgestreckten Zeigefinger auf die Kameras zeigen und sagen, das ist der Lügenapparat, der uns in diese Misere geführt hat. Das ist diese Attitüde. Was wir aber haben in Deutschland ist, dass Kevin Kühner fünf Jahre nachdem er dieses Statement gemacht hat, aufgibt und dann drei Wochen später noch mal in so einer Abend-Talkshow sagt, ja, das ist echt scheiße und das ist alles und so weiter.
Und der Zeit nochmal erzählt, dass er jetzt auch mit dem FDP-Band zusammen ist und man muss auch die andere Seite gut kennenlernen. Und dann denke ich mir so, ja, das kann man privat halten, wie man will, bedeutet aber politisch nichts.
Aber ich glaube, hier gibt es Benchmarks.
Ich finde ganz erstaunlich, wo wir jetzt gerade hier gelandet sind, weil die Leute bekommen einen Eindruck von diesem Buch, dass dieses Buch glaube ich nicht vermittelt.
Aber es lässt das zu.
Genau, wir lesen es heute heraus. Also ich will sagen, dieses Buch ist nicht revolutionär in irgendeiner Weise aufgestellt.
Es gibt zu bedenken, wie der Recht im Populismus ist. Marxistischen Theoretiker und so.
Aber es ist wirklich kein Buch, das jetzt sagt, und so müsste jetzt die revolutionäre Politik aussehen. Aber du leitest das davon ab und ich gehe da auch mit. Und ich glaube, dass das wirklich das entscheidende Problem ist, dass die ganze Zeit in dem Modus, wie wenn die verfahren wird und dass sich alle, die in irgendeiner Weise eine progressive Politik anstreben, sofort dort einbinden lassen, damit das alles vernünftig klingt und damit man auch nochmal bei Maischberger artig behandelt wird und auch vielleicht nochmal am nächsten Tag gelobt wird von Mickey Beisenherz im Podcast. Also es geht ja alles so, dass man darauf eingehegt wird. Und wenn man noch irgendwie ausbrechen kann aus dem Diskurs, dann mit irgendwelchen Zeichensetzungen, weiß ich nicht, irgendeine grüne Politikerin zieht ein Pulli gegen Polizisten an und dann reden da drei Wochen die Leute drüber. Aber wenn es wirklich um die politische Auseinandersetzung geht, sind alle sofort wahnsinnig fromm, ziehen sich zurück und sagen, ne, das müssen wir noch mal reden und ich muss jetzt mal gucken, ob ich die Zeit parat habe für den Mietendeckel. Man muss dann wirklich auf den Angriffsmodus übergehen. Das würde das natürlich eigentlich bedeuten.
Ich sehe ehrlich gesagt die Linke Fraktion im Bundestag schon sehr im Angriffsmodus. Mir gefällt das sehr und sie sehen ja auch, dass es sich für sie in der Unterstützung ausmalt. Klar läuft das jetzt erst mal über Mode. Jemand hat seine Basken-Mützke. Cansin hat jetzt, Kukturk, die in ihrem Buch haben wir ja auch gelesen, so einen mit Klebestreifen Palästina auf ihrem Hemd stehen.
Das habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Das war gestern und da wurde sie eben des Saals verwiesen von Julia Klöckner. Und da stand halt einfach nur Palästina drauf. Also es ist so zu sagen.
Ach so, das ist schon ein Statement.
Ja, man braucht so sehr viel Last, die man mitbringt auf Empfängerseite, um das überhaupt zu problematisieren. Und das sind alles so Sachen. Klar, das ist alles so anfängerhaft und es sieht so ein bisschen verspielt aus. Aber es geht ja jetzt darum, sich langsam vorzuarbeiten, um einfach so verschiedene Benchmarks, die man sich selber setzt. Wenn wir 13 Prozent haben und dann Action machen einen einen Monat, haben wir danach immer noch 13 oder vielleicht sogar mehr und dann echte Bilanzen ziehen und das ganz kalkuliert eskalieren. Jedenfalls müssen wir immer Form und Inhalt parallel denken.
Aber ich sehe jetzt zum Beispiel ja bei der Linken, wenn ich das mal kritisch einwenden darf, keine besonders gute Aufstellung in Sachen Außenpolitik. Also wenn sich die Linke darauf beschränkt, Jan van Aken in der Talkshow zu schicken, der sagt, wir brauchen härtere Sanktionen gegen Russland. Dann ist das für mich auch ein bisschen dürftig. Nur ich glaube, dass schon es Wähler gibt, und ich habe übrigens mit sehr jungen Wählern gesprochen vor einigen Tagen, dann ist das schon etwas, was umtreibt, dass also Krieg und Frieden in dem Sinne da keine Rolle spielt, außer vielleicht auf den Nahostkonflikt angewendet und da ja auch nur in Teilen. Wenn jetzt hier Babić sagt, geoeconomische Auseinandersetzung, Technologien, Marktanteile, Lieferketten und Infrastrukturen werden nicht mithilfe protektionistischer Industriepolitik und der Abschirmung von Schlüsselindustrien ausgetragen, sondern sind schon aufgrund ihrer Voraussetzungen globalisiert. Verflechtung wird somit zum Brandbeschleuniger des Rechtsdrucks und ökonomischen Nationalismus in vielen westlichen Ländern. Dann frage ich mich auch über Texte Rich und all das hinaus, wo ist die tatsächliche politische Kraft, ob in Deutschland oder EU-weit, die sich gegen diesen ökonomischen Nationalismus wendet? Und diese Kraft sehe ich nirgends.
Und ich sage dir, die braucht auch niemand gerade. Wir haben es hier gerade mit einer innerlichen…
Auf dem Bavar ja schon. Wir sind da ja in einem doch sehr heiklen Gefilde.
Ja, ich sehe es trotzdem, also ich sehe es ja wirklich ganz anders. Denn wir haben es hier mit einem Buch zu tun, dass uns die Welt, die globalen Verstrickungen, die Geschichte einmal runterdampft, auf ein Niveau, das wir verstehen. Wir haben in Deutschland eine Avantgarde, die Tageszeitung liest. Das sind nie mehr als drei, vier Millionen Menschen gewesen. Von dieser Avantgarde weiß ich aus den eigenen, aus meiner Zeit bei der FAZ, was Außenpolitik und Reader Scans angeht, von dieser Avantgarde 5 Prozent der Bevölkerung. Interessiert sich 5 Prozent für Außenpolitik. So, wenn Außenpolitik jetzt häufiger in Politik ist, weil es immer heißt, Putin macht irgendwas und sofort schlägt sich das bei uns nieder. In China ist ein Virus und sofort haben wir innenpolitische Probleme. Dann sind das innenpolitische Probleme, die auch nicht über Bande über Außenpolitik zu lösen sind, sondern das sind innenpolitische Probleme. Weshalb ich, jetzt mal beim Verweis auf Die Linke, Die Linke braucht jetzt keine Außenpolitik. Niemand interessiert sich dafür. Es fordert niemand. Und ehrlicherweise, ich möchte, dass Die Linke ihrem Thema treu bleibt und sagt, Miete, schick uns deinen Mietvertrag, wir geben dir Hinweise. Wie auch immer.
Gut, aber wir haben doch jetzt durch dieses Buch gelernt, dass wir plötzlich Kräften ausgesetzt sind, die nicht nur die Gestalt unseres Vermieters annehmen, sondern plötzlich bedeuten, da droht was von außen.
Ja, aber das ist...
Da muss ich mich ja in irgendeiner Weise zu verhalten. Sage ich dann, okay, ich mache einfach das, was Ursula von der Leyen gerne machen möchte, nenne das nur ein bisschen anders und kritisiert sie auch nochmal für Frontex oder habe ich wirklich eine Alternative im Angebot?
Das ist alles egal. 80 Millionen Deutsche, diejenigen, die politisch aufgewühlt sind, bezahlen zu viel Miete. Wenn der Mietpreis hoch ist, ist denen die Außenpolitik egal. Wenn der Mietpreis sinkt, sind sie politischer zufriedener, egal was in der Außenpolitik los ist.
Aber wir haben gerade geklärt, dass die Außenpolitik uns noch...
Ja, Außenpolitik, also sehr viele Probleme, die kommen, werden importiert. Die kommen aus einer globalen Verflechtung.
Wir sind ja eine Exportnation, also die Außenpolitik ist schon relevant. Also Interesse für die Außenpolitik meint ja nicht, dass ich jetzt erwarte oder davon ausgehe, dass Leute morgens am Frühstückstisch sitzen und alle über die Außenpolitik diskutieren. Das war nie so gewesen und wird auch niemals kommen. Was aber der Fall ist, ist, dass wenn außenpolitische Entscheidungen getroffen werden, wie z.B. Protektionismus, Zollpolitik etc., kann das heißen für eine Exportnation, dass Papa und Mama am Frühstückstisch plötzlich sagen, wir wissen nicht, ob wir nächste Woche noch einen Job haben.
Ja.
So und da ist die Außenpolitik.
Alles richtig. Das Buch verweist ja auch auf Krisen, Krisen, Krisen, Covid, Inflation, Kriege. Das ist alles Außenpolitik. Am Ende ist alles Außenpolitik. Aber.
Ja, eben.
Aber. Das ist ganz wichtig. Ich meine, selbst wenn man jetzt Außenpolitik sagt, hat man plötzlich so eine Sphäre zu Innenpolitik.
Also, beim Mieten kriegst du es noch ziemlich wirklich ohne Außenpolitik hin. Klar, es gibt da so ein paar Konzerne und so. Aber der Mietmarkt ist ja, weil es eine Immobilie ist, ein ziemlicher Binnenmarkt. Insofern kannst du da tatsächlich viel ohne Außenpolitik machen. Aber sonst, würde ich auch sagen, ist alles andere Außenpolitik, gerade wenn man von einem Exportweltmeister spricht.
Ja, es gibt jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder du hast einen Wähler vor dir, so wie Hans Zimmer, die Doris, für die er Musik macht, weil er irgendwann mal so eine Doku gesehen hat, wo so eine Doris aus dem Krankenhausdienst nach Hause kam und meinte, ich brauche jetzt einfach Unterhaltung. Und dann sagt er sich, für die mache ich Musik. Ich verstecke sie, sie sieht einen schönen Film, die kriegt die Musik wahrscheinlich gar nicht mit, aber sie wirkt trotzdem, so ungefähr. Also für diese Doris, für diese Persona, wie wir jetzt gelernt haben, Oma Erna ist ja auch so eine Persona. Also eine idealtypische Figur als Individuum, repräsentativ für das ganze Publikum. Wenn du das außenpolitisch behälligst und denen irgendwas erklärst mit, wir müssen jetzt mal in China und es ist aber gut, dass die Merkel, was er unter uns gesprochen hat, in der ganzen Pram.
Die brauchen es nicht zu erklären, die sollen das machen.
Die machen das nie. Also wenn das die Erwartung ist, dann ist es ausgeschlossen, dass sich nochmal was zum Besseren wendet. Wirklich. Außenpolitik ist tot. Die ist nur lebendig da, wo es wirkmächtig ist, da wo echte Politik ist. Aber in der Ansprache an den Wähler haben wir doch gesehen, Donald Trump erzählt einfach jeden Scheiß und den Wählern ist alles. Und mit alles meine ich 100 Prozent. Egal, die wollen revolutionäre Attitüde. Und die schlägt sich nicht nie damit, aber jetzt haben wir einen außenpolitischen Punkt gemacht, sondern was kostet das Ei im Supermarkt? Und zwar in dem Supermarkt, der mich interessiert, den ich zu Fuß erreiche. Mich interessiert nicht der Supermarkt in San Francisco oder in New York oder sonstiges, sondern mein Supermarkt. Natürlich ist das eine außenpolitische Frage. Aber setzt du dich in dein Auto und sagst, also wenn mir nicht der BMW-Chef selber als der letztverantwortliche juristisch verhaftbare Mann mir erklärt, dass ich mein Auto jetzt nicht in Luft auflöst und vorher an falschen Stellen Benzin explodiert, fahre ich nicht los, dann wirst du nie losfahren. Also diese Idee von, wir könnten jetzt Avangandistisches übertreiben, ist inhaltlich zu betonen, sagt ich. Nein, es geht um die Attitüde. Und mit Attitüde ist gemeint Methode.
Okay.
Scheiß auf die Inhalte.
Wir sprechen jetzt über zwei verschiedene Dinge. Das eine ist ja von dir beschriebene Strategie, Wählerstimmen zu bekommen.
Aber darum geht es in diesem Buch. Es geht ja darum, warum hat der falsche Populismus so viel Erfolg, der macht später auch Außenpolitik. Das ist ganz richtig. Aber im Erfolg, warum er erfolgreich war, spielt Außenpolitik keine Rolle. Wenn du ansetzt bei der Außenpolitik, zäumst du das ganze Pferd falsch auf. Du musst da anfangen, wo Trump erfolgreich war. Attitüde, Ansprache.
Das will ich auch gar nicht in Zweifel ziehen. Wenngleich es ja auch eine erfolgreiche Politik gibt, von innenländischen Problemen abzulenken, durch eine Außenpolitik. Also das gibt es auch.
Er macht ja im März gerade sehr erfolgreich, der Außenkanzler.
Der versucht das nämlich jetzt gerade, weil er hier natürlich gar nichts machen kann und selbst seinen reichen Freunden eigentlich keine großen Steuergeschenke machen kann. Hier eröffnet sich ja ganz am Ende eine optimistische Lesart, die sagt, naja, wenn so eine Regionalisierung auch stattfindet, Lieferketten wichtig werden, die neu organisiert werden müssen, könnte dies die Nachhaltigkeit und Fairness des globalen Handels verbessern oder den neoliberalen Fokus auf Effizienzsteigerung zugunsten einer verstärkten Rolle von Lokalität und der Kreislaufwirtschaft verschieben. Nun, jetzt ist die Frage, sehen wir das irgendwo? Also, dass das generell möglich ist, das will ich ja nicht leugnen. Aber man hätte auch sagen können, also da, finde ich, wird es ein bisschen beliebig. Ich kann natürlich auch sagen, der Neoliberalismus ist eine wunderbare Möglichkeit mit seiner Idee der Globalisierung, weil wir endlich den anderen Menschen nahe kommen und deshalb den Klimawandel als unsere höchste Aufgabe ansehen. Also, so könnte ich auch den Neoliberalismus interpretieren. Das heißt, was ich hier so als Optimismus aufgemacht finde, ist ein bisschen hilflos, was vielleicht gar nicht dem Hautor anzugreiten ist, sondern weil die Situation so fatal ist. Dann heißt es noch, was spricht für eine solche optimistische Lesart? Nun, zum einen wurde das Verhältnis von Kapitalismus und Demokratie bereits mehrmals neu verhandelt. Die Zähmung des globalen Kapitalismus nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg und die folgenden goldenen Jahrzehnte des kensianischen Massenproduktionen und des Massenkonsums wiesen zwar allerlei ökonomische und ökologische Macht- und Gleichstellungspolitische sowie kulturellen Probleme auf. Progressive Kräfte heutzutage sollten daher auch nicht versuchen, diese oft verklärten Phase globaler Entwicklung irgendwie zurückzuholen. Aber dennoch zeigt sich, dass man also das Verhältnis Demokratie Kapitalismus verbessern kann. Ist das etwas, wo wir sagen, das macht mir jetzt so wahnsinnig Mut, dass es das mal gegeben hat. Also erst mal muss man sagen, war das ja fast in der Geschichte des Kapitalismus oder es war eine Anomalie. Also so war er davor und danach nicht. Und jetzt kann man sagen, ja, aber er war dann mal so. Also warum sollte er nicht noch mal so sein? Ich sehe aber hier den fundamentalen Unterschied, dass als diese Keynesianische Politik erfolgreich war, der Kuchen auch so stark wuchs, dass man sich andere Fragen gar nicht stellen musste, sondern es lief ja super. Da, wo er nicht mehr wächst, wird Keynesianische Politik meines Erachtens besonders schwer. Und an diesem Punkt stehen wir jetzt gerade. Und deswegen sind auch diese Versprechen, die gemacht werden gerade auch von der Linkspartei, ich will die jetzt gar nicht besonders kritisieren, nur weil du die jetzt so exponiert hast, sind diese ja sehr häufig auf Umverteilung aus. Und ich bin sehr für Umverteilung. Das Problem ist nur, dass Umverteilung ja sagt, wir agieren mit dem Vorhandenen. Also was an Geld da ist, gucken, ob der eine zu viel hat, dem nehmen wir was ab. Wenn du aber wirklich progressive Politik dauerhaft gestalten willst, musst du auch Wachstum in irgendeiner Weise haben. Damit meine ich vielleicht jetzt nicht nur das BEP-Wachstum. Aber du musst schon den Kuchen vergrößern können. Also nur mit der Umverteilung allein, bei vielleicht sogar noch einem schrumpfenden Kuchen, wird man in eine fatale Situation sehr rasch geraten. Weil auch dann das auf Zukunft ausgerichtete Projekt in dem Sinne nicht mehr da ist. Dann ist wirklich Musialisierung aber im Sinne von Stillstand, Status quo, irgendwie Verteidigend erhalten. Und da sehe ich das große Problem. Und das ist aber auch eines, das die Linke gar nicht so leicht lösen kann, weil sie selbst natürlich weiß, von der doch jetzt recht großen Gesamtkrise, in der sich der Kapitalismus weltweit befindet. Und ich würde hier auch nicht sagen der Neoliberalismus, sondern wirklich der Kapitalismus als solcher. Und diese Krisenhaftigkeit ist aber nicht jetzt das revolutionäre Moment meines Erachtens, sondern jetzt gerade das Moment der Regression, auch weil die anderen Antworten nicht da sind. Und auch wenn die Linkspopulisten jetzt tatsächlich es schaffen würden hegemonial zu werden, wären ihre Lösungen auch tatsächlich momentan nicht besonders weit tragend.
Ja, also alles ja, aber ich höre in deinen Antworten noch sehr viel Sehgewohnheiten aus eigentlich vergangenen Zeiten. So. Ja, ich glaube, statt irgendwo in der Ferne ein außenpolitisches Problem zu identifizieren und sagen, das müssen wir jetzt mal lösen, dann wird alles besser. Würde ich sagen, nein, es ist wirklich ganz woanders. Wir haben jetzt neue Statistiken. Ich lese gleich den Satz vor, der mir in diesem Buch am Ende im Finale wirklich wahnsinnig gut gefällt, der sehr viel zu denken gibt und dann sein Lösungsangebot. Wir haben erste Studien, wir haben schon ein bisschen darüber gesprochen, dass wir so sagen, die jungen Männer driften alle voll nach rechts und die jungen Frauen aber genau ins Gegenteil. Also wir haben so eine neue Unvereinbarkeit im Gemütszustand der Jugend. Und offenbar scheint es nochmal, ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich es gehört habe, sogenannte Gegenwart wäre so ein klassischer Kandidat dafür, aber wer auch immer, dass man sich nochmal genauer anschauen muss diese Corona-Jahrgänge. Also dass man wirklich so ein Jahr im Alter heute die 20, 21-Jährigen differenzieren muss mit, die Jüngeren driften noch härter in so eine, ich radikalisiere mich im Grunde im Internet. So, also ich falle voll drauf rein, da ist Mark Zuckerberg, ich will mir eigentlich nur die Fotos meiner Freunde angucken, aber jedes dritte Video ist, irgendwer stirbt gerade, irgendwer stürzt ein Fenster runter, irgendwas ist, ich bin emotional erregt und auf diesem Level möchte ich gern alles, meinen ganzen Medien konsum, und der ist aber zehn Stunden am Tag. Der driftet einfach ein Teil einer jungen Generation voll ab, während so ein anderer, und das ist eben nicht nur Gender, sondern das ist auch so ein bisschen die Corona-Differenz, die noch reinspielt und so, und die anderen sagen, nee, ich kümmere mich hier um mich, mir sind meine Freunde wichtig, ich soll hier arbeiten, das Land verteidigen, was ist das für ein Scheiß? Also so Konzepte, die einfach gar nicht mehr verstanden werden, wenn irgendwer kommt, und das hören wir ja gerade bei Ole auch in der Diskussion, dass dann relativ viele junge Leute so für Deutschland kämpfen, also kämpfen ist sowieso schon mal ein Konzept, und Deutschland, was war Deutschland noch mal? Ach so, das Land, in dem ich lebe, ganz vergessen, so ungefähr, ja, so ich bin noch nie im Internet, so. Und jetzt schreibt er hier, beinahe zwei Generationen in den reichen kapitalistischen Demokratien des Westens sind in einer Welt politisch sozialisiert worden, die nur wenige attraktive und populäre politische Projekte zu bieten hatte. Wir übersehen so ein bisschen, weil wir eine sehr alte Gesellschaft sind, in der 60-Jährige mit 55-Jähriger bewusster Lebenserinnerung immer noch den Ton angeben, dass diese Verknüpfung aus Demokratie und Kapitalismus irgendwie von Bedeutung wäre. So. Das können die noch behaupten. Das fällt ihnen auch immer schwerer, da noch Worte für zu finden. Es ist im Grunde eine große Lüge. Ja, also das mag für die so sein.
Also doch, hast du unsere Autoren zu unrecht kritisiert. Blüthorn und Selk.
Sehr zurecht kritisiert, aber anderes Thema.
Demokratiedämmerung und so weiter.
Ich wiederhole das nicht. Also wir haben heute eine jetzt eben dritte Generation, die wirklich anders auf die Welt schaut. Also wirklich anders. Für die, und damit meine ich jetzt, für die ist 2001 vor ihrer Geburt. Für die ist Hitler schwarz-weiß. Das ist nicht zu unterscheiden von einer Statue von Aristoteles oder so. Also das ist einfach, alles ist weg. Für die ist Gegenwart und Zukunft was ganz anderes. Wir hören ja hier schon, wer übers Klima spricht. Und da ist einfach Jahrgang 90. Der ganze Text ist super abgeklärt, super aufgeklärt. Er macht sich da Gedanken. Er geht da so in Themen rein, wo man so merkt, ah ja, du hast ja noch nicht gelebt. Das ist wirklich ein neuer Einschlag. Für dich ist eine Regierungserklärung von 1999 einfach historisches Material. Dafür gehst du ins Archiv. Das ist nicht nur Erinnerung, die man noch so hat vom Fernsehen gucken oder so. So, und er schreibt übers Klima wirklich sehr anders. Und er schreibt auch über Umverteilung sehr anders, weil für Leute, die noch nicht 50, 60, 40 Jahre Medienerfahrung haben, sondern die jetzt gerade den Fernseher einschalten, weil ihre Oma das noch guckt, und die sehen da einfach den reichsten Mann der Welt, der für 100.000 tote arme Kinder verantwortlich ist. Die schleppen da kein Gedankenapparat mit, der das nochmal irgendwie versucht, über eine alte Geschichte reinzunormalisieren oder so. Für die ist einfach völlig klar, Reichtum ist evil. Der amerikanische Präsident wird von der ganzen Welt gehasst. Jeder Reiche, der berühmt wird, wird in dem Maße, wie er berühmt wird, verhasst. Und jede Statistik zeigt das. Elon Musk war noch nie so berühmt wie heute. 90 Prozent der Amerikaner wissen, wer das ist. Und er wird von 75 Prozent abgelehnt, von 60 Prozent gehasst. Und da ist auch keine Renaissance möglich, dass er jetzt die nächsten fünf Jahre noch mal das nächste Tesla, ich rette die Welt wundern oder irgendwas. Diese Geschichte ist jetzt durch. Und das sind die Neuen so wirkmächtig wie damals Demokratie und Marktwirtschaft. Und es schlägt sich in Sonntagsreden über Jahrzehnte nieder. Und Steinmeier versucht, das immer wieder an seine Predigten unterzubringen. Die neue Sehgewohnheit ist, amerikanische Präsidenten hassen wir. Superreiche töten die Ärmsten und so weiter und so fort. So und da entsteht anderes. Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass wir noch mal jetzt nach ein und zwei Generationen, eine dritte Generation macht, die sagt, ja, aber das mit Demokratie und Marktwirtschaft war schon voll gut. Also irgendwie hat die Geschichte ja doch was zu bieten. Nee, das glaube ich nicht.
Aber es gibt ja jetzt nicht eine Ablehnung der Demokratie bei jungen Leuten, oder?
Aber hallo.
Also wenn du jetzt von den Rechten, also ich meine nicht die Rechte.
Nein, ich meine auch junge Frauen, die genau wissen, auf die Demokratie kann ich nicht setzen. Ach okay, das ja. Das ist irgendwas, davon habe ich nichts zu erwarten.
Da hast du vollkommen recht. Und das ist mir natürlich auch schon aufgefallen, dass es vielleicht noch einen instrumentellen Umgang mit der Demokratie gibt, aber dieses Sonntagsreden-Demokratie-Ding.
Das ist nur noch Schulunterricht, Textbuch, Sonntagsrede. Weißt du, wo man das auch findet?
Schulunterricht, Textbuch. Oder manchmal so, wenn man Jusos trifft. Weil die versuchen, noch mal so diese alte Bundesrepublik aufleben zu lassen. Man hat dann es mit 22-Jährigen zu tun, die aber mit einem reden.
Die machen sich auch außenpolitische Gedanken.
Genau, die reden aber auch so, als hätten sie eben noch mit Helmut Schmidt telefoniert.
Genau, ja, ja.
Und für die sehen sich auch so irgendwo zwischen Helmut Schmidt, Giovanni di Lorenzo und weiß ich nicht wem. Und die machen dann eine große Außenpolitik dann. Aber klar, die Frage ist nur, wer wird am Ende in der Gesellschaft tonangebend sein?
Genau.
Und da ist natürlich das Ding, dass diese Leute, die noch alte Bundesrepublik spielen, auch gerade in den jungen Kader natürlich ganz nach vorne gestellt werden. Wir haben es ja gerade bei den jungen Grünen gesehen, dass die, die sich also nicht mehr auf das Spiel eingelassen haben, die Organisationen verlassen haben oder dann auch verlassen mussten. Und dass dann sofort Leute nachrücken müssen, die Renate Künast genehm sind. Und ich würde sagen, wenn man Renate Künast genehm ist, ist man auf jeden Fall schon mal die falsche Person für alles, was du da jetzt für die Zukunft ausgemalt hast. So und das bedeutet, dass wir möglicherweise eine noch größere Kluft bekommen zwischen jenen, die repräsentieren und denen, die eigentlich repräsentiert sein sollten. Weil natürlich diese Leute, die du da gerade beschreibst, sich zwar bereit sind, direkt politisch zu organisieren in Gewerkschaften oder sonst was, vielleicht noch, ja, aber den Schritt in die parlamentarische Demokratie oder so finden die fast absurd. Und sie haben ja auch recht damit. Ich will das hier ganz ausdrücklich sagen. Also ich will hier nicht sagen, Mensch, das ist aber schade und nochmal sagen, seid ihr denn zu dumm für die Demokratie? Nee, die sind eigentlich zu klug für die Demokratie, müsste man sagen.
Ja, ich sehe ja so ein bisschen diese Gemengelage aus Parlamentarismus und Abendstagesthemsendung. Ist eine Hinterlassenschaft aus dieser Demokratie und Marktwirtschaft Zeit, die sich längst überlebt hat. So wir wissen doch, wie die AfD mit dem Parlament umgeht. Da werden nur noch so Snippets produziert. Da zeigt man sich vor dem Adler und die große kleine Rede. Also die große Rede ist nur noch 30 Sekunden lang und so weiter und so fort. So und jetzt sagt er ja, so wie du jetzt auch schon so die großen Diskrepanzen aufgemacht hast zwischen den Repräsentierenden und den Repräsentierten, je nachdem in welche Richtung das Pendel schlägt, gibt es zwei Wege. In vielerlei Hinsicht schreibt er, könnten ähnliche Kräfte in Bewegung, die 2020er und 2030er Jahre bestimmen, die bereits ein Jahrhundert zuvor gewütet und eine globale Ordnung in Trümmern hinterlassen haben. Also wir sehen ja ein vielerlei Ländern. Bislang ist das so Iran und Afghanistan. In den 60er Jahren sind die Fotos kaum zu unterscheiden von Leipzig und Bremen. Und heute ist da einfach gar nichts mehr. Also es ist einfach ein Länder im, also im Iran auch nicht allzu sehr, aber in Afghanistan ist einfach, das ist keine Zivilisation. Wir kriegen gerade noch in die Augen zu verschließen. Aber das droht hier auch. Also nach dieser Wahl in Polen bin ich mir auch nicht so sicher, ob es wirklich gar keine schießende Auseinandersetzung zwischen Deutschland und Polen gibt. Und wir sind dann völlig überrascht.
Wie meinst du denn das jetzt?
Naja, also die Polen, diese deutsche Legende, dass in Polen durch irgendwelche komischen Kräfte, immer weil die Landbevölkerung das so will, so diese Kaczynski Gang regiert, aber eigentlich sind das alles pro Europäer. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass das immer noch so eine Sehgewohnheit deutscher Journalisten, die beim Deutschlandfunk auch schon seit 30 Jahren arbeiten ist, im Sinne von, wenn es wirklich harte Fragen gibt, sind sie schon Europäer.
Das ist ja eher so eine Sicht der jungen Leute. Also das würde ich sagen...
Ja genau, das ist die Sicht der jungen Polen auf dem Lande, so wie in Ostdeutschland auch.
Nein, was du jetzt gerade da den Journalisten in die Schuhe schiebst, das würde ich aber auch den jungen Journalisten in die Schuhe schieben. Also die jungen Journalisten sind ja da ganz... Also glauben ja wirklich, dass Polen quasi die Rettung für die EU sein wird. Also wenn du auch wie...
Welches Polen, wann, also jetzt gerade?
Ja, die sehen zwar durchaus das jetzt dann kritisch und sagen, schade hat wieder nicht geklappt mit einem progressiven Kandidaten. Aber wenn du jetzt auch dieses Böhmermann-Video über Polen, wie Polen aufrüstest oder so siehst, dann hast du da so eine ganz klare Ausrichtung. Ich würde sowieso sagen, der junge Journalismus hat eine ganz klare Ausrichtung zu osteuropäischen Ländern, um zu sagen, das ist die Zukunft der EU. Und da würde ich immer in Frage stellen, ob das wirklich dann die EU ist, die wir mal meinten.
Also ich wiederhole nicht nochmal, was ich gerade eben schon zum Journalismus sagte. Und ehrlicherweise, wenn man sich anschaut, mir gibt die allgemeine Bevölkerung Recht, was irgendwelche Journalisten zu irgendwas sagen, interessiert immer weniger Leute.
Ja, ich wollte dir nur sagen, dass diese Rekrutierungsprinzipien gerade sehen und viele entdecken da jetzt plötzlich auch ihre eigenen Wurzeln und so weiter. Und das hat echt so eine so eine so eine interessantes Fall, was da so, dass dann auch gerne Dinge übersehen werden. Also auch Fragen des Rechtsrucks zum Beispiel dort.
Hier müssen wir jetzt irgendwann mal ganz große Punkte machen, also wirklich Haken dran, dass ein 23-jähriger Volontär beim Bayerischen Rundfunk nochmal den drei Minuten Jubelkommentar über Israel schreibt, weil das Christian Nietzsche gefällt, ist für mich kein Beispiel mehr für irgendwas Repräsentatives irgendwo. Das ist nur noch im Rahmen des Bayerischen Rundfunks. Das ist In-House-Kommunikation. Das interessiert mich nicht. Das interessiert auch sonst niemanden. Das ist egal. Ja, also das ist diese Avogad-Scheiß, das ist wirklich egal. Hier geht es jetzt darum...
Aber jetzt musst du noch mal sagen, was du da meintest mit einer schießen Auseinandersetzung.
Na ja, dass die Polen wirklich Deutschland angreifen und ich meine jetzt nicht im Sinne von...
Wie kommst du auf die Indie?
Dass die Polen als polnisches Parlament entscheiden, wir fühlen jetzt wie der Krieg, sondern das ist eine gewaltsame Auseinandersetzung von und das haben wir im Osten auch, da überfällt man sich jetzt schon gegenseitig und da gibt es Wehrsportgruppen und da wird organisiert und das kann sich hochschaukeln und am Ende... .heiß es die Deutschen da drüben, die kommen immer zum Einkauf und die schießen jetzt tot. Irgendwie sowas, ja.
Okay, also deine Befürchtung ist, dass paramilitärische Einheiten sich dort bilden und...
Das ist ein Gemütszustand, der durchaus eine politische Dimension hat.
Okay.
Also der dann von Kaczynski und so weiter, von diesen ganzen Leuten auch benutzt wird. Das haben wir jetzt im Wahlkampf auch gesehen. Ich empfehle sehr, sehe ich mal die Wortlaute, wie man über Deutschland redet in Polen. Also es ist einfach grotesk, dass die deutsche Bundesregierung da gar keine Rücksicht drauf nimmt und bei dem knappen Wahlergebnis ist Dobrindt schuld. Dobrindts, ich schließe hier die Grenzen, sollen auch die Polen selber mit den Ausländern und so weiter. Das ist dieser kleine Knackpunkt gewesen, der in Polen dazu führte, dass die sagten, also wenn die Deutschen so mit uns umgehen, ja, das ist steile These, aber bei dem knappen Wahlergebnis und bei der krassen Thematisierung, dass man nicht länger an Deutschlands Schicksal...
Ja, ich will dir aber gerade ein Beispiel mal machen. Und zwar ist das ja doch interessant mit den Polen, denn die haben ja eine unglaubliche Erfolgsgeschichte vorzuweisen. Für die hat ja tatsächlich... Wir haben das Ende der Sowjetzeit Wohlstand gebracht. Die Integration in die EU Wohlstand gebracht. Und zwar in einem unglaublich starken Ausmaß. Und auch so sehr, dass ja auch die Peace-Partei durchaus ja Sozialpolitik gemacht hat. Also es war ja jetzt nicht alles nur Austeritätspolitik und schlanker Staat. Klar, wir wissen, wie wir dazu zu stehen haben, zu dieser Partei, aber es ist ja keineswegs so, dass wir jetzt hier es mit einem Land zu tun haben, das als Globalisierungsverlierer gesehen werden kann.
Gar nicht.
Ganz im Gegenteil. Und trotzdem haben wir diesen Rechtsruck jetzt wieder erneut. Und es gab da mal kurz so ein Aufatmen, da ist nicht so schlimm gekommen da. Und das sind ja auch jetzt keine linken Kräfte gerade an der Regierung gewesen. Und jetzt haben wir schon wieder den nächsten Rechtsruck und man weiß nicht, was als nächstes kommt. Und wir haben tatsächlich auch in der Landgegen so eine Xenophobie, die sich ausbreitet, die auch hin zu einer wirklichen Brutalisierung führt. Und das ist ja doch auch erstaunlich, dass, obwohl es wirtschaftlich besser ging, deutlich besser ging, das in diesem Maße stattgefunden hat.
So und das liegt auch daran, dass man sich zum Beispiel als EU-Kommission und damit sind vor allem die Mitgliedsstaaten gemeint, gegenseitig auf der Nase herumtanzt, weil man immer glaubt, man könnte die kleinen Errungenschaften, die eigentlich für alle da sind, noch mal gegeneinander für sich selbst zum Vorteil nutzen. Weil eigentlich müsste die Konsequenz sein, zum Beispiel für Ungarn, raus aus der EU. Und zwar nicht, weil Ungarn sich da und dann doch noch mal so klein, sondern weil die EU einfach selbstsicher entscheidet, so nicht. Ihr könnt so nicht teilnehmen. Ihr könnt neue Entscheidungen treffen, aber die Entscheidung muss immer ganz oder gar nicht sein. Ihr könnt nicht immer ein Veto von 27 einlegen und ausnutzen, dass wir hier so einen Einheitsabstimmungs, dass eh ein Fehler war, so zu machen. Und es gilt genauso auch für Polen. Wenn die Polen solche Präsidentenwahlen machen, dann ist das einfach auch ein Zeichen für die EU. So, aber derzeit, und das ist eben dieses Problem, ohne revolutionäre Attitüde, und die würde ich auch da gerne sehen, hast du halt immer so ein, ja komm, zwei Jahre lang kriegen wir die guten alten Errungenschaften noch in die Zukunft gezogen. Wir geben uns noch mal Mühe. Wir probieren es noch mal, und dadurch hast du so eine langsame, stetige Zertrümmerung, das einfach eine ordentliche Aufrechterhaltung hat.
Und wir sind ja jetzt hier mitten im Feld des geoökonomischen Diskurses, wir müssen bald zum Schluss kommen, aber das ist so interessant mit Polen deshalb ja auch, weil ja Polen für viele, konservative und auch liberale, bis hin in linke Kreise, man kann das ja dann bei Böhmermann sehr gut auch nachvollziehen in diesem Video, wie die so drauf sind, ist Polen die Avantgarde in Sachen Sicherheitspolitik, Aufrüstung, Wehrpflicht und und und finden. Es gibt so einen richtigen Polen-Hype, möchte ich sagen, der bis in linke Kreise hineingeht und zugleich haben sie aber dann die anderen geoeökonomischen Faktoren mit drin, dass sie sagen, naja, also jetzt diese rechte Regierung, die bringt aber dann auch wieder ganz viele Probleme, wenn die sich sträuben bei anderen europäischen Fragen. Es stellt sich natürlich so vieles dann plötzlich in Frage gestellt dadurch, dass wir da eigentlich jetzt sehr gut sehen, wie heikel das jetzt ist, weil natürlich zum einen gerade alle sagen, die jetzt so ein bisschen progressiv irgendwie so drauf sind, also im Sinne von Slavo-Ukraini und so, jetzt Polen ist die Avantgarde, während man aber zugleich nicht von Avantgarde reden kann, wenn die die ganze Zeit rechte Politiker wählen. Und da sind wir dann schon in dieser Gemengelage, die hier in dem Buch immer wieder beschrieben werden.
Ich warne aber nochmal davor, wenn du immer so von linken Kreisen, du meinst linke Kreise, die sich medial exponieren, sei es mit 500 Followern auf Instagram. Die sind nicht repräsentativ für irgendwen. Die Bevölkerung denkt anders. Du hast eine Wehrpflichtsdiskussion, die es medial komplett entkoppelt. Von dem, was allgemein gedacht wird. Du hast eine, unterstützen wir die Ukraine, wenn ja wie, komplett entkoppelt. Das haben wir ja betont in den letzten Jahren. Und so eben.
Das ist, wir haben ja, wir sind ja eingestiegen. Also vor dem Salon haben wir über Biden gesprochen und sagen, der CNN-Journalist legt ein Buch vor, in dem er aufschreibt, was die normalen Amerikaner seit Jahren gedacht haben. Joe Biden wirkt irgendwie dement.
Ja.
Das haben alle gedacht. Und dann vier Jahre später schreibt der Journalist auf, ich habe was rausgefunden, der war irgendwie nicht mehr so ganz bei der Sache.
So, und jetzt kommen wir wieder mit dem menschlichen Spekulieren. Du erinnerst dich, Daniel Gerlach redet darüber, wie es in Gaza gerade zugeht, obwohl er keinen Journalist Zugang hat. Man kann ja menschlich spekulieren, wie es da zugeht. Einfach davon abstrahieren, dass man es gerne operationalisieren würde, aber man sieht eine Landschaft, in der alle Häuser zerstört sind und man weiß genau, ich brauche jetzt keine empirische Sozialforschung, um herauszufinden, wie es den Leuten in Gaza geht. Ich kann es menschlich spekulieren. Ich möchte also einen Punkt machen, der ganz wichtig ist, denn ich sage, ich möchte jetzt keine mediale Realität da bieten, sondern ich sage einfach nur, das Buch am Ende resoniert sehr mit dem, was ich in meinem Kopf wiederfinde und auch in meinem Umfeld sehe. Also, Sarkasmus ist viel größer als man glaubt. Die Leute sind zynisch, sie hinterfragen sich da selbst, es sind verschiedene Suchbewegungen statt, wie man sich das erklärt. Man versucht schon, so einen ironischen Einschlag zu finden, aber wie auch immer, die Leute haben die Nase voll, sage ich mal so. Jetzt ist die Frage, an welchem Punkt kann und es wird für heute, es wird dann ganz schnell normalisiert, aber noch ist der Punkt nicht da. Es wird eine revolutionäre Attitüde geben. Die Frage ist nur, wo. Beim Klima ist sie gescheitert. Keiner interessiert sich fürs Klima. Es gibt aber ein Thema, für das sich die Leute interessieren. Und hier steht jetzt bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, das ist ein bisschen aus dem Kontext, aber ein progressives, globales, politisches Projekt kann dafür an mehreren Punkten ansetzen. Geradezu obszöne ökonomische Ungleichheit ist ein solcher Punkt. So, und ich möchte das, auch wenn man immer noch in diesem Zeitalter ist, wo das ein bisschen ach du Naiveling und so weiter. Aber wir hatten jetzt, und das fällt sehr mit dem neoliberalen Zeitalter zusammen, Samine Christiansen, Frauentausch, RTL 2, und der ganze Kram, der uns einfach gesagt hat, Armut, mit den Leuten wollen wir nichts zu tun haben. Das sind ja voll die Loser. Wir leben jetzt in einer Zeit, in der wir Larry Ellison, Peter Thiel, Elon Musk auf der Bühne sehen und uns einfach nur fragen, sind die ernsthaft krank? Sind die einfach gestört? Sind die dumm? Und das sind alles legitime Fragen, die sich flächendeckend gerade gestellt werden. Niemand sieht Elon Musk und sagt, ich wäre auch gerne mal so ein Milliardär, sondern man sieht, Momentchen mal, 400 Milliarden und so siehst du dann aus, das geht nicht, das will ich nicht. Ich lehne das ab. Das ist eine Lehre, auch für mich. Das muss man ganz ernst nehmen. Also ich sehe hier Potenzial für große Veränderungen in diese Richtung, dass nämlich irgendwer dann kommt und sagt, so du bist jetzt fertig mit der Uni, wir bieten dir hier einen Job, 250.000 Euro Einstiegsgehalt, dein Büro ist da ganz oben, du kannst auch immer mit dem Chef reden und so und du reist ganz viel. Und dann werden Leute sagen, kein Bock, I prefer not to. Ich würde lieber mit meinen Freunden treffen und mir reichen 80.000 im Jahr. Und das Zeitalter wird ja kommen, in dem die jungen Leute einfach händeringend gesucht werden. Da wird auch die KI, ich stelle nachher einen Text, der das so ein bisschen konterkariert, aber das ist sehr fragwürdig. Also es ist wirklich ein neuer Zeitalter, ja. Und dieser Verweis auf, wir starten jetzt gerade, und ich habe sie ja zu Hause, mit der dritten Generation, die versucht, in dieser Welt Fuß zu fassen, da gelten die alten Sehgewohnheiten nicht mehr. Ja. Diese Leute, früher war es so, ich habe mich getrennt. Und die Elterngeneration ist aus allen Wolken gefallen. Heute ist die Botschaft, ich weiß, ihr habt alles dafür getan. Und ich habe auch Freude. Und es war voll toll bei SAP, aber ich habe gekündigt. Und dann kommt die Elterngeneration, du hast bei SAP gekündigt. Aber ich gebe doch seit zehn Jahren an, dass du bei SAP arbeitest. Und das ist ein echter Clash. Und das muss man ernst nehmen, auch wenn wir hier nur menschliche Spekulation haben, weil sich bei den Tagesthemen und bei Instagram anderes zeigt. Aber hier greift die Rutger-Breschmann-Logik. Das hat mit dem normalen Menschen nichts zu tun. Wir werden hier in die Irre geführt.
Wir sind gespannt. Man sieht auf jeden Fall, das Buch leitet an zur Diskussion und führt uns mitunter auch weit weg. Davon ist es jedenfalls ein sehr lesenswerter Beitrag, möchte ich sagen.
Allerdings.
Die neoliberale Globalisierung ist am Ende. Erleben wir jetzt die Rückkehr der Geopolitik? Nein, sagt Milan Babić in seinem Buch Geoökonomie, Anatomie der neuen Weltordnung. Und das ist schon der Grundbegriff, der auch einen neuen Blick ermöglichen soll auf die Dinge, die uns umgeben. Geoökonomische Interessen sind es nun. Die Staaten, Konzerne leiten, aber die natürlich auch dafür sorgen, dass sich in den Demokratien und Autokratien die Leute in einer ständigen Verunsicherung befinden. Ist der falsche Populismus dann plötzlich die einzige Antwort, die noch da ist? Milan Babić versucht, diese geökonomische Welt zu beschreiben und es gelingt ihm zu zeigen, dass dies mit aller Komplexität getan werden muss, um überhaupt der Sache Herr zu werden und um zu verstehen, was haben die Zölle von Trump, was haben die protektionistischen Tendenzen von China und der EU eigentlich mit uns direkt zu tun?
Ja, ein rosanes, farbliches Surkamp-Theorie-Buch. Haben wir es hier wieder mit einem Selk, mit einem Blüthorn zu tun? Muss ich es ablehnen? Nein, es ist einfach ein Spektakel. Es ist eine niederländische Zuschrift von einem Jahrgang 1990 Autorin, der also ins Archiv geht, echte Texte liest, sich Gedanken macht und noch mal ein Lehrbuch nachschaut, um uns die Zeit, sagen wir mal, 1945 bis 2025 zu erklären. Der sich also nicht vom Fernsehen und Nachrichten geschehen hat verunsichern lassen. Und er kommt zu anderen Gedanken. Und es war sehr inspirierend, es zu lesen und es mit ihr zu diskutieren. Und ich glaube, man kann wieder ein bisschen Hoffnung schöpfen, gerade weil er auch so punktgenau das Problem beschreibt, das nämlich sehr groß ist. Die Zwanziger, wir haben häufiger darüber gesprochen, deswegen heißt der Podcast so, endeten mal in einer großen Krise, die droht hier auch. Aber Auswege, es gibt Auswege.
Der Literaturhistoriker Tilman Lahme legt eine Thomas Mann Biografie vor, die heißt Thomas Mann ein Leben. Was ist an dieser Biografie neu und warum sollte man sie lesen oder warum kann man sie lesen? Nun, es ist ein Buch, das sich tatsächlich auf den privaten Thomas Mann konzentriert, nicht einfach nur, um durchs Schlüsselloch zu blinzeln, sondern auch, um deutlich zu machen, dass das Werk von Thomas Mann entscheidend davon geprägt ist, wie er sein Leben und vor allem seine Liebe ordnet oder wie er die Liebe, die ungelebt bleibt, aber ständig in seinem Werke mitführt. Nun ist es ja keineswegs neu, die Erkenntnis, dass Thomas Mann homosexuell war, sich auch sehr hingezogen fühlte zu jungen, auch pädarastische Fantasien in seiner Literatur. Immer wieder hat er formuliert und er hat auch in gewisser Weise ja selbst mit seinen Tagebüchern unglaublich viel offen gelegt. Er hat Tagebücher verfasst, sehr gründlich. Einige hat er dann auch später vernichtet, also aus den frühen Jahren. Aber sehr viel ist eben auch erhalten. Und dort beschreibt er ja auch dann noch im hohen Alter, wie er hingerissen ist von einem Kellner beispielsweise, den er in einem Hotel sieht. Er kommt immer wieder auf die Singe zu sprechen und wird ja auch in seinen Romanen mitunter ziemlich explizit. Wenngleich das dann nicht autobiografiegleich ist, kann man doch so ja nachvollziehen, welche Stimme da eigentlich spricht. Nämlich die von Thomas Mann zum Beispiel im Felix Krull. Wenn da eine Frau sagt, dass sie immer eigentlich die Männer liebte, die noch nicht ganz Mann geworden sind und so etwas, dann ist das natürlich sehr viel, was Thomas Mann da selbst über sich bekundet. Allerdings ist es so, dass in der Germanistik oder in der Thomas Mann Forschung, die Homosexualität eine nicht ganz so große Rolle spielte. Zwar gab es natürlich einige, die sich mit einigen Lieben von Thomas Mann und glücklichen Lieben beschäftigt haben, aber doch ist man oft dazu übergegangen, das ja nur als so ein Beiwerk zu sehen oder hat auch immer wieder versucht, Thomas Mann, der ja sechs Kinder hatte, mit Katja Mann verheiratet war, doch als eigentlich allerhöchstens bisexuellen Autor anzusehen, hat also sich auch sehr davor gescheut und hat auch zum Teil, und das ist wirklich ganz erstaunlich, was diese Biografie dann zutage fördert, Bekanntes nicht an die Öffentlichkeit drängen lassen. Also gab es beispielsweise einen Jugendfreund, mit dem er sehr lange im Briefkontakt war, Otto Krauthoff, mit dem sich Thomas Mann ausgetauscht hat und der sein Vertrauter gewesen ist. Dieser Krauthoff hat Briefe von Thomas Mann erhalten und diese Briefe sind auch herausgegeben worden, dann schon in den 70er Jahren. Aber man hat zwei frühe Briefe einfach weggelassen, nämlich zwei Briefe und die sind hier auch mit abgedruckt, in denen sich Thomas Mann sehr genau informiert, was der Krauthoff da gerade vornimmt. Nämlich Krauthoff ist homosexuell, unternimmt eine Konversionstherapie, weil er sich davon in Anführungszeichen heilen will. Und Thomas Mann ist sehr daran interessiert, an dieser Therapie. Diese Briefe werden nicht veröffentlicht. Die sind jetzt hier abgedruckt, also viele Jahrzehnte später. Krauthoff ist auch derjenige, der ja mit Thomas Mann über diese Dinge reden kann. Und er ist aber der, der dann nachher in der Forschung ganz schlecht wegkommt, als der Freund, der ihm immer geistig wahnsinnig unterlegen war und so. Also es ist ganz erstaunlich, obwohl wir es da mit einem sehr renommierten Kunsthistoriker zu tun haben, der die deutsch-französische Gesellschaft gegründet hat. Also niemand, der jetzt irgendwer war. Ja, aber es ist sehr erstaunlich. Und es gibt einen sehr langen Einschub dann am Ende des Buches, in dem Tilman Lahme auch mit der Thomas Mann-Forschung ja regelrecht abrechnet, warum hat sie so lange dazu geschwiegen? Warum hat man sich auch geziert, die Tagebucheinträge, die zensiert wurden, sich mal genau anzusehen? Die sind auch hier abgedruckt auf zwei Seiten, in denen dann Thomas Mann sehr klare sexuelle Fantasien in seinem Tagebuch schildert. Jetzt kann man sagen, aber ist das nicht jetzt wirklich auch alles ein bisschen was, was uns nicht interessieren sollte? Dazu muss man wissen, Thomas Mann hat seine Tagebücher geschrieben und darüber verfügt, dass sie 20 Jahre verschlossen bleiben, bis alle tot sind, also alle, die da besonders betroffen sein könnten. Und dann soll das der Welt zugänglich gemacht werden. Das heißt, man kann also erst mal sagen, Thomas Mann wollte, dass wir es lesen. Und man darf wohl auch behaupten bei vielen Eintragungen, Thomas Mann hat schon auch die künftigen Leser imaginiert. Denn er hat natürlich auch Beschönigungen vorgenommen, hat sich nur versucht, ins rechte Licht zu rücken. Das macht man ja für irgendwen für die Nachwelt. Genau, jetzt ist es so, dass man natürlich trotzdem sagen kann, braucht man die ganze Zeit diesen privaten Blick. Nun, es gibt sehr viele Biografien über Thomas Mann, die sich auf den politischen Mann konzentrieren, auf seine Exilzeit oder auf sein literarisches Werk. Hier finde ich, wird eigentlich ein relativ guter Spagat gefunden zwischen dem privaten und dann immer wieder dem Rückbezug auf das Werk. Also wo geistern die Liebschaften oder so durch das Werk von Zauberberg oder Mephisto? Bei mir stellt sich natürlich dann häufig der Eindruck an, dass ich sage, ja gut, jetzt weiß ich das mal, dass damit mit der Figur ist Paul gemeint und das andere ist Klaus oder so. Ja, nur ergibt das ja nicht jetzt für mich eine neue Sichtweise auf das Werk an sich. Also ich lese ja so ein Werk nicht, um mal herauszufinden, also als Schlüsseltext, wie ging es dem Autor. Das wäre ja dann nicht so spannend, es sei denn, ich bin jetzt besessen von der Person Thomas Mann, was ich ja nicht bin. Also für mich wird ja eigentlich Literatur dann interessant, wenn dieses biografische abfällt. Und deswegen ist natürlich diese Sichtweise hier, die ist natürlich einer Biografie geschuldet, eine, die das Werk jetzt sehr stark darauf einengt. Oder wir bekommen jetzt davon Tilman Name, so einen Schlüssel in die Hand gelegt, mit dem wir sehr viel aufschließen können. Ich finde, man kann das gut wissen, dass das so ist. Ich glaube aber, dass man dann schon noch mal der Literatur eine Eigenständigkeit zugestehen muss, die dann über das hinausgeht, dass man jetzt sagen kann, und da hat Thomas Mann eine unglückliche Liebe oder etwas verarbeitet. Um mal so einen Eindruck zu bekommen, wie dieses Familienleben sich überhaupt gestaltete, denn es ist eine unglückliche Familie, die uns hier geschildert wird, bei all dem Erfolg. Mal hier ein Eindruck. Thomas Mann schreibt einen Essay in den Zwanzigerjahren über die Ehe und steuert aber in diesem Essay vor allem auf die Homoerotik zu, was ja in einem Ehe-Essay ein bisschen merkwürdig ist. Jedenfalls ist das auch so ein verdecktes coming out, kann man sagen. Aber in dieser Zeit passiert noch sehr viel mehr. Ich lese einfach mal so ein paar Absätze daraus vor, um einen Eindruck zu bekommen. Der Ehe-Essay ist ein ganz vorsichtiges und eingeschränktes öffentliches coming out. Er ist ein Bekenntnis zur Ehe und eines zur Homoerotik gleichermaßen, die nur der Künstler in sich vereinigen und im Werk gestalten könne. Er verteidigt Thomas Manns eigene Existenz gegen die Bedrohung von beiden Seiten, gegen die Feinde der Homosexualität, ob aus grundsätzlicher Ablehnung oder aus medizinisch pathologisierender Sicht, und gegen die der liberalen Befürworter, die für gelebte gleichgeschlechtliche Liebe eintreten. Thomas Mann verteidigt sein eigenes Leben, indem er dem Leben, das sein Sohn Klaus führt, eine Absage erteilt. So also sieht es Mitte der 20er Jahren in Sachen Liebe aus bei Thomas Mann und seiner Familie. Sein ältester Sohn lebte in aller Offenheit aus, was der Vater in sich niederringt und schreibt unverschleiert darüber. Die älteste Tochter liebt ebenso leidenschaftlich wie vergeblich eine Frau, Pamela Wedekind, und heiratet den seinerseits schwulen Gustav Gründgens. Alle vier zusammen bringen homosexuelle Liebe und Generationenkonflikte auf die Bühne. Sie werden von zwei Seiten hart kritisiert, von professionellen Kritikern, die sich am leichtfertigen und am Rummel der literarischen Anfänge Klaus Mann stören, und von erzkonservativer bis rechtsextremer Seite, die das offene und andere Lebenskonzept, das sich hier äußert, scharf angreifen. Der zweite Sohn Golo wiederum trifft auf Widersprüche gegen seine Homosexualität, als wäre er ein Widergänger seines Vaters. Der Schulleiter Hahn, der seine eigene Homosexualität unterdrückt, schreibt Thomas Mann, der die Hunde im Sautérin fest an der Kette hält, über die abnormen Triebe des Sohnes, wie er sie aushungern müsse. Der Vater ist offenkundig einverstanden, der Sohn wird nicht vor dieser Therapie bewahrt und nicht von der Schule genommen. Monika schließlich hatte, wenn man ihre Andeutung richtig versteht, ein sexuelles Verhältnis mit einem Lehrer, als sie noch am Münchner Luisen-Gymnasium war. Er habe sie, die noch nicht ganz 14-Jährige, ins Unstadthafte gelockt, schreibt sie später. Rund 100 Jahre vor MeToo sorgt es dafür, dass die Schülerin das Gymnasium verlassen muss, nicht der Lehrer. Als fiktiver Stoff wäre dies alles völlig unglaubhaft. Eine Familiengeschichte mit grotesken Zügen. Die Wirklichkeit schert sich darum nicht. Im Sommerurlaub 1927 verliebt sich Thomas Mann auf Sylt in einen 18-Jährigen. Klaus Heuser ist der Sohn eines Kunsthistorikers aus Düsseldorf. Und Thomas Mann schreibt dann an seinen Sohn, ich nenne ihn du und habe ihn beim Abschied mit einer ausdrücklichen Zustimmung an mein Herz gedrückt. Ich bin schon alt und berühmt. Warum solltet ihr allein darauf sündigen? Daraufhin ist wiederum Golo eifersüchtig. Der stört sich dann in die Krise, beziehungsweise schreibt, wie man das im Hause Mann macht, dann eine Erzählung über das wieder. Also das sind die Verwicklungen, von denen wir da reden. Also eine Familie, bei der man froh ist, dass man da nicht Teil war. Einem solch gigantischen Vater ausgesetzt, der natürlich dort alles beherrschte. Und zwar in einer, ja, wie könnte man das ausdrücken, in aller Stille. Also er war ja niemand, der jetzt das Selbstorganisierte groß, sondern das musste ja alles Katja Mann machen. Und Katja Mann musste quasi dafür sorgen, dass im Haus absolute Stille eingehalten wird, wenn der Vater schreibt. Die Kinder durften das Arbeitszimmer auch nur sehr selten betreten. Er hatte auch dann einfach eine Lieblingstochter oder so, die er sich dann rausgepickt hat. Und die fand er dann immer ganz reizend. Die durfte auch alles machen, die anderen Kinder nicht. Also die Härte, die er seinen Kindern mitgegeben hat, ist natürlich auch in einer Unbarmherzigkeit hier geschildert, dass man sagt, das ist kaum nachzuvollziehen. Dass das, also das, beziehungsweise man weiß ja, was aus den Kindern dann auch da zum Teil geworden ist. Also es sind ja auch dann Selbstmorde in der Familie und all das. Also es ist wirklich eine gruselige Schilderung hier. Also das vieles weiß man aber in diesen Details noch mal, wie das hier nachgearbeitet wird, ist wirklich auch, wie es geschrieben ist, sehr, sehr gut. Es geht auch dann um diese unglaubliche Eitelkeit von Thomas Mann. Er wollte unbedingt den Literaturnobelpreis haben, hat ihn ja dann bekommen 1929. Aber in der Begründung stand für sein Werk die Buddenprugs. Oder eigentlich wird ja der Literaturnobelpreis für das Gesamtwerk verliehen. Thomas Mann wollte das dann auch so dargestellt haben, aber das stimmte halt nicht. Mit den neueren Romanen Thomas Manns konnten die nichts anfangen in Schweden. Also haben die nur die Buddenprugs eigentlich ausgezeichnet. Darunter litt dann wieder Thomas Mann. Es geht hier auch um den Dr. Faustus, also einen Roman, der sich mit dem Faschismus auseinandersetzt. Auch hier gibt es eine Beziehung des Komponisten zu einem, der heißt Rudi Schwertfeger, in diesem Roman. Und dann kann Tilman Lahme ziemlich gut zeigen, welche eigentliche reale Grundlage diese Beziehung, die eigentlich homoerotischer Natur ist, hat. Also das ist schon ganz beeindruckend, so dann immer mit dem mit dem Werk abgeglichen. Aber es ist natürlich immer dieser dieser intime Blick, bei dem ich mich dann manchmal frage, gut ich weiß das jetzt alles ganz genauso von Thomas Mann, aber führt mich das zu dem Werk eigentlich mehr hin? Oder führt es mich mitunter weiter davon weg? Weil ich natürlich dann einen Spezialfall habe. Also kein Familie ist wie die der Manns. Das ist glaube ich jetzt schon in den wenigen Absitzen nicht vorgelesen, aber deutlich geworden. Und habe ich dann so eine Spezialkonstellation der Literatur. Ich würde ja sagen, die Stärke von Thomas Mann liegt ja darin und vermutlich würde Tilman Lame mir auch da Recht geben, dass er aus dieser sehr spezifischen Situation heraus Literatur mit universeller Geltung geschaffen hat, bei der diese Fragen sich dann am Ende nicht mehr stellen, hat Thomas Mann hier verarbeitet, Klaus Heuser mit 18 Jahren da und dort getroffen, sondern es geht ja um was anderes. Also es geht da tatsächlich um die literarische Qualität, um das auch, was dann darüber hinausgehend gesagt wird, über das Begehren, die Liebe, den Verzicht.
Ja, ich finde das wahnsinnig interessant, dass es überhaupt eine Autorenforschung spezifisch hier eben auf einen Autoren gemünzt zu gibt. Ich frage mich immer, was man so hinterlässt, wenn man Texte geschrieben hat. Wir beide haben ja auch viel geschrieben, Bücher, Texte, so im laufenden Betrieb, wie auch immer. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob sich das bei mir überhaupt lohnen würde. Also klar kann man jetzt irgendwie sagen, hat ein Buch über Familie geschrieben, wird wahrscheinlich gerade nicht 70 Jahre alt gewesen sein währenddessen so. Aber mehr wird es, glaube ich, nicht herauszulesen geben. Also eigentlich nutze ich auch so Schreibphasen immer für, ah ja, dann kann ich mich einfach sonntags ins Büro setzen, laut Musik hören und halt an meinen Texten so rumarbeiten.
Ja.
Und danach gehe ich wieder zurück ins Leben. Und blende wieder ein, was mich eigentlich interessiert.
Und das ist hier der große Unterschied. Und das ist sicherlich auch das Besondere an Thomas Mann, nämlich zu sagen, in der Literatur findet mein eigentliches Leben statt. Das ist das, was mich interessiert. Ich nehme deshalb auch meine Wirklichkeit als literarisches Material wahr. Er ist durchaus befreundet mit Gerhard Hauptmann. Und Gerhard Hauptmann hatte die Angewohnheit, Sätze nicht zu Ende zu sprechen und noch so ein paar andere Marotten. Thomas Mann analysiert das alles sehr gut, beobachtet das sehr scharf. Und dann wird aus Gerhard Hauptmann Pepperkorn im Zauberberg. Als Hauptmann den Zauberberg liest, ist er erboost und dann ist erst mal Funkstille zwischen den beiden. Hauptmann will eigentlich einen Brief schreiben und hält sich dann zurück. Und das ist tatsächlich diese Haltung, dass aus allem, was geschieht, Thomas Mann Literatur macht. Oder er ja auch, wenn eben ihm danach ist, in der Literatur jemanden sterben lässt, um ihn quasi zu bestrafen dort. Also das ist tatsächlich diese Haltung. Mein Leben findet nicht statt. Deswegen findet er das ja so degutant, dass der Klaus Mann wirklich mit irgendwelchen Matrosen und so ins Bett geht, während er natürlich nur die Fantasie davon hat. Und er sagt, ich verlagere das alles in die Literatur hinein. Also Supplimation, würde man mit der Psychoanalyse sagen. Und dadurch ist es natürlich so interessant, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen. Und es ist mitunter dann verrückt, wie Keusch, manche Germanisten damit umgegangen sind. Ich glaube nur dann, wenn man jetzt nur noch diese Blickweise auf Thomas Mann hat, dann hat man auch irgendwann so ein Buch vor sich, dass man dann auch so liest als ein pathologisches Sammelwerk, von jemandem, der da irgendwie Probleme mit was hatte. Und das, glaube ich, ist eben dann nicht der Fall. Und man muss auch quasi dann nochmal die Literatur als solches betrachten. Das ist jetzt nicht der Vorwurf an die Biografie, nur glaube ich, dass man sich zu sehr auf diese Rezeption auch nicht einengen sollte. Was noch ganz interessant ist, ist, dass Susan Sonntag ja Thomas Mann als damals noch Schülerin getroffen hat. Ich glaube, 17, 18 war sie und hat damals so ein Essay darüber geschrieben. Und wie enttäuscht sie darüber war, dass dieser große Dichter des Zauberbergs eigentlich nur in Phrasen gesprochen hat. Interessant ist aber, dass dieser Text ja Jahrzehnte später erschienen ist. Sie hat aber gleich nach dem Treffen oder eine Weile nach dem Treffen tatsächlich einen Text veröffentlicht, der heißt Bei Thomas Mann. Und der ist erstmalig hier abgedruckt. Und in dem ist der Ton plötzlich ein ganz anderer. Und geht es auch nochmal um andere Dinge. Und da legt dann auch Timan Lame nochmal so eine bisschen freudianische Literaturinterpretation vor. Es geht im Zauberberg um einen Stift, der sich ausgeliehen wird. Und der Stift ist ein Fallos-Symbol und bedeutet natürlich Sex. Und das ist auch wiederum eine Szene aus der eigenen Biografie von Thomas Mann. Und interessanterweise lässt Susan Sontag sich eine Zigarette geben von Thomas Mann und überlegt, wie sie die eigentlich als Andenken behalten kann. Und bei Susan Sontag gibt es zu der Zeit auch natürlich einen Ringen damit, ob sie ihre lesbische Liebe ausleben soll oder nicht. Und das wird dann hier nochmal so verschränkt. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein origineller Blick nochmal, der hier stattfindet. Also wenn man sich mit Thomas Mann beschäftigen will und schon manches gelesen hat, wenn sonst ergibt das nicht so viel Sinn, dann kann man hier auf jeden Fall bei Tilman Lahme eine sehr elegant verfasste Biografie lesen, die vor allem einen großen Vorteil hat. Sie versucht nicht, Thomas Mann zu imitieren. Denn das liegt ja nahe, wenn man sich die ganze Zeit mit Thomas Mann beschäftigt, dass man plötzlich auch noch anfängt, so zu schreiben. Und das macht Tilman Lahme nicht. Er findet einen eigenen Ton dafür. Und ich finde, es ist auch nicht ein Ton, der jetzt zu sehr ins Intime hineingeht, sondern er versucht schon immer wieder mit der Literatur das Ganze in eine Beziehung zu setzen.
Ja, sehr gut. Ich war ja gestern bei den Lyriktagen in Frankfurt. Es gibt so verschiedene Veranstaltungen. Es waren zwei Autoren da, die Lautprogramme ein bisschen über die Weiblichkeit im Gedicht und wie man das verarbeiten kann. Es wurde dann sehr viel schneller, sehr viel existenzieller. Aber gleichzeitig sitzt man so sehr distanziert vor diesen Texten. Die werden einem ja kurz vorgelesen von den Autoren selbst. Und man weiß, ich muss das jetzt eigentlich nochmal selber lesen. So schnell kann man das nicht verarbeiten. Die Worte kommen doch zu unüberraschend aufeinander und so. Aber man merkt, und da wird dann auch geschildert, wie man bei anderen Lyrikveranstaltungen ist und dort Tränen überströmt, solchen Gedicht, Darbietung hört. Ich merke dann nochmal, wie wenig das meine Welt ist. Aber jetzt erinnere ich mich wieder sozusagen an gestern, weil hier ja offenbar Autoren die Welt als Artefakte für ihre Geisteswelt, die sie aufschreiben, sehen. Statt ich Sachbuchautor, der halt sage, die Welt ist, wie sie ist. Und ich lege mal ein Text als Artefakt daneben. Und dann gehst du wieder ins Leben.
Du sagst nicht, dein Sachbuch ist dein Leben.
Genau. Und ich gehe auch nicht davon aus, dass das jetzt unbedingt sehr viele lesen und vielleicht ein Nobelpreiskomitee darauf aufmerksam wird. Aber das scheint ja hier ganz anders zu sein.
Oh ja, oh ja.
Sehr gut. Wir machen jetzt auch mal eine Textexegese. Wir müssen also kurz einen Text. Ich werde mal unüblich viel lesen. Danach machen wir uns dazu Gedanken, denn es ist ein bisschen schockierend. Aber finde ich auch interessant, denn das sind die neuen politischen Denksportaufgaben, die wir brauchen. Das State Department hat einen Text veröffentlicht bei Substack. Die publizieren da seit April. Es ist noch nicht viel dort entstanden. Vier, fünf Texte. Das ist jetzt der aktuellste.
Aber kostenlos oder muss man das machen?
Ja, es ist ja einfach erstmal nur ein Newsletter und so, oder? Und er ist von Samuel Samson, der Senior Advisor for the Bureau of Democracy, Human Rights und Labor, also Demokratie, Menschenrechte, Arbeit, zentrale Themen, wichtiger Posten, ist kein unbedeutender Text. Das ist offizielle Kommunikation. Das ist der amerikanischen Regierung. Die Überschrift lautet The Need for Civilization Allies in Europe. Also der Bedarf an zivilisatorischen, historischen, geschichtlichen Allianzen mit Europa. Ich habe mir das übersetzen lassen. Zur Übersetzung sage ich gleich noch was, denn ich habe mal Dieb gegen Clot und so ein bisschen ausgespielt. Also es geht um eine einzigartige Verbindung der gemeinsamen Kultur, gemeinsamen Glauben, familiäre Bindung, gegenseitige Hilfe in schwierigen Zeiten, die ein gemeinsames westliches Zivilisationserbe zwischen Amerika und Europa herstellt. Und wir wissen ja, der große Streit ist ja mit China und so. Die Reiche oder die Reichhaltige, die reichen westlichen Traditionen des Naturrechts, der Tugendethik und der nationalen Souveränität. Diese Traditionen reichen von Athen und Rom über das mittelalterliche Christentum bis hin zum englischen Common Law, schließlich zu den Gründungsdokumenten der Vereinigten Staaten. Und jetzt wissen wir ja, die Gegenwart Europa und so. Die revolutionäre Behauptung der Unabhängigkeitserklärung. Alle Menschen, und jetzt Zitat aus der amerikanischen Unabhängigkeitserklärung, von ihrem Schöpfer mit bestimmten unveräußerlichen Rechten ausgestattet sind. Also man versucht jetzt, um was rein zu kommentieren, selbst die Unabhängigkeitserklärung, die also ein klarer Spalt zwischen Amerika und Amerika wieder auf so einer höheren Ebene, wir haben ja schon über den Gottesstaat geredet, zu sagen, nee nee, da sind sie sich eigentlich einig gewesen. Ja, also selbst die Unabhängigkeitserklärung wird jetzt nachträglich als, nee nee, das ist der große Bruderkuss zwischen Europa und Amerika. Genannt werden hier die Gedanken von Aristoteles, Thomas von Aquin und anderen europäischen Denkern. Es geht um alle Menschen, natürliche Rechte. Keine Regierung hat das Recht, sie einzuschränken. Also das Naturrecht als Paralleluniversum wurde irgendwie mobilisiert. Diese Verbindung zwischen Europa und den Vereinigten Staaten ist auch der Grund, warum wir ehrlich sind, wenn wir anderer Meinung sind oder Bedenken haben. Und warum die Trump-Regierung in Europa Alarm schlägt. Da wird erinnert an JD. Vance, seine Rede auf einer Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz. Der zentrale Satz wird hier nochmal in voller Länge zitiert. Was mir Sorgen macht, ist die Bedrohung von innen der Rückzug Europas von einigen seiner grundlegendsten Werte, Werte, die es mit den Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika teilt. So, weiter im Textverlauf. Nach zwei verheerenden Weltkriegen wurden doch supranationale Strukturen geschaffen, die uns wieder zusammenführen. Substanzielle Diplomaties entstanden, wirtschaftliche Beziehungen durch die Überwindung der Fesseln von Nationalität, Kultur und Tradition versprach der globale Liberalismus das, was Francis Fukuyama als das Ende der Geschichte bezeichnete, die ultimative Innovation des politischen Lebens. Heute liegt dieses Versprechen in Trümmern. Was stattdessen fortbesteht, ist eine aggressive Kampagne gegen die westliche Zivilisation selbst. In ganz Europa haben Regierungen politische Institutionen gegen ihre eigenen Bürger und gegen unser gemeinsames Erbe instrumentalisiert. Hier hat übrigens Dieb L instrumentalisiert geschrieben. Claude hat dann später darauf hingewiesen. Das ist eine sehr ideologische Übersetzung, denn im Originaltext steht weaponized. Ich hatte Claude in dem Moment auf sehr streng eingestellt, aber fand er so streng ist die Anmerkung gar nicht. Und ich musste sowieso an Dieb L mal diesen Text zurückmelden, weil nämlich JD Vans mit Pants übersetzt wurde. Also da greift auch eine Kontextualisierung, die echte Fehler produziert. In deren Sicht wurde diese Übersetzung hier von Claude Schmitt sehr kritisiert, als zu weichgespült. Dazu gleich im Textverlauf weiter. Europa ist eine Brutstätte für digitale Zensur, Massenmigration, Einschränkung der Religionsfreiheit und zahlreiche andere Angriffe auf die demokratische Selbstverwaltung. Es ist also ein besorgniserregender Trend. Es werden so Beispiele aufgezeigt. In UK gab es eine Verhaftung, weil irgendwer sich zum Christentum bekannt hat.
Ja, das ist ja genau das Beispiel, das JD.
Vance in München erzählt hat. Genau, es wird alles wieder aufgewärmt. Es geht um Abtreibungskliniken, die stillge... Also im Vereinigten Königreich verhaftete die Polizei Christen, unabnamenlich Adam Smith Connor und Livia Toszici-Bold, weil sie vor Abtreibungskliniken stillgebetet haben. Also sie haben ihren christlichen Glauben und den gemeinsamen Erbe folgend ihren eigenen vulgären Gottesstaat Naturrecht durchgesetzt oder still darauf hingewiesen und wurden gleich verhaftet. Auch Deutschland wird kurz erwähnt. Wir haben es hier mit einem ausgeklügelten System zur Überwachung und Zäsur von Online-Äußerungen zu tun. Also das, was jetzt immer hofiert wird, nicht ganz so unrecht, das haben wir auch schon betont, aber hier halt sehr einseitig aufgegriffen.
Oder sagen wir mal von denen aufgegriffen, die momentan so massiv zensieren, wie die EU das noch nie getan hat.
Also das ist ja der Witz. Also Julia aus allen Bichereien raus und dann aber uuuh, da wurde jemand verhaftet. Ja, also, kurze Erwähnung des digitalen Dienstleistungsgesetzes der Europäischen Union, das eine Orrwälsche Inhaltskontrolle Raum gibt. Dieses Umfeld schränkt auch die Wahlen in Europa ein, wie kürzlich von Minister Rubio hervorgehoben wurde. Der AfD wird erwähnt, Le Pen wird erwähnt mit diesem Urteil, das sie jetzt verbietet anzunehmen. Polen, Rumänien wird erwähnt, Ungarn wird erwähnt. Die Amerikaner sind mit diesen Taktiken vertraut, denn, so ging es ja auch gegen Trump zu, vielmehr trampelt es im Namen, also Europa, einer dekadenten herrschenden Klasse, die Angst vor ihrem eigenen Volk hat, auf der Demokratie und dem westlichen Erbe herum. Die Unterdrückung der Meinungsfreiheit, die Erleichterung der Massenmigration, die Verfolgung religiöser Äußerungen und die Untergrabung der Wahlfreiheit, bla bla bla, es wird alles aufgezählt, es geht die richtige Rolle hin. Ein Europa, das seine geistigen und kulturellen Wurzeln ersetzt, also so eine Art kulturelle Umfolgung wahrscheinlich, die hier gedacht wird, traditionelle Werte als gefährliche Relikte betrachtet und die Macht in nicht rechenschaftspflichtigen Institutionen zentralisiert, ist weniger in der Lage, sich gegen externe Bedrohung und inneren Verfall zu behaupten. Ja, also hier geht es richtig ans Eingemachte und am Ende wird noch mal drauf hingewiesen. Die Vereinigten Staaten bekennen sich weiterhin zu einer starken Partnerschaft mit Europa und zur Zusammenarbeit bei gemeinsamen aus dem politischen Zielen. Diese Partnerschaft muss jedoch auf unserem gemeinsamen Erbe beruhen und nicht auf globalistischer Konformität. Deshalb müssen wir auf beiden Seiten des Atlantiks die Errungenschaften unserer gemeinsamen Kultur bewahren und dafür sorgen, dass die westliche Zivilisation auch für künftige Generationen eine Quelle der Tugend, der Freiheit und des wenschlichen Wohlergehens bleibt. So, ich habe diesen Text von Dieb L übersetzen lassen und weil es zu diesem Vance Penns Fehler kam, kurz Claude gefragt, wie er das übersetzen würde und was er so von der Übersetzung hält. Ich habe Claude sehr streng eingestellt, gibt mir immer wieder Worte, mache ordentliche Argumentationen und so weiter. Und Claude schrieb mir dann die vorliegende deutsche Version, zeigt klassische Merkmale einer Systemanpassung durch Übersetzung. Die aggressive polarisierende, der aggressive polarisierende Duktus des Originals wird durch sprachliche Normalisierung entschärft. Das ist kein neutraler Übersetzungsvorgang, sondern eine implizit ideologische Operation. Ich habe es also für uns jetzt auf Deutsch übersetzt, damit wir es im Podcast einfach lesen können. Und die Hörer, die es mit doppelter Geschwindigkeit hören, einfach wissen, um welchen Tenor es jetzt geht in ihrer Muttersprache. Aber im Original sagt Claude noch sehr viel schärfer. Also man muss sich das, was ich jetzt vorgestellt habe, nochmal weaponized und nicht nur instrumentalisiert vorstellen. So, ich habe dann außerdem bei Claude mal gefragt, was würdest du jetzt als Einschätzung geben? Was ist hier das Problem? Und ich bleibe erst mal dabei, ich empfehle das sehr. So wie vorhin schon, wenn man sich für Namen interessiert, einfach kurz Claude Chibitie oder Gemini fragen, datenjournalistischen Text, wo erst mal im dritten Absatz ist das wichtig gekommen und so. So auch hier. Also wir haben es mit einer quasi theologischen Genealogie zu tun. Athen, Rom, Christentum, Kamenla, amerikanische Gründung, Europas Zukunft. Die gibt es so nicht. Ich habe jetzt dadurch, dass ich endlich mal Zugriff auf eine digitale Version von Niklas Lumans Die Gesellschaft der Gesellschaft habe, dass ich das ab und zu mal so audio-mäßig nebenherlaufen. Und mir ist es wieder wie Schuppen von den Ohren gefallen. Wie wichtig es Luhmann war am Anfang, macht er ja immer zu betonen. Es gibt Theorien zur Gesellschaft, von denen wir uns fernhalten wollen. Und der erste Einstieg in die eigene Art der Systemtheorie ist, auf der Zeitdimension Fokus drauf zu legen. Gegenwart ist Gegenwart. Geschichte gibt es nur in der Gegenwart. Eine Vergegenwärtigung ist eine Interpretation. Es gibt keine Geschichte. Und dass einem das fünf Minuten später so begegnet, als instrumentelles Communiqué einer amtierenden amerikanischen Regierung, die einem einfach hier wirklich Lügen auftischt. Also ein gemeinsames Erbe unterjubelt, bei dem selbst die Unabhängigkeitserklärung noch mal eine gemeinsame Werteunion bekräftigen, das Dokument so sein soll. Das ist wirklich grotesk. Vor allem hat Claude noch mal darauf hingewiesen, dieses Naturrechtskonzept, was hier drin steht. Das also so, jeder hat auch seine eigenen Präferenzen und Privilegien, die sind Gott und Natur gegeben und die geben wir dann durch. Und dann sagt Claude, nein, das gibt es überhaupt gar nicht. Also es ist, wenn Naturrecht, ist das also eine Zeit, in der es extrem anti-individualistisch zu ging. Da ging es um Pflichten, da ging es um Prinzipien. Und wenn da irgendwer gesagt hat, aber ich, dann hieß es gleich, sorry, aber Naturrecht. Also nichts passt hier zusammen. Überhaupt diese mittelalterlichen scholastiken hier zu benutzen, um eine moderne Legitimation für eine kommende, gemeinsame politische Zeit zu formulieren. Ist einfach völlig absurd. Und dann, und deswegen lese ich den Text vor, wollte ich dann wissen, wie kriegen wir das? Wir brauchen ja Grundbegriffe jetzt für solche Phänomene. Weil, hier können wir nicht einfach immer sagen, der lügt oder wie auch immer.
Naturrecht meint hier natürlich, in dieser Ausdefinition geht es natürlich darum zu sagen, ach so, ihr wollt Familie neu ordnen? Nee, das ist gegen das Naturrecht.
Es sind Ableitungen von oben, kommt bloß nicht auf eigene Ideen.
Ja, ja, das ist unhintergehbar.
So, also der erste Begriff, der mir vorgeschlagen wird, Synchretismus, finde ich sehr gut. Es geht um selektive Rekombination disparater historischer Elemente, ohne Rücksicht auf deren ursprünglichen Sinn. Das haben wir hier in 1a gegeben, in fast jedem Satz. Das ist einfach Synchretismus, ja, also dieses Synthetisieren und Rekombinieren, aber total selektiv. Also wirklich nur die totale Vergegenwärtigung von, was man mal so braucht. Und dann bleibt einfach von so einem großen Kaiserschmand nur noch die Rusin übrig.
Ja, bzw. kennt man das ganz gut aus der Populärkultur, aus solchen Blockbustern, aus Franchises.
Dafür sind die da.
Das ist auch so die Arbeit mit Synchretismus. Also das ist im Prinzip so eine Idee, dass man sagt, ja, wir brauchen schon ein Schicksalsgedanken drin, aber vielleicht auch Gott, vielleicht auch noch eine New Age-Philosophie. Was könnte man noch reinbringen? Familienwerte, aber auch Individualismus. Also dieses Synchretistische ist…
Müssen wir jetzt neu lernen. Synchretismus.
Also dieser Synchretismus ist etwas, was wir eigentlich wahnsinnig gut kennen aus der Popkultur. Und dann nehmen wir das auch irgendwie hin, dass es da zwischen diesen beiden Stämmen eine besondere Verbindung gibt, weil das wird uns irgendwann in einem Spin-Off nochmal erklärt, warum das so sein soll. Ich habe gerade gestern das Spin-Off zu John Wick gesehen. Das arbeitet auch mit so einem albernen Synkretismus. Da gibt es dann plötzlich eine Balletttänzerin. Und die hat doch auch schon John Wick schon mal gekannt. Genau. Und die hat ja einen Vater verloren. Und die hat noch irgendwo eine Schwester. Und dann baut man sich da irgendwas zusammen. Und dann redet aber noch jemand darüber, ob wir völlig determiniert sind oder ob wir einen eigenen Willen haben. Und irgendjemand sagt noch, ja, aber das Schicksal, ja, ja, genau. Und das fügt man dann alles in so einen Rahmen. Und dann wird ein Film daraus. Und im Prinzip arbeiten die Republikaner ganz ähnlich.
Genau. Also diese Begriffe brauchen wir jetzt und zwar in den Tagesthemen. Nicht nur uns Lothar Dey-Texen, die das einschätzen. Nächster Vorschlag, der ist so Nietzsche-Foucault inspiriert. Genealogische Fabrikation. Das hört mir ganz gut, weil die beiden Begriffe kenne ich mehr als Synkretismus. Die nachträgliche Konstruktion einer Abstammungslinie, die historisch so nie existierte. Lévi-Strauss, also so ein bisschen französisch, traditionellistische Bricolage. Das bastelhafte Zusammenfügen verfügbarer kultureller Fragmente zu neuen Bedeutungsstrukturen. Gramsci, das ist dieser Marxist, der uns auch im Geoökonomiebuch begleitet hat. Hegemoniale Appropriation. Die Aneignung fremder Diskourselemente zur Stabilisierung der eigenen Machtposition. Das ist auch nicht schlecht. Systemtheoretisch am präzisesten strukturelle Kopplung heterogener Semantiken. Das ist jetzt nicht so unbedingt auf einen Begriff runtergebracht. Und konzeptionell auch, also ein bisschen kompliziert so, aber verschiedene historische Sinnwelten werden operativ verknüpft, obwohl sie funktional inkompatibel sind. Eine funktionale Kompatibilität. Also hier haben wir das Problem, wenn man es so in eine konstruktivistische Richtung dreht. Bei den anderen Begriffen hatten wir immer noch so ein, ja, ja, so kann man es deuten. Und die davon abweichende, hier instrumentelle Nutzung ist eine Lüge, die einfach politisch genutzt wird. Bei der Systemtheorie wäre es ja schwierig, überhaupt erst mal den eigentlichen roten Pfaden, die eigentliche geschrieben Geschichte zu finden, von der man dann eine Abweichung definiert. Also lassen wir das mal durchgehen, dass das hier nicht auf einen Begriff gebracht werden kann. Außerdem, Shijaks Terminologie wäre wohl ideologische Soutour. Die Verdeckung fundamentaler Antagonismen durch scheinbare historische Kontinuität, finde ich auch gut, weil Verdeckung ist sozusagen dieser Aspekt, dass man nicht nur etwas ins Schaufenster stellt, was man plötzlich braucht, sondern dass man damit mit Absicht noch etwas anderes verdeckt.
Jetzt muss ich mal nochmal fragen.
Das finde ich sehr gut.
Wie sind diese Ergebnisse zustande gekommen? Hast du gesagt, sag mal, was Zizek, Levi-Strohs und Luhmann dazu gesagt hätten? Oder wie kommen die Antworten?
Ich wollte eine systemtheoretische Einordnung, aber nicht auf einen Begriff, sondern einfach, was findet da statt? Und er hatte ja den Originaltext, die Diebe, die Übersetzung und seine eigene. Also er hat schon so ein bisschen so einen latenten Sinnstruktur abseits nur des Originaltextes, sondern auch durch die Übersetzungsdifferenzen und so. Und dann war mein Prompt einfach, bring es mir auf Begriffe und mach sie so plausibel, dass man die Autoren kennt, dass man sagen kann, okay, wir gehen über Autorität. Wie würden die großen Denker das nennen? Und ich würde aber jetzt einfach ganz simpel sagen, wir haben es hier mit historischer Aneignung zu tun. Und das finde ich besonders witzig, weil die halt die ganze Zeit mit dieser kulturellen Aneignung auf dem Kriegsfuß stehen. Und das ist ja das Schlimmste überhaupt, wenn plötzlich jemand ohne Rassalocken den falschen Beat spielt und so. Und ja, das ist einfach historische Aneignung. Also, das ist wieder mal alles gegen was sie sich wenden und was sie verabscheuen und so. Machen sie einfach selbst. Ganz ekelhaft.
Eine Zeitgemäße Form der Liebe heißt das Buch von der Schriftstellerin Katharina Bendigsen, das bei der Edition Nautilus erschienen ist. Es ist ein Buch, das sich mit dem Thema Kinder auseinandersetzt und Mutterschaft beziehungsweise Elternschaft. Es gibt auch noch den Untertitel Parentale Prosa. Das ist ja zunächst einmal interessant, dass man diese wunderbare Formulierung dafür hat. Worum geht es jetzt hier in diesem Buch? Nun, wir haben es mit Kurzprosa zu tun, mit Kurzgeschichten vor allem, die erzählt werden, aber auch mit Träumen einer Mutter. Es geht aber auch zum Beispiel um Fragebögen, die eingestreut werden. Es ist ein Buch, das sich also verschiedener Formen bedient, um diesem Thema in irgendeiner Weise gerecht zu werden, beziehungsweise um verschiedene Facetten des Ganzen freizulegen. Also es gibt experimentellere Formen, wenn man so möchte. Da gibt es auch einen Chatverlauf zwischen Eltern, der hier abgedruckt ist, also der geschrieben wurde, du magst so etwas kennen. Oder es ist auch eine alternative Form der Abschlussprüfung, in diesem Buch zu finden. Da sind also die verschiedenen Fächer aufgeführt, zum Beispiel Mathematik. Die erste Aufgabe lautet, Person eins und Person zwei erwarten ein Kind. Person eins verdient monatlich 2500 Euro, Person zwei verdient monatlich 1700 Euro. Während der Elternzeit erhalten beide Personen 65 Prozent ihres Gehalts, jedoch höchstens 1800 Euro pro Monat. Und dann schließen sich eben Fragen daran an, wie würde man es richten? Das wäre eine Mathematikaufgabe. Oder für die Gesellschaftskunde gibt es zum Beispiel folgende Frage. Das Risiko in Armut zu leben, ist für leinerziehende Familien in Deutschland von allen Familienformen am höchsten. 43 Prozent der Ein-Eltern-Familien gelten als einkommensarm, während es bei den Paarfamilien mit zwei Kindern 11 Prozent sind. Durch welche Maßnahmen stellt die Bundesregierung sicher, dass sich daran nichts ändert?
Sehr gute Frage.
Also man sieht, diese Sachen sind auf Proante gestrickt. Finde ich ganz schön, aber wirklich mich direkt beeindruckt haben die Geschichten. Und zwar ist da eine Geschichte von einer Rosa. Rosa Freitag ist ein kleines Mädchen und sie steckt sich einen Sonnenblumenkern ins Ohr. Und die Eltern wollen eigentlich damit zum Arzt und dann lassen sie es aber doch sein. Und irgendwann, wir ahnen schon, wächst aus dem Ohr eine Sonnenblume und die wird immer größer und bedeutender für ihr Leben. Oder es gibt eine Geschichte, die heißt Der Spalt, die immer davon handelt, dass die Ich-Erzählerin bei den Eltern übernachtet und dann nochmal ins Badezimmer geht. Und da plötzlich ist da ein Spalt zwischen zwei Badezimmerfliesen und da verbirgt sich immer irgendetwas darunter. Also plötzlich kommt das Abgründige zum Vorschein, auch in Bezug dessen, wie wir unseren Eltern eigentlich begegnen, auch wenn wir sie länger nicht gesehen haben. Das Eigenleben der Eltern, die Wiederkehr der Kindheit, die man dort in irgendeiner Weise erfährt, eine ja unheimliche Geschichte. Und was die Autoren aber besonders kann, ist, aus dem alltäglichen Literatur zu machen. Und zwar in einer Weise, dass es das Alltägliche bleibt. Also nicht das jetzt zu übersteigern und sagen, ich erzähle da jetzt eine mythologische Geschichte draus, sondern sie bleibt da. Tilman Lahme erzählt, dass Thomas Mann einmal in der Situation war, seine Tochter wickeln zu müssen, weil wirklich niemand zu Hause war, der das machen konnte. Und nun war jetzt Thomas Mann nicht nur unbeholfen, was wahrscheinlich für alle Männer in den Zwanzigerjahren galt, sondern er war kurz davor, einen Nervenzusammenbruch zu bekommen.
Gab ja auch keine Pampers, das war alles noch Stoff oder so.
Ja, also er ist das für ihn eine existenzielle Situation, dass er völlig damit überfordert ist. Diese Literatur hier von Katharina Bendigsen geht mitten hinein ins Leben. Und ich will ein Beispiel geben, und die Geschichte hat mir tatsächlich am besten gefallen. Sie heißt So viel Glück. Die beginnt, Ich sah den Unfall auf dem Nachhauseweg im Wald, hatte Mio mir noch von Ben erzählt, der ihn heute angeblich wieder gebissen hatte. Wirklich, frag dich, Ben hat dich schon wieder gebissen? Ich glaubte ihm kein Wort. Es ging mir eher darum, dass er in seinem Fahrradsitz nicht einschlief. Seine Erzieherin hatte gesagt, dass er wieder in der Wachgruppe gewesen war. Und wenn er jetzt wegnicken und ich ihn gleich im Hof wecken würde, hätte er den Rest des Nachmittags schlechte Laune, würde Schubladen aufreißen, unser Bücherregal hochklettern oder mit seinem Spielzeug nach Ralf werfen. Und ich müsste schneller sein, als es mir nach acht Stunden im Projektraum möglich war und durfte vor allem nicht schimpfen. Denn schimpfen machte die Sache noch schlimmer. Also Situationen, die Eltern kennen. Dann gibt es einen Unfall und sie ist da als Zeugin dabei. Eigentlich sah ich den Unfall gar nicht. Mio und ich hatten gerade den Wald verlassen und fuhren auf die Kreuzung mit dem Supermarkt und dem syrischen Bistro zu. Da hörte ich den Knall und danach einen Schrei. Und ich bremste so abrupt, dass mir fast das Vorderrad wegrutschte. Auf der Straße lag ein Fahrrad darunter. Eine andere Mutter, die Lene des Kindersitzes hinter ihr, war zerbrochen. Das Kind darin war still. Es war deutlich jünger als Mio. Anderthalb vielleicht oder zwei. Wer kann Pappröhren mitbringen? Hatte ich noch vor eine Viertelstunde an der Wannzeitung im Kindergarten gelesen. Länger als Küchenrolle. Natürlich mussten die Röhren länger als Küchenrollen sein. Alles andere wäre zu einfach gewesen. Der Fahrer des Wagens, der halbauf und halb vor dem Fahrrad zum Stehen gekommen war, umklammerte das Lenkrad. Eine Ampel schaltete auf Rot, eine andere Ampel schaltete auf Grün. Und da war kein Blut auf der Straße. Auch das Fahrrad schien unversehrt, nur der Kindersitz war kaputt. Also wir merken schon, wir haben hier eine Erzählerin, eine Ich-Erzählerin, die etwas erlebt. Und es schiebt sich aber noch etwas aus der jüngsten Vergangenheit dazwischen. Also mit diesen Pappröhren liest sie, die werden gebraucht für den Kindergarten. Jetzt entspinnst sich also zwischen diesen beiden Müttern ein Gespräch. Nämlich, sie war doch Zeugin, soll jetzt doch aussagen und das sei doch alles ganz klar, aber sie ist sich eigentlich gar nicht sicher, will aber eigentlich nur weg, hat auch jetzt eigene Sorgen mit dem Kind, muss sich aber jetzt plötzlich dieser Situation aussetzen. Und wie entscheidet man sich dann eigentlich? Diese Erzählung hat einen Humor, weil diese beiden Mütter oder die eine Mutter will sich jetzt mit der Ich-Erzählerin jetzt so verbünden, wir als Mütter zusammen, aber dieser Ich-Erzählerin ist das auch gar nicht so recht. Vielleicht sollte ich ihn jetzt wecken. Also Mio war eingeschlafen. Vielleicht durfte er sich kurz in den Streifenwagen setzen. Das könnte den Nachmittag eventuell retten. Ich musste an den Bechteltest denken. Das ist dieser Test, den es in der Filmwissenschaft gibt, der umstritten ist, also inwieweit man einen Film feministisch beurteilen kann. Dann sagt der Bechteltest, wenn zwei Frauen alleine miteinander zu sehen sind in einer Szene und sie unterhalten sich nicht mit einem Mann. Und sie schreibt jetzt, ich musste an den Bechteltest denken, direkt neben mir redeten zwei Frauen miteinander und zwar nicht über einen Mann. Wenn Alison Bechtel Kinder hätte, hätte sie den Bechteltest anders formuliert. Die zwei Frauen durften miteinander auch nicht über Fremdbetreuung und Rabattaktionen und die Konsistenz von Ausscheidungen reden. Aber was blieb da noch übrig? Nur Filme und Bücher, von denen 90 Prozent den Bechteltest nicht bestanden und das Wetter und Unfälle vielleicht. Jedenfalls entspinnst sich das so weiter mit diesem Unfall. Und irgendwann endet dann auch diese Episode. Sie kommt nach Hause und versucht, das dann ein bisschen zu erklären, was da los war. Und dann aus dem Augenwinkel hatte ich etwas wahrgenommen. Ich ging zu blauen Tonnen und schlug den Deckel nach hinten. Jemand aus dem Haus musste neue Rollläden bekommen haben oder Plakate oder Bilder oder was auch immer in langen Pappröhren geliefert wurde. Die Ampel stand auf Rot. Warum hatte ich das zu der Polizistin gesagt? Warum beneide ich die andere Mutter um die Art, wie sie mit ihrem Kind sprach? Warum war ich der Meinung, etwas durchschaut zu haben, was ihr verborgen war? Die Tonnen noch trocken, schon nach Herbstlaub. Wir merken also auch hier schiebt sich wieder ganz viel dazwischen. Es geht also weiter an diesen Beobachtungen. Es geht noch einmal um Mio und dann um Ralf, den Mann. Würde ich zur Polizei gehen und meine Aussage wieder rufen, ich würde sagen, ich war einfach müde, so wahnsinnig müde. Ich war so erschöpft, dass ich mich geirrt habe. Kennen sie das? Sind sie auch manchmal erschöpft? Eine nach der anderen hob ich die Röhren aus der blauen Tonne. Mir traten die Tränen in die Augen. So wunderbar glatt waren sie. Es ist so wunderbar, wie diese Fokusverschiebungen stattfinden. Was man eigentlich gerade erledigen will, was man aber zu bedenken hat, was man im Hinterkopf noch hat. Also diese Röhren, das wäre doch schön, wenn jemand mitbringen könnte. Und jetzt plötzlich diese Freude über diese Röhren, das ist ja was völlig Banales, aber dass darüber ein Tränenausbruch stattfinden kann. Und also quasi dieses hohe und Banale so miteinander zu vermischen, ist wirklich wahnsinnig gekonnt und ist so dran an der Lebenswirklichkeit, aber ohne sie einfach abzuschreiben, sondern es findet eine Poetisierung in irgendeiner Weise statt oder auf eine Pointe gebracht, dann auch wird einem was klar, dass ich das sehr empfehlen kann. Das ist wirklich eine Erzählung, wie ich sie lange nicht gelesen habe.
Sehr gut, ja, das ist wirklich sehr vielversprechend zu dieser letzten. Es gibt gerade so ein Video, das rumgeht von so einem Busfahrer, der in Tränen darüber ausbricht, dass sein Frigadellenfrühchen freitags wahrscheinlich ausfällt, weil einfach dieser Frigadellenstand nicht mehr da ist und so.
Ah ja.
Und das wird auch sehr viel geteilt, weil die Leute dann so denken, das ist doch literarisch, das muss man doch aufschreiben. Na ja, sehr gut, dass es solche Bücher gibt, die das ganze Thema aus der Gedöns-Ecke rausholen und da so ein bisschen noch das Gute suchen. Ich habe mich an dem Familienthema über Zahlen zugewendet und wir bleiben jetzt auch mal bei Zahlen. Apple in China. Dieser Patrick McGee, der Autor, ist sehr renommiert. Der hat für das Wall Street Journal und die Financial Times jahrelang über Apple geschrieben und dachte sich, okay, ich mache das jetzt als Buch. Das kommt für Apple wahrscheinlich wirklich zur Unzeit, denn eigentlich wollen die unter dem Radar abfliegen. Aber das hier ist, man sieht ja auch an seiner Medienpräsenz, wie alle Interviews gehen ein bisschen länger mit ihm. Also, ich nenne mal ein paar Zahlen, bevor wir in den Text gehen. 1999 werden null Apple-Produkte in China hergestellt, heute 90 Prozent. 2003 werden in China 937.000 iPods verkauft, zwei Jahre später schon 23 Millionen. Heute 250 Millionen iPhones im Jahr. Eine absolute Gewinne. 2003 macht Apple einen Gesamtgewinn von 69 Millionen US-Dollar. 2024, und ich nenne erst die Vergleichszahl, Nvidia. Und wir wissen alle, was Nvidia 2024 für ein Kursfeuerwerk hingelegt hat. Der Umsatz von Nvidia lag bei 60 Milliarden, der Umsatz. Der Gewinn von Apple lag bei 94 Milliarden.
Ja, das ist so gigantisch.
Das sind unglaubliche Zahlen. Und dann das, was wirklich war, also ich habe es da vorhin schon genannt, aber man kann es nicht glauben. Steve Jobs stirbt und 11 Jahre später hat sein Nachfolger Tim Cook eine Erfolgsgeschichte hingelegt, indem er jeden einzelnen Arbeitstag im Durchschnitt das Unternehmen um 700 Millionen US-Dollar teurer gemacht hat, sodass es auf 3.000 Milliarden, also 3 Billionen Marktkapitalisierung gekommen ist. Schon vor zehn Jahren hat Apple pro Jahr mehr als 50 Milliarden nur in das, was man braucht, um dort überhaupt tätig zu sein. Hinzu kommen noch alle Materialkosten für die Geräte, die später wieder importiert werden. Es verdoppelt diesen Wert nochmal. Also wir liegen bei ungefähr 100 Milliarden pro Jahr Zufluss an Geld nach China. 28 Millionen ausgebildete Menschen, weil Foxconn irgendwann sagte, ja wir brauchen hier mehr Rotation und so weiter. Was eben dazu führt, jetzt gerade leben in China 28 Millionen Menschen, die das größte Hightech Produkt aller Zeiten selber mal hergestellt haben. Also die sozusagen im Knowhow alles übertreffen, was es irgendwo auf der Welt gibt.
Also wenn Tim Cook mit Donald Trump spricht, dann muss das ja für Tim Cook sein, ansonsten hat er jetzt irgendwie ein, wie man denn Würstchenbude betreibt oder so.
Ja, wir sind alle so beeindruckt von Donald Trump ist jetzt der mächtigste Mann der Welt und er hat ja so viele Handlungsmöglichkeiten und so.
Und er hat 300 Millionen verdienen mit dem Mini-Coin oder was auch immer.
Genau, Tim Cook ist auch wahrscheinlich gerade sehr aufgewühlt. Auf der anderen Seite kann er nur die Ruhe weg haben, weil seine Probleme sind andere als Donald Trump. Also die sind halt da. Also ich gehe das mal durch, weil wir haben jetzt das Geoökonomie Buch gelesen. Das ist die beste Voraussetzung, um zu verstehen, was es hier geht. Ich gehe mal diese Eskalationsgeschichte. Ist ja ein 400 Seiten langes Buch, aber wir gehen mal auf Ausschnitte durch. Also ganz am Anfang geht es um die Schwester von Steve Jobs. Patty, die für einen Dollar pro Platine zusammensteckt, was Steve Wozniak als Mitgründer entworfen hat. Sie kriegt einfach die Komponenten zugeliefert und baut die dann zusammen. Später stellt man dann fest, oh, ganz schön ein Verkaufserfolg. Also der populäre Apple II wird dann so, ja, da kennt jemand jemanden und er kennt jemanden und niemand sagt der Polizei Bescheid. Und am Ende sitzen irgendwelche Südasiaten und Mexikaner da so oben in der Nachbarschaft und puzzeln das so zusammen irgendwie. Also der McGee weist darauf hin, es war immer diese Apple-Geschichte, die Produktionsgeschichte. Du hast immer die Feingeister gehabt, die ihre ästhetischen Design bei Apple. Und dann hast du immer diese Produktionsstätten gehabt, die so ein bisschen abseitig waren und so. Apple war bei weitem nicht der größte Computerhersteller, den Taiwan damals, ging alles über Taiwan, je hatte. Aber seine Vorliebe für komplexe Designs und Intoleranz für Defekte war einzigartig und übertrieben, was eine Form intellektueller Investition erforderlich machte, die keiner seiner Rivalen teilte. Damals aus dieser Taschenrechner-Ecke und so. Apple-Veteranen aus dieser Zeit könnten nicht genug betonen, dass niemand sonst Dutzende von Ingenieuren in taiwanesische Deliveranten einbittete und dann konsequent die Grenzen des Möglichen ausreizte. Zitat Apple ist allein verantwortlich dafür, Qualität nach Südostasien zu bringen, sagte Robert Brunner, der Direktor des ID-Studios von 1990 bis 1997. Also schon in dieser frühen Zeit war völlig klar, Apple hat hier eigene Ansprüche. Wenn Apple irgendwo ist, sind die da so richtig, dann wird da Action gemacht. Da wird nicht einfach nur Taschenrechner zusammengeschraubt, sondern da ist richtig was los. Westliche PC-Unternehmen verlagerten nach China wegen dem, was verfügbar war. Apple verlagerte wegen dem, was möglich war. Der Journalist James Fallon, der Ende der 2000er Jahre in China lebte, hat argumentiert, dass Terry Gu, ganz wichtige Figur, ist der Chef von Foxconn, der gleich von Anfang an all in war. Nach Deng Xiaoping an zweiter Stelle steht, wenn es darum geht, China in den letzten 50 Jahren in ein industrielles Kraftpaket zu verwandeln. Ach ja. Also wir haben hier schon die Gleichstellung aus Politbüro, Chefe für die Geschäfte, öffnet China und Terry Gu. Also sehr viele der 28 Millionen Leute wurden über Terry Gu da durchgelotst. Weitere Ausschnitt aus dem Text, der dieser Apple Ingenieur beschreibt. Also der hat ja über 200 Gespräche geführt und so weiter. Dieser Apple Ingenieur beschreibt Gu's Ansatz heute als schlaue Wette, um westliche Unternehmen anzulocken, sie süchtig nach der Droge billige Produktion zu machen und eine klebrige Beziehung basierend auf Foxcons Auswahl von Komponenten zu schaffen. Zitat Sobald sie dich zur Tür hereinbekommen, ist das alles sie kontrollieren dich, sagt er. Foxcon wird nicht umsonst Foxcon genannt. Terry Gu war ein Spieler. Der echte Name des Unternehmens war Hanhai. Das wurde zu Foxcon geändert, weil er war ein Fuchs und er war ein Betrüger. Also wir haben hier eine, kennen wir soweit Foxcon, okay, spielt eine große Rolle. 2005 Begriff Jobs, also zwei Jahre vor dem iPhone, dass es keinen Weg zurück gab. 2005, das ist 20 Jahre her. Da war für Apple klar, wir müssen uns dem jetzt verschreiben, sonst passiert ja gar nichts. In diesem Jahr schlug ein Unternehmen vor, dass ein bestimmtes Projekt in den Vereinigten Staaten gemacht werden sollte. Und Jobs antwortete straff, ich habs versucht, es hat nicht funktioniert. Jahre bevor Uber zum größten Taxi-Anbieter werden würde, ohne ein einziges Fahrzeug zu besitzen, ohne Airbnb zum größten Unterkunftsanbieter werden würde, ohne Immobilien zu sitzen, entdeckte Apple, wie man der weltgrößte Hersteller wird, ohne Fabriken zu besitzen. Die haben schon diese 13, 15, 18 Milliarden im Jahr da investiert, ganze Industrieparks da aufgezogen, ohne dass da jemals ein Apple-Logo irgendwo auftauchte. Das war immer so im geben und nehmen Geschäft mit dem Kräften vor Ort. So, dann Steve Jobs stirbt im Oktober 2011. Erste große Zäsur. Also iPhone ist natürlich die zentrale Zäsur. 2007 kommt das iPhone, 2011 stirbt Steve Jobs, 2013 ist das Steve Jobs.
Ich muss ja ganz kurz einatmen, weil du das jetzt so beschrieben hast. Die Fabriken in China sind Foxconn-Fabriken. Bedeutet also, sind keine Fabriken, die Apple gehören, sondern es sind Fabriken, die gebaut werden, um Apple-Produkte herzustellen.
Genau, aber Apple wollte immer mehr. Sie sind immer auf diesen Terry Gou gestoßen, wie sich sehr viel später herausstellen wird, mit politischen Ambitionen. Oder nicht seine politischen Ambitionen, sondern es gibt politische Ambitionen in Terry Gou, als sie verwirklicht. So dass sie mit ihren Designs und was sie wollten, und dann brauchten sie Lieferketten. Also es gibt dann tausende Zulieferer in 50 Ländern der Welt und so, die das alles da so kombinieren. Und dann landet das alles in China an und wird dann zusammengebaut auf Maschinenparks, die extra dafür entwickelt wurden. Von Mitarbeitern, die Apple extra dafür anlernte. Aber eben Apple kommt da selbst als Dienstleister für Foxconn, weil Foxconn der Betreiber und so weiter ist. Also es ist ein ganz interessantes und einzigartiges Konzert.
Und dadurch konnten sie natürlich auch so früh in China so groß werden, weil sie in dem Sinne ja nur den Aufträge gaben, aber nicht jetzt selbst einfach sich da breit gemacht haben.
Genau, also wir kommen da gleich drauf, aber es gab eine ganz frühe Pointe, die da erzählt wird. 2003, als es noch kein iPhone gab, als iPods gebaut werden, also kleine Musikplayer, die Steve Jobs so aus seiner kleinen Hosentasche da holt, wo sonst die Sendstücke reinwandern. Schicken sie diese Designs dorthin und dann plötzlich macht der Terry Gou so eine Veranstaltung mit den Apple Leuten und zeigt ihnen, guck mal, das ist so unser iPod, den wir ganz ohne eure Technologie gebaut haben. Also das ist nicht nur Fertigung, das ist auch Research and Development. Und hat ihnen relativ früh gezeigt, wir können das alles, was ihr wollt. Ihr könnt uns einfach euer Zeug geben, wir liefern das dann schon. Und es wird dann seitenweise beschrieben, wie das einfach so, die rufen in China an, sagen, wir erwarten jetzt wieder Piek Weihnachtsgeschäft und so weiter. Wir brauchen zehn neue Fabrikhallen. Und dann fahren die drei Monate später hin und alles ist fertig, sauber. Die Leute müssen nur noch angelernt werden, das neue Design muss gezeigt werden und dann wird sofort gearbeitet. Und das hat sie halt sehr verlockt. Das ist einfach völlig klar, weil da müssen wir nur anrufen und sagen, das sind die erwarteten Umsätze, das ist euer Budget, baut mal die Fabrik und dann kommt die dahin und zack, steht die nächste Fabrik. Das ist sie nirgendwo sonst begegnet. Amerika völlig ausgeschlossen.
Und wohl auch ein bisschen länger die Arbeitszeiten dort.
Großes Thema. Ja, also diese soziale Dimension ist ein ganz großes Thema. Aber da gibt es gleich eine Pointe. Sei gespannt. 2013, also auch wichtige Zäsur, weil Xi übernimmt. Da begann das Unternehmen erstmals vorsichtiger zu werden und sich den Markt ein bisschen anzuschauen.
Es ist nicht einfach alles gegeben hinzunehmen. Im Gegensatz zur Rechtsstaatlichkeit, die im Westen entwickelt wurde, kehrte Xi, China, zu einer Rule-by-law-Tradition zurück. Einem Regierungssystem, das mehr als 2000 Jahre zurückgeht und es wir heute als Geoökonomie bezeichnen können. Also man nutzt die Möglichkeiten, die sich durch was auch immer, ach ihr habt eine WTO, ein juristisches Konzept, das kriegen wir schon in unserem eingebettet. Also Rule-by-law. Peking forderte nicht explizit etwas für Marktzugang. Das war illegal unter WTO-Regeln, aber es gestaltete das System um, um Wink Wink Arrangements wahrscheinlicher zu machen. Wie ein westlicher Geschäftsmann, der damals in China lebte, die Veränderung charakterisierte, Zitat, Freiwilligkeit ist das Neue obligatorisch. Apple hatte eine Regel, und jetzt wird es brisant, Apple hatte eine Regel eingeführt, damit seine Verkäufer nicht, also Zulieferer und der ganze Kram, nicht mehr als 50 Prozent abhängig von Apple und ihren Umsätzen waren, unabhängig von Apple, Unabhängigkeit von, über Abhängigkeit, so komplizierte Worte, also über Abhängigkeit von Apple, könnte nämlich Probleme schaffen, weil Cupertino eine Neigung hatte, Richtungen zu wechseln. Wenn also, sagen wir, ein Unternehmen, das eine Schlüsselkomponente lieferte, 80 Prozent abhängig von iPhone-Umsätzen war und Apple eine Designänderung machte, die die Notwendigkeit für diese Komponenten überflüssig machte, könnte dieses Unternehmen kollabieren. Tatsächlich taten viele das. Das passierte wiederholt und es verursachte Apple Probleme, einschließlich negativer Schlagzeilen in den Medien und schlechten Willen von Lieferanten. Also lernte Apple einen Sweet Spot zu finden, der wichtigste Kunde für seine Lieferanten zu sein, damit es Hebel hatte, aber nicht so sehr, dass die Lieferanten übermäßig abhängig waren. Das Ergebnis dieser Politik war ein, wie ein Senior-Führungskraft damals ausdrückte, war, dass egal, in welcher Rate wir wachsen, sie müssen so schnell mit uns wachsen. Apple hat also diesen ganzen Industriemarkt dort überhaupt erst mal mit hochgezogen, weil sie immer dieses Problem hatten, Weihnachtsbusiness und drei Monate vorher ein neues Apple-iPhone-Design. Und dann mussten alle Produktionslinien darauf abgestimmt werden. Plötzlich gab es keinen Gorilla-Class mehr, sondern irgendwas Neues und so weiter und so fort. Und damit die Zulieferer nicht zu so viel politischen und so weiter da führten, wurde immer darauf geachtet, dass sie möglichst viele andere zu liefern brauchten. Also musste um dieses Apple-Produktionssystem noch ein weiteres Ökosystem aufgebaut werden, was jetzt hier zufolge nach Poante führt. Also als iPhone-Lieferung in die Höhe schossen, ermutigte Apple seine China-basierten Lieferanten, den Android-Markt zu füttern.
Ach so, weil sie ja sonst nicht diversifizieren können.
Sonst hätten die, die mussten einfach, wie so eine Druckerei, die einfach mittwochs die Zeit druckt, brauchten auch was zu drucken von Montag bis Dienstag. So, das Wochenende, ja. Also mussten einfach irgendwelche Sachen, also mussten die einen Markt kreieren, damit es Abnehmer, andere Abnehmer gibt. Als Ergebnis gebar Apple die chinesische Smartphone-Industrie, was es wirklich, oder wie ein ehemaliger Apple-Vice-President diesem Autor bei einem Kaffee sagte, und das ist dann auch so eine Warte hier, bist du sicher, dass du deine These nicht überdenkst? Du redest ständig über Geopolitik. Aber ich war doch 2000 damals dabei. Da sagte er, als wir die Produktion in China aufgebaut haben und ich kann dir sagen, wir dachten überhaupt nicht an Geopolitik. Und dann meckte ich so, ja genau. Also dieses Buch geht diese ganze Geschichte durch. Die letzten 100 Seiten, die habe ich gestern leider nicht mehr in voller Gänze geschafft, aber da geht es dann um ganz konkret, das ist dann nicht mehr, naja und so, sondern das ist dann Huawei. Die übernehmen einfach diese ganze Infrastruktur. Und die Chinesen wollten das. Also die wollten einfach, dass da so eine Industrie entsteht. Und hier zwei Zitate, die wirklich herausragend sind, mal so ein bisschen wahllos. Es geht nicht darum, dass Apple chinesische Arbeiter ausgebeutet hat. Sondern, dass Peking Apple erlaubt hat, seine Arbeiter auszubeuten, damit China im Gegenzug Apple ausbeuten kann. Sehr wichtiges Prinzip.
Ja, das ist ja schon so gedacht der Starter als ideeller Gesamtkapitalist, der sich sagt, wir brauchen ein Wachstumsmodell. Wir können das nicht mit unserem Know-how jetzt stemmen. Wir müssen das also von auswärts holen. Dafür müssen wir denen, um wettbewerbsfähig zu sein, unsere Arbeiter zu wenig Lohn und schlechten Bedingungen zur Verfügung stellen. Die bauen das dort auf. Apple hat auch ein Interesse daran, dass diese ganze Wirtschaft da floriert. Und wenn da einzelne Unternehmen nur von Apple abhängig sind, komplett von Apple abhängig sind, dann kann das auch zu politischen Verwicklung führen. Wenn da Arbeitslosigkeiten und so auftreten, dann ist die Schreierei groß.
Genau, wir sehen, was in Deutschland passiert.
Also muss man sehen, dass die auch noch was anderes produzieren können. Also produzieren die dann auch die anderen Smartphones. Und die Frage wäre jetzt natürlich für mich, jetzt wo Apple anstrebt, sich aus China zu verabschieden Richtung Indien, ist das eine Diversifikation, die stattfindet, die aber am Ende noch bedeutet, dass China ein wichtiger Player für Apple bleibt? Oder ist das jetzt so, dass das eigentlich das gemachte Nest ist nun für Huawei und andere Hersteller, die jetzt einfach sagen, gut, dass Apple sich jetzt ganz draus zurückgezogen hat, da können wir jetzt vollkommen übernehmen?
Genau. Diese Infrastruktur in China ist da. Also wenn Apple sich da zurückzieht, ist das wie McDonald's in Russland. Dann wird das einfach jedem zugeteilt und dann macht der da Burgerbraten. Weil alles andere, was nötig ist, ist ja vor Ort. China hat sehr gute Kontrolle über die ganzen Zulieferprodukte, die man so braucht. Nachdem ich das Buch jetzt gelesen habe, würde ich einfach sagen, Apple ist in China. Apple kann nirgendwo anders hin. Es ist völlig undenkbar, das irgendwie in Indien aufzuziehen. Vielleicht in 20 Jahren oder was auch immer. Also das Einzige, was noch weiterführen würde, ist eine Art von Automatisierung. Aber selbst wenn wir jetzt sagen, okay, das ist dann wie, wir haben es in Arbeitsfrei gelesen, wo das mal so am Ernährungsthema durchgegangen wird. Selbst wenn du eine Mühle hast, in der pro Tag 10.000 Tonnen Weizen gemahlen wird und da arbeiten nur drei Ingenieure in den Dimensionen, reden wir immer noch über hunderttausende Menschen, die als letzte Ingenieure da die Aufsicht behalten müssen und so. Und das ist, also ich halte jede Bewegung von China weg für völlig ausgeschlossen jetzt. Dieses Buch sagt einfach, wir haben eine Sehgewohnheit zu sagen, der amerikanische Präsident entscheidet und da passiert da irgendwas. Die Realität ist, Apple ist es einfach so passiert, die haben sich in ein gemachtes Nest gesetzt. China hat das 15 Jahre lang den so aufgebaut. Das Schicksal ist geschrieben. Also wenn wir weiter iPhones haben wollen, müssen wir uns mit China verstehen.
Und Apple ist ja jetzt auch nicht das Unternehmen. Das sagt, wir wollen weg von der Hardware gehen. Ganz im Gegenteil. Also die sind eher, was Software oder KI anbelangt, eher vorsichtig oder manche sagen, die verschlafen was. Gut, kann man darüber diskutieren. Jedenfalls ist die Hardware-Seite das Geschäft von Apple.
Und es geht auch nicht ohne Hardware. Also, es ist, irgendwer muss einmal die Hardware herstellen.
Und diese Preise, die da abgerufen werden, 1000 Euro für ein iPhone, kannst du natürlich nur verlangen, wenn wirklich alles perfekt ist.
Genau, also darum geht es da ganz viel. Das erste iPhone hat 500 Dollar gekostet. Und es ist das einzige Produkt, das niemals im Preis sank. Sondern jedes Jahr wurde Neues vorgestellt, dann wurde gesagt, 50 Euro mehr. Und jetzt sind sie halt bei 1000, 1500, 2000 Euro. Und jetzt, klar, wir haben jetzt diese politische Dimension.
Es gibt ja noch ein anderes Produkt, Autos. Das ist nämlich auch so.
Ja, aber du brauchst, damit die Welt so funktioniert, wie sie funktioniert, brauchst du Smartphones.
Genau. Nein, ich meine, was die Preissteigerungen anbelangt. Bei Autos hast du auch nicht, du hast auch nicht, dass irgendwann der Dreier BMW oder der C-Klasse Mercedes billiger geworden ist. Die werden jedes Jahr oder alle zwei Jahre nochmal anderthalb 1000, 2000 Euro teurer.
Genau. Aber du hast ja auch nur eine Avantgarde-Gruppe, die die ab Werk kauft und dann rutschen die 20 Jahre lang so durch den Markt. Wo funktioniert das denn? Das ist ja bei iPhones auch nicht. iPhones sind einfach grundsätzlich teuer. Also auch auf dem Zweitmarkt und so ist einfach teuer. Also jetzt haben wir jedenfalls diese politische Diskussion und wie es ein ehemaliger Apple-Ingenieur ausdrückt. Wir haben ein ganzes Land ausgebildet und jetzt nutzt dieses Land es gegen uns. Also hier ist, She sitzt an einem so viel längeren Hebel, dadurch, dass Huawei diese Produktionsstätten auch nutzen kann, dass sie ihr eigenes Heaven OS oder wie das heißt, irgendwie so haben und weiß nicht. Also das ist einfach hier. Hier wurde ganz strategisch von China Geopolitik, Geoökonomie betrieben, also Politik mit geoeconomischen Mitteln.
Ja, und das, was jetzt gerade passiert, was in Indien, was aufgebaut wird, funktioniert ja auch nur, weil dann doch wieder die ganzen, nicht nur Rohstoffe, sondern auch die vorgefertigten Teile doch wieder aus China importiert werden. Und man geht jetzt nicht davon aus, dass Indien auf eine große Rivalität mit China hinaus will. Warum auch?
Ja, sag mal mal, du hast so ein iPhone 16, ein ganz Neues gekauft. Um das wieder aufzubauen, an anderer Stelle als Produktionsort China, geht, glaube ich, eine ganze Generation ins Land. Dann würden wir nur noch, wir hatten damals so iPhones und so, weißt du? Und das ist wirklich eine echte Gefahr.
Also das Beispiel von Donald Trump mit den 30 Puppen oder zwei Puppen gut schön. Aber wenn du jetzt den Amerikanern sagst, ja, so ein iPhone, braucht ihr das wirklich? Dann wird es schwierig. Vor allem auch, was nehmen sie dann für Produkte? Es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass sonst iPhones in den USA produziert werden.
Ja, also China ist im Grunde dasselbe so.
Ja.
Apple hatte halt nie eine eigene große inhaltliche, aber die haben sich halt auch komplett unterworfen. Die New York Times war auf iPhones nie lesbar in China. Da war einfach völlig klar, China sagt, es gibt hier keine iPhones, in denen AirDrop einfach so möglich ist, damit die sich ihre Flugblätter hin und her schicken können. Ich will nicht, dass jemand New York Times liest, Apple so, okay. Also einfach, das ist wirklich mal eine krasse Geschichte.
Krasse Geschichten liefert uns Andrea Jeske in der Zeit. Nämlich hat sie sich mit Ukrainern unterhalten, die nicht kämpfen wollen. Viele, vor allem junge Ukrainer, schreibt sie, wollen nicht kämpfen. Ihnen sind Gebietsverluste lieber als weiteres Sterben. Sie werfen ihrer Regierung Täuschung vor, Verletzung der Menschenrechte, Nationalismus. Sie hat mit diesen jungen Männern gesprochen, die natürlich anonym bleiben, also dann nur einen Namen zugeteilt bekommen jeweils. Und wir hören uns mal an, was die sagen. Da ist ein Student 25 Jahre alt, der sagt, die EU-Bürokraten haben immer nur gesagt, Vladimir Putin ist böse. Ihr werdet gewinnen. Sie haben das Blut der Ukraine benutzt. Sie wollten Zeit gewinnen, um sich selbst länger auf einen Krieg einstellen zu können. Deshalb haben sie uns immer erzählt, wir seien Helden. Aber gleichzeitig haben sie weiterhin Gas aus Russland gekauft und beträchtliche Einnahmen erzielt. Wir wurden von ihnen verarscht. Dieser Student hat durchaus Hoffnung, dass vielleicht etwas besser wird mit Donald Trump. Er arbeitete als Fotograf an der Front. Er sagte, ich fürchte mich vor dem Tod. Ich bin zu feige, um zu kämpfen. An der Front zu fotografieren war mein Mittelweg. Die Soldaten erzählten, dass sie wie Sklaven behandelt werden. Sie hatten wenig Pausen. Die Kommandeure schicken sie in aussichtslose Kämpfe. Dazu hatte ich keine Lust. Die Botschaft der Regierung, sagt dieser junge Mann, ist, wir schicken dich in den Krieg, damit wir dich schützen. Wenn sie uns wirklich schützen wollen, dann sollten sie die Grenzen öffnen, damit die Leute fliehen können. Also, er sagte auch, also das ist schon wirklich sehr prägnant hier formuliert, Silenz gedürstet nach Macht, deshalb hat er 10.000 in den Tod geschickt. Also, die sind auch nicht froh mehr mit dieser Führung. Er sagt, wenn es irgendwie eine Chance gibt, dass dieser Krieg jetzt endet und dann muss man den Russen was abtreten, dann ist das so. Er sagt besser, wir haben einen schlechten Frieden als einen guten Krieg. Er will nur Familie, Freunde, all das wiedersehen. Ivan, ein Musiker, sagt, ich glaube erst dann an etwas Gutes, wenn die Raketen nicht mehr auf unsere Städte fallen und wenn ich endlich aufhören kann, jeden Tag wie ein Irrsinniger durch die Nachrichten zu scollen. Was uns jetzt versprochen wird, stimmt nicht mit der Wirklichkeit überein. Die wichtigste Erkenntnis, die ich in diesem Krieg gewonnen habe, ist, dass all diese Konzepte von Land, Stolz, Ehre nur politischer Müll sind. Sie werden benutzt, um uns zu manipulieren. Ich werde mein Leben nicht opfern, um für eine Idee zu kämpfen. Also es spricht sehr für das, was du über junge Menschen eben gesagt hast, die jetzt hier endlich mal zu Gehör kommen. Zumindest ein paar kommen hier mal zu Wort, während man ja immer noch nicht sagt, wir lassen die alle fliehen. Da wird ja auch die Regierung nicht unter Druck gesetzt. Im Gegenteil haben wir Leute wie Roderich Kiesewetter, die jetzt über die Ukrainer, die hier sind, sagen, warum kämpfen die nicht, warum gehen die nicht dahin? Nikita25 sagt, wenn wir diesen Krieg verlieren, werden wir nach Schuldigen suchen, die Regierung oder jene, die nicht an der Front waren. Dieser Krieg wird nicht gerecht enden. Wir werden akzeptieren müssen, dass die Opfer umsonst waren. Und wir werden uns fragen müssen, wie wir der Gewalt im eigenen Land begegnen. Denn das ist es, was ich um mich herum sehe. Gewalt, Unterdrückung, Nationalismus. Also nicht eine klureiche europäische Zukunft. Wlodomir, 24, ein Informatiker, sagt, jetzt sagen viele, Trump verrate uns. Aber Trump ist derjenige, der etwas tut. Überhaupt ist es Amerika zu verdanken, dass wir noch am Leben sind. Der Übeltäter ist Putin und die EU-Politiker, die uns so viel versprachen, aber dann nicht lieferten. Er sagt, wer jetzt davon spricht, dass Putin auch bezahlen muss für seine Aggression oder wir nicht aufgeben dürfen, der versteht nicht, dass es Ukrainer sind, die für diese Forderungen sterben. Wir zahlen den Preis. Und er sagte auch, egal wie der Friedensdeal ausgeht, es wird zu einer politischen Krise kommen, weil die Leute noch immer denken, dass wir gewinnen und unser Territorium zurückerobern werden. Wenn sie endlich verstehen, dass das nicht stimmt, wird die Regierung die Unterstützung verlieren. Dann wird es Neuwahlen geben, aber erneut werden Leute an die Macht kommen, die die Menschen belügen. Also völlig desillusioniert dort. Und wir haben einen völlig anderen Diskurs. Ich bin fast gewiss zu sagen, man sollte eigentlich nur noch mit dem Mikro wirklich rausgehen auf die Straße und befragen. Also das ist ja ein längerer Text. Das waren jetzt nur kurze Auszüge aus diesen längeren Statements. Wenn man das liest, dann muss man sagen, das bringt mehr als die 1000. Analyse von irgendwie Carlo Massalla schreibt nochmal auf, wie das jetzt sein wird. Putin gewinnt nicht. Da gibt es einen Vorankommen. Da ist dies und das. Das sollten wir unbedingt jetzt tun. Und Strack Zimmermann möchte nochmal dies liefern. Und Paul Ronzheimer, gemahnt nochmal an den Taurus. Und der spricht ja mit so Leuten eigentlich. Diese Stimmen kommen ja sonst nicht vor. Und es hat ja jetzt auch ewig gedauert, bis man mal sowas findet. Also gut, dass die Zeit das mal gebracht hat. Aber das müsste natürlich in einem ganz anderen Ausmaße stattfinden.
Ja, also einen Text, den wir voller Überzeugung und so weiter anhängen. Hier auch. Also ich will jetzt mal, da ist bisher immer so ein bisschen, ich teile komplett das Problembewusstsein von Dario Amodei, von dem ich gleich berichte. Er hat, für Aufsehen, wir haben ja eh schon ein paar Text von ihm gelesen, also der Chef von Entropic, der Mitgründer von OpenAI, glaube ich, war, aber jetzt sind ja mehr OpenAI-Gründer bei Entropic als bei OpenAI. Und Claude Vier schlägt ja wirklich, also das verändert ja wirklich Leben mittlerweile. So, bei mir auch. Weshalb ich hier seine Warnung vor, die Hälfte aller Einstiegsjobs im Angestelltenbereich könnten vernichtet werden, was eben bedeutet, alle Jobs, die von Unternehmerseite aus ach, Kosten ersparen ist, brauchen wir da wirklich Personal. Und da würde ich sagen, okay, diese Jobs ist fast gelud, denn die Leute sagen sich ganz schön häufig, nee, brauchen wir kein Personal. Nur dadurch kommt ja das hereinwachsen, das reinsozialisieren in so berufliche Felder unter die Räder. Und Amodai wird im Text darauf verwiesen, 42, also so alt wie ich, entwickelt nun diese Technologie und ist gleichzeitig der Meinung, hier muss man ganz schön viel machen, weil es ist einfach nur entwickelt wird, reicht nicht. Hier braucht man sofort eine politische, gesellschaftliche Begleitung, um das Land zu schützen. Gesetzgeber allerdings verstehen es nicht oder glauben nicht daran, beklagt er, es klingt verrückt, aber die Leute glauben es einfach nicht. Und jetzt ist die Frage, wie kann man das lesen? Also selbst das, was sie hören, klingt verrückt oder dass sie es nicht verstehen wollen, ist verrückt, dass sie sich nicht dafür interessieren. Aber wir wissen alle, wie es ist. Ein amerikanischer Senator hat einfach ein Büro, der delegiert sein ganzes Leben schon Sachen. Ob da noch irgendwer irgendwas mit KI macht, das kriegt er gar nicht mit. Also der hat da gar keine Fühler dafür, der hat einfach nur Leute, die um ihn herumspringen. Und ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich ein echtes Problem. Man denkt immer, aber so blöd kann auch so ein Parlament gar nicht sein. Aber ja, diese ganze Bewörterung und Beförderung überhaupt führt dazu, dass sie wirklich so raumschriftmäßig in ihren eigenen Welten leben. Außerdem Gesprächspartner in diesem Text Steve Bannon. Wir kennen ihn, Präsidentschaftswahlkampf 2016. Er sagt jetzt, der Präsidentschaftswahlkampf 2028 wird unter einem völlig neuen Licht stehen. Er sagt, ich glaube, niemand berücksichtigt wie Verwaltungsmanagement und Tech-Jobs für Menschen unter 30, Einstiegsjobs, die in den Zwanzigern so wichtig sind, wegfallen werden. Nächster Gesprächspartner dann später ist noch Mark Zuckerberg. Amodai, wir haben ja seinen Text gelesen, verweist noch mal auf Krebsheilung. Wir haben jetzt einen großen Börsensprung gehabt von Biontel, weil sie da auch wieder eine große Zusammenarbeit mit amerikanischen Unternehmen haben und so. Was auch interessant ist in dieser Gemengelage, dass sie sich wieder einen amerikanischen Partner suchen, um die eigene Krebsforschung, die ja mit 20, 25 Studien hier sehr intensiv läuft, auf die Spur zu kriegen. Amodai beschreibt jetzt hier so ein Szenario. Wir könnten Krebs heilen, die Wirtschaft um 10 Prozent wachsen lassen, den Haushalt ausgleichen und trotzdem 20 Prozent weniger Menschen haben Jobs. Also es besteht einfach eine echte Gefahr, dass Menschen, die es in dem Falle halt wirklich einfach nicht sehen, weil sie sich auch für wenig interessieren, richtig aussortiert werden und sie nicht wissen, wie es ihnen geschieht. Er redet von einem Job-Massaker, noch während der Amtszeit von Trump. Also es geht alles wahnsinnig schnell. Diese Hersteller, diese Technologien und er beschreibt sich selbst, wir als Hersteller dieser Technologien haben die Pflicht und eine Verpflichtung, ehrlich zu sein. Es ist eine sehr seltsame Dynamik, in der wir sagen, ihr solltet euch Sorgen machen, wohin unsere Technologie führt, die wir also entwickeln. Wir glauben ihnen nicht, sagen dann Kritiker, sie machen ja nur Werbung, wo er sagt, ja, das ist ein berechtigter Skeptizismus, auch von Google und so kennen wir alle, wir können Bosenkurs und Voraussagen und so. Nur er fragt dann einfach, was ist, wenn wir Recht haben? Wenn wir diejenigen, die nicht nur das entwickeln, sondern auch die Potenziale abschätzen und es auch im Haus sehr viel verwenden und ich würde sagen, auch beispiellose Forensik und Franchion machen zu den eigenen Modellen, wenn die einfach Recht haben. Also dann haben wir es mit einem Blutbad in den Bürojobs zu tun. Diese KI-Unternehmen verbessern ihre Technik so kontinuierlich und so stetig, dass es relativ schnell geht. Und jetzt hat man das Dilemma, dass die US-Regierung natürlich befürchtet, gegen China den Boden zu verlieren, also sich lieber bedeckt hält. Und dadurch einfach so ein, kennt man ja vom Rüstungswettlauf, der hat dann irgendwann so ein Eigenleben, dass es dann einfach problematisch wird. Und wenn die Politik wegschaut, schauen auch die Amerikaner weg. Und dann fast über Nacht droht er. Erkennen Unternehmensführer die Einsparungspotenziale, die sich plötzlich ergeben. Das fand ich auch super interessant. Und jetzt habe ich einen Redaktionsschluss kurz beschrieben, wie Schirmacher einfach in so einem Gespräch nebenbei erfuhr. Ach so, der Online-Redaktion gibt so eine Software Chartbeat und die hängt ein Label an den Text. Und danach entscheidet die Redaktion, welchen wir spielen. Aber wir sind doch die Herausgeber. Wir machen die Blattlinie. Und dann ruft er das Haus zusammen und sagt, ne, wir machen die Blattlinie. Das war so das letzte Aufbührende eigentlich. Und wir wissen heute, zehn Jahre später, es ist quasi nur noch das Online-Geschäft. Also ich habe Carsten Knob letztens in so einem Podcast gehört, hier in Frankfurt. Die Stadtverwaltung macht so eigene Podcasts, wo er auch zu Gast war, weil es so einen Digitaltag gab und so. Und da hat er quasi über die Leser, die noch die gedruckte Zeitung lesen, so geredet, wie ich vor zehn Jahren in Redaktionsschluss darüber geschrieben habe. Also es war völlig abgeschrieben. Die gibt es noch. Das sind 80-Jährige. Das muss man jetzt aussitzen und man muss es noch ein bisschen organisieren, dass es am Ende ökonomisch tragfähig ist, noch die eine Zeitung für den letzten Leser da herzustellen und so. Also der ist mittlerweile angekommen, aber es hat halt viel zu lang gedauert. Dieses KI-Zeug geht ja alles viel, viel, viel, viel schneller. Naja, ich will es nicht zu lang machen. Mark Zuckerberg wird ja nochmal gefragt. Er war im Joe Rogan Podcast, wird hier aufgegriffen mit der Frage. Ja, also wir haben jetzt schon so und so viel. Eigentlich switchen wir jetzt voll um auf KI-Unternehmen. Das wird nicht mehr lange dauern. Und dann schreiben wir unseren Code einfach mit KI. Und Joe Rogan so, ja, wann denn? Ja, 2025. Sagt er einfach voll auf den Track und so. Sehr interessant ist, dass diese Jobs jetzt schon wegfallen. Also Microsoft entlässt gerade schon 6000 Mitarbeiter, 3% der Belegschaft. Walmart 1500 Stellen runter. CrowdStrike minus 5%. Also man kann jetzt schon sich den Markt anschauen und schon die Unternehmen, die besonders elektronisch, technisch, digital aufgestellt sind, die nutzen das halt als allererstes. Und es wird aber so dann den ganzen Markt ergreifen. Und in diesem Text taucht ein ganz interessantes Disclosure auf, denn sie schreiben bei Axios, also dem Unternehmen, das hier nachrichtmäßig diesen Text verbreitet, bitten wir unsere Manager zu erklären, warum KI eine bestimmte Aufgabe nicht übernehmen kann, bevor wir sie genehmigen. Klammer auf. Axios-Artikel werden immer von Menschen geschrieben und redigiert. Klammer zu. Ah ja. Da sieht man schon, der Trend ist klar, aber dass er schon so einen Hinweis macht darauf, dass einige Leser ja wissen, dass es bei euch auch so Doktrins gibt, sagt er schon einiges. Der Amo Dae wird aber nicht nur Schwarzmaler sein, sondern ein Topic führt selbst ein Economic Index, um so ein bisschen Gesellschaftsbeobachtung zu machen. Auf die Kongressabgeordneten ist er schlecht zu sprechen, da erwartet er wenig, aber er bittet, beginnen Sie mit der Debatte über politische Lösungen für eine Wirtschaft, die von übermenschlicher Intelligenz dominiert wird. Wir müssen den Wohlstand der großen KI-Unternehmen neu verteilen. Das wird Steuern für Menschen wie mich und vielleicht speziell für KI-Unternehmen mit sich bringen, aber muss sein, sagt er. Eine politische Idee, die Amoday uns gegenüber äußert, ist eine Tokensteuer. Jedes Mal, wenn jemand ein Modell nutzt und das KI-Unternehmen damit Geld verdient, gehen vielleicht drei Prozent dieser Einnahmen, Zitat, an den Staat und werden auf irgendeine Weise umverteilt.
Ja, also das ist ja hier unser Albert Winger, dem wir das letzte Mal in Grund und Boden geredet haben. Ja, das halte ich für völligen Unsinn. Also das wird doch niemals kommen. Das ist so diese Idee der Digitalsteuer oder der Finanztransaktionssteuer. Es gibt immer solche Modelle, bei denen man berechnet, wenn man da zwei Cent wegnimmt und das dann aufaddiert, dann kommt da eine bedeutliche Summe und aus der kann man das bedingungslose Grundeinkommen oder irgendwas anderes zahlen. Das halte ich für völlig falsch. Also das wird doch niemals, erst mal wird es niemals kommen. Zweitens ist das auch nicht machbar. Also wenn es jedes Mal eine solche Zahlung gäbe, zwar machen die ordentlich Profit mit unter diese Unternehmen, würde das aber niemals reichen, um da eine stattliche Summe draus zu generieren. Genauso ist es ja auch, wenn man es jetzt umlagern würde auf die Kunden, dass die immer das selbst bezahlen. Na ja, dann würde es auch nicht gehen. Dann würden sie halt weniger Anfragen bei der KI machen. Oder beim Finanztransaktionshandel ist das ja auch immer so. Man sagte dann, wenn man jede Transaktion mit so einem 0,9% besteuern würde, dann käme das und das bei rum. Na ja, diese ganz heftigen, schnellen Transaktionen werden ja nur deshalb gemacht, weil da keine Steuer ist. Das heißt, dann geht das zurück. Das heißt, was da jetzt vorgestanden wird, halte ich für unsinnig. Wenngleich ich glaube, dass er da für diese Bürojobs recht haben könnte. Also ich habe ja auch schon mit Leuten gesprochen, die sagen, sie wissen gar nicht so, wie sie jetzt mit den Neuen umgehen sollen, weil die Arbeiten, die sie vorher denen gegeben haben, protokollieren mal, machen dies und das, das macht heute die KI. Also müssen sie eigentlich gleich auf einem Niveau einsteigen, bei dem die Frage ist, wie viel braucht man von denen, die auf diesem Niveau da arbeiten? Also was da tatsächlich wegrationalisiert wird, das scheint mir erheblich zu sein. Ich kann das auch nicht einschätzen, wie viel Panikmacher dabei ist oder wie viele Investoren spreche. Ich sehe nur jetzt nicht, dass es in irgendeiner Weise in Deutschland eine Politik gibt, die sich damit näher beschäftigt.
Ne, unsere Bundesregierung ist ja gerade schlecht aufgestellt. Also ich würde zu dieser, du hast jetzt genannt, Tokensteuer, Robotersteuer, der ganze Kram. Ich finde, das wird auch alles zu feindlich, zu kompliziert. Also muss man dann jeden Token beobachten, der irgendwie mal durchgerechnet wird oder was auch immer, sehr absurd. Ich würde auch sagen, wir müssen zurück in so ein Abschöpfen der produktiven Erträge, also wirklich radikal bis 90 Prozent Gewinne besteuern.
Nur sind die Erträge gerade so hoch? Also sind die bei den KI-Firmen, wenn ich das doch richtig verstanden habe, ist das doch gerade so, dass die einen Umsatz machen, dass die etwas Gewinn machen, dann wieder Investorengelder einsammeln, um überhaupt wachsen zu können. Also jetzt in dem Moment, also ich könnte mir vorstellen, wie man vielleicht bei Apple Gewinne abschöpft und dann läuft der Betrieb weiterhin gut, nur hat dann Tim Cook und ein paar andere weniger. Aber bei diesen Axtus-Unternehmen, dass da jetzt da reingekrätscht wird und gesagt wird, wir besteuern jetzt bis 90 Prozent oder so, das wird doch niemals der Fall sein.
Ja, jetzt muss man sich genau die, sagen wir mal Lieferketten anschauen. Denn diese Unternehmen verdienen bisher kein Geld. GPT kostet 5 Milliarden im Jahr, Open AI. Das machen die Investoren aber mit, bei relativ kleinen Umsätzen, diese gigantischen Marktkapitalisierung schon mal so einzupreisen. Mit dem besonderen Phänomen, dass diese Unternehmen jetzt anfangen, von sich aus eine Steuer dran zu hängen. GPT hat damit angefangen, Claude hat nachgezogen und jetzt ist Gemini auch nachgezogen. Alle drei Unternehmen und das sind, ich sage jetzt mal so die westlichen, auf Augenhöhe operierenden Unternehmen, haben Modelle, die im Monat über 200 Euro kosten. Die werden also anfangen, Produktivität bei so einer Avantgarde, die für sich durchrechnet, 200 Euro im Monat ist ganz schön viel, aber es lohnt sich für mich, da wirkliche Geldströme zu organisieren. Das sind natürlich Testbewegungen. Wie viel das dann ergibt, weiß man nicht. Ich sehe ja auch in dem Podcast, den ich so höre, bei Twitter und so, machen die immer wieder so Jokes über dieses One-Man-Unicorn. Also, wann ist die erste Person geschafft, alleine nur mit KI-Unterstützung ein Unternehmen aufzubauen, das eine Milliarde wert erringt? Also, wenn der Preis 200 Euro im Monat ist für das Modell, dann kauft genau eine Person für 200 Euro bei GPT und macht aber eine Milliarde Umsatz oder eine Milliarde Marktkapitalisierung mit dem Unternehmen. Also, da müssen sowieso Geldströme neu organisiert werden. Aber ich will nur darauf hinweisen, dass es hier zumindest kalkulatorisch eine Einflugsschneise gibt, denn Amerika und Deutschland auch, alle westlichen Länder operieren gerade mit Vollbeschäftigung. Also, die Nicht-Vollbeschäftigung hat wirklich einen pathologischen Einschlag. Das kann man nicht einfach politisch jetzt organisieren. Ich finde, Morris Höfke macht das immer ein bisschen zu ambitioniert, dass er sagt, wir haben doch so viel, so viel und so. Aber ich würde sagen, wir gehen jetzt mal bei dem Status Quo, den wir jetzt haben, als die einzige Realität, die uns zur Verfügung steht, von Vollbeschäftigung aus. So, wenn wir hier jetzt eindeutig nachweisbar durch Unternehmen treffen, Entscheidungen und KI ersetzt echte Tätigkeiten und dann künftig in ein paar Monaten nachweislich Jobs, dann fällt damit auch ein Geldstrom raus aus der großen volkswirtschaftlichen Gesamtbetrachtung. Da fallen Lohnzahlung raus, Steuerzahlung raus und so weiter. Einfach nur, dass Personen ersetzt werden, aber die Aufgaben weiter im Unternehmen bleiben und auch erledigt werden. Aber halt von KI. Angefangen bei die Übersetzungsbüros, in Anwaltskanzleien, wie auch immer. Die Tätigkeit ist noch da, aber das Personal nicht mehr. So. Und ich finde, diese Kennziffer, die sollte man genau im Blick behalten und sich dann auch Gedanken machen, wie man die eins zu eins Menschen wurden durch Maschinen ersetzt. Wie man diesen Geldstrom politisch nachbereitet. Also da wirklich diese Art von Produktivität beobachtet, abgreift und so weiter. Denn es nützt uns gar nichts, wenn wir so allgemein jetzt eine Tendenz beobachten, die wirklich auf so einen One-Man-Unicorn hinausläuft, dass wir es erst dazu kommen lassen, zuerst eine große Podcastparty abzufeiern, weil jetzt jemand da ist, der es geschafft hat. Und danach erst, Mist, hätten wir doch mal vor fünf Jahren schon drüber nachgedacht. Es war doch klar, dass das die Entwicklung ist. Also hier brauchen wir so ein Szenario, das so ein bisschen prognostisch und so umgeht, um diese bislang an über Lohnzahlungen organisierten Geldzahlungen, dass wir die einfach im Blick behalten, auch wenn es nicht mehr an Personen geknüpfte Lohnzahlungen, Steuerzahlungen, Konsum und so weiter ist. Einfach um die Masse an, um diesen Geldbetrag geht es. Wo wir den dann abgreifen, wie wir das organisieren, das kann man ja dann immer noch. Aber wir brauchen erst mal so eine laufende Forensik, einfach am und in dem Falle sage ich wirklich mal Patienten. Aber mal sehen. Ich finde jedenfalls, das ist schon sehr aufrüttelnd, das so zu lesen.
In Le Monde Diplomatique schreibt Florentin Kasunet darüber, was Rumänen von Europa halten. Er trifft auf Marius Tudori. Er ist ein 49-jähriger Ingenieur. Und er ist Vize-Vorsitzende der Rechtsextremen Partei Allianz für die Vereinigung der Rumänen im Ort. Und er ist einer von sechs neu gewählten Abgeordneten der Partei im Regionalrat. Für ihn ist die Sache die, dass Europa natürlich den Rumänen eigentlich wenig bringt und die EU wird nicht positiv gesehen. Die Erfolgswelle der Ultra-Rechten hat neben anderen Faktoren mit dem Krieg in der Ukraine zu tun. Tudori sagt, Russland kann nicht besiegt werden. Rumänien sollte sich nicht in den Krieg einmischen. Wir haben ein Haushaltsdefizit. Uns werden Sparmaßnahmen abverlangt. Das Geld für den Krieg sollte lieber in die Entwicklung des Landes gehen. Es ist auch so, dass Solidarität mit den Geflüchteten, die 2022 noch da waren, kaum noch anzutreffen ist. Das liegt auch daran, dass sich die wirtschaftliche Situation ganz verschärft hat. Wir sprechen davon von einer wirklich hohen Inflation. Im Jahr 2022 war sie bei sogar 12 Prozent. Jetzt ist sie immer noch bei 5,8 Prozent im Jahr 2024. Er und auch 40 Prozent der Landsleute finden, dass Brüssel der nationalen Souveränität Fessel anlege, also eine antieuropäische Haltung. Die Souveränität wird geschmälert. Man findet stattdessen Staatschefs wie Donald Trump und Viktor Orban als vorbildlich. Er sagt weiter, dass überhaupt das Erbe von Schorcesko nicht richtig betrachtet wird. War doch eigentlich alles gar nicht schlecht mit Schorcesko. Und weiter heißt es dann auch, dass natürlich Rumänien unter den demografischen Veränderungen stark zu leiden hat. Und zwar in der Weise, dass die Rumänen das Land verlassen. Da heißt es, die letzte Volkszählung im Jahr 2021 zählt Rumänien, laut dieser Volkszählung zählt Rumänien nur noch 19 Millionen Einwohner, 4 Millionen weniger als 1992.
Das ist ganz Berlin, mehr als Berlin.
Ministerpräsident Marcel Chialocu bezeichnet die rumänische Diaspora mit 6,5 Millionen, vorwiegend in Moldau, Italien, Spanien und Deutschland, als die wichtigste Europas. Der Exodus-Zwang, Rumänien Arbeitskräfte vor allem aus Vietnam, Indien oder Nepal ins Land zu holen. Also die Rumänen hauen ab. Sie sagen, oh Gott, wo kriegen wir Leute her? Die kommen aus Nepal oder Vietnam. Dina Bumbak, 71 Jahre alt, heißt es hier, ist eine der Millionen Rumäninnen und Rumänen, die zum Arbeiten in den Westen gegangen sind. Zu Beginn der Pandemie kehrte sie aus Italien zurück, wo sie erst auf den Tomatenfeldern dann als private Altenpflegerin gearbeitet hatte, während Mann und Sohn in Rumänien blieben. Die häusliche Pflege von Demenzkranken war ein Gefängnisleben, sagt sie, im Haus der Arbeitgeber ohne Vertrag und soziale Absicherung. Vom italienischen Staat erhält sie keine Rente, in Rumänien lediglich 200 Euro. Die EU hat mir gar nichts gebracht. Also das ist die durch die EU verschuldete EU-Feindlichkeit. Also über die muss man auch reden, nicht einfach kommen die ganzen Rechtsextremen her. Rumänien hat durchaus von der EU profitiert. Mit dem Beitritt 2007 steht hier nochmal. Das Bruttoinlandsprodukt hat sich inflationsbereinigt nahezu verdreifacht. Das ist ja schon viel. Aber, da sind wir wieder bei deinem Thema, das Land hat es versäumt, einen auf Umverteilung der Gewinne gegründeten Wohlfahrtsstaat aufzubauen.
Das ist auch mein Thema.
Ist auch mein Thema. Für Millionen Rumänen sei die EU zum Synonym für Verarmung geworden.
Obwohl es nicht an Geld mangelt.
Verdreifacht. Verdreifacht.
Das Geld ist ja da.
Innerhalb von 15 Jahren.
Ich werde diesen Clip nochmal raussuchen, aber dass einfach 16 Billionen Euro genannt werden, um 2008 die Banken zu retten.
Ja.
Also hier ist einfach so unbequem dieses Wort ist, auch im Diskurs, weil immer alle schon so und so, aber Umverteilung ist einfach...
Ja, ja. Also hier kann man es nochmal ganz deutlich sehen.
Apropos. Arme Gesellschaften zählen zu den glücklichsten der Welt. Wir sind natürlich im letzten Text, den ich vorstelle, was bedeutet, hier darf man etwas spielen. Also es gibt einen Autor, Eric Galbraith. Der ist Professor in McGill. Das ist eine Universität in Kanada. Ich kannte sie nicht. Ich habe die GPTs gefragt oder Klotser, was auch immer. Ist das eine renommierte Uni? Ja, top renommiert. Also eine superrenommierte Uni. Denn ich bin etwas gestolpert über den Zuschnitt dieser Professur. Es geht nämlich um so Biogeochemie. Da sieht man mal, Biogeochemie. Das ist ja genau. Und theoretische Ökologie, wo wir sonst ja immer das Thema drückt, praktisch. Und Soziologie. Er führt ein Institut, das Integrated Earth System Dynamics Laboratory heißt. Er ist also jemand, der Human- und Erdsystemforschung im größten Sinne, um nicht nur Naturwissenschaft zu sagen, verbindet. Und Erdforschung gemacht. Und zwar ausführliche Interviews mit 2.966 Befragten in 19 indigenen Gemeinschaften, die alle eine Eigenschaft hatten, nämlich weniger als 1000 Dollar pro Jahr zur Verfügung. Ich lese jetzt nur aus diesem Spektrum der Wissenschaftentext. Es gibt aber die Originalquelle mit ihrer DOIS oder wie sie heißt nochmal, den verlinke ich auch. Die habe ich aber nicht reingeschaut. Also es gibt und es geht um eine Skala von 0 bis 10. Alles in allem, wie zufrieden sind sie mit ihrem Leben und dann so einer großen Versuchsanordnung, Operationalisierung, um auszuschließen, dass die einfach nur sagen, wie sind sie mit ihren finanziellen Möglichkeiten zufrieden und so weiter und so fort, sondern da so ein bisschen ganz eingemachter zu gehen. Weshalb man sich auch ein bisschen von, man kommt mit der Perspektive, wie viel Dollar pro Tag, pro Jahr sind so und so weiter, aber danach hat man sich so angeschaut, womit leben die materielle Gegenstände, wie ist das Haus, die Wohnung, wie auch immer eingerichtet. Und hat dann daran so festgemacht, okay, das sind Menschen, die sind materiell ärmer als wir. Ungefähr diese 1000 Dollar im Jahr ist so der Grenzwert. Und dann hat man über Zufriedenheit gesprochen und rausgefunden, die sind alle zufriedener als die Kontrollgruppen aus den reichen Ländern.
Okay.
So, und es ging dann einfach um die Frage, warum eigentlich? Also, wie ist denn das zu verstehen? Es gibt dieses Easterling Paradox. Ich kannte den Namen nicht, aber das Prinzip ist natürlich bekannt. Langfristige Wohlstandsanstieg führt nicht automatisch zu steigender Lebenszufriedenheit. Wir haben eher das Problem, mit dass dann Verlustängste und so weiter kommen. Also, Reckwitz, da ja auch ein bisschen drüber geschrieben. Ist natürlich eine alte Erkenntnis, aber trotzdem super relevant. Und man hat dann die Cantril-Leiter nochmal mit eingepreist, unterschiedliche Messmethoden, den Geldglücksbias wieder ausgerechnet. Also, dass jemand nicht nur über ja, ich habe genug Geld, was machst du damit? Ja, das ist so zweitrangig, aber doch eigentlich primär für deine Lebenszufriedenheit, wie auch immer. Also, indigene Gemeinschaften kommen flächendeckend über acht von zehn Punkten in der Selbstauskunft, ob es ihnen eigentlich gut geht. Und die wohlhabenden Länder, also da ist acht schon Ausreißer. Da muss man schon ein paar Leute fragen, bis man jemanden, der findet so acht von zehn. Hat natürlich sehr viel mit wie sehe ich mich im Verhältnis zu anderen in meiner unmittelbaren Lebenswelt zu tun. Und wir haben eine verschwindend geringe Geld-Glücks-Korrelation. Und es geht ja um Gebiete in Südamerika, Afrika, Südasien und überhaupt fünf Kontinente. Äußerst abgelegene Regionen, die immer, also sie scheinen so ein Muster zu geben, sollte uns zu denken geben. Nochmal über materielle Grundlagen neu nachzudenken. Geld als Glücksfaktor ist nicht. Soziale Beziehung, Naturverbundenheit, Gleichheit. Ich muss da natürlich wieder an unsere Befreiungstheologen denken, die das säkulare Aufladen von Nationalismus, Kapitalismus und so weiter da betont haben. Scheint was dran zu sein. Es liegt alles auf einer Diskursdimension, sag ich mal. Auch grundsätzliche Veränderungen. Dieses Narrativ, naja, dann müssen wir einfach Wachstum versprechen. Und das führt dann zu Glück. Nein, auch das nicht. Weder ist es der Status quo noch eine erhoffte Veränderung. Ja, in der Hoffnung liegt es schon, aber nicht dann in der konkreterlebten Änderung. Sehen wir ja an Elon Musk, 400 Milliarden steht vor der Presse und hat ein angeschlagenes Auge und ist quasi ein gebrochener Mann. Also das, ja, ich finde das alles, das ist in dem Falle wirklich sehr ernst zu nehmende Forschung. Also hier ist man wirklich reingegangen. Das ist so Steffen-Mau-artig. Hier wurde Budget verbrannt und so. Für eine irgendwie naheliegende intuitive, aber eben finde ich sehr ernst zu nehmende Erkenntnis einfach. Die Nähe zu anderen Menschen und die Aufgabenverteilung, die sich aus dieser Nähe ergibt, ist grundlegend für den Zufriedenheitswert, der sich später herausstellt. In der Ansicht, diesen neuen gottlosen Katholizismus, den kann man ja wirklich mal neu begründen. Da liegt was drin.
Zum Schluss noch ganz kurz eine Musikempfehlung. Diesmal Jazz. Und zwar empfehle ich die neue CD vom Julia Hülsmann Quartett. Under the Surface heißt, die CD ist bei ECM erschienen. Klavier, Tenor-Saxophon, Kontrabass, Schlagwerk und Hilde Gunn-Eusset ist dabei. Also es ist dann eine Person mehr. Also eigentlich ein Quintett diesmal. Und Hilde Gunn-Eusset spielt Trompete, aber auch Ziegenhorn. Das ist jetzt ein Instrument, das man sonst nicht im Jazz findet. Aber es ist wirklich spektakulär, wie dieses Instrument klingt, wie lyrisch und zugleich auch ein bisschen zerbrechlich dieser Ton ist. Vor allem in dem Stück Bubbles, das ist das vierte Stück auf der CD, kommt das unglaublich schön heraus. Nun ist es so, dass Hilde Gunn-Eusset eine sehr bekannte Trompeterin ist und auch ist sie da eine Meisterin beim Ziegenhorn. Julia Hülsmann aus Deutschland ist eine weltweit gefeierte Jazz-Musikerin. Die eine wirklich sehr tolle CD hier vorlegt mit ihrem Quartett, weil wir es hier mit einem allenfalls reichen Stil zu tun haben. Wir haben ja oftmals so eine Grundlage, die auf dem Klavier geschaffen wird. Oftmals ist es so, dass wir da erst so eine Melodiefolge hören. Unter dieser Melodiefolge ist etwas über dieser Melodiefolge ist, wir haben eine Rhythmik, die nicht intuitiv da ist, sondern die auch etwas dagegen arbeitet. Also das funktioniert auf so verschiedenen Ebenen, diese Musik, ohne dass das jetzt so klingen soll. Es ist wahnsinnig anstrengend, das zu hören, aber man muss die Musik, um ihr gerecht zu werden, doch mit einer hohen Aufmerksamkeit folgen. Und ich bin sehr begeistert davon, mag vor allem da die Musik, wo sie besonders filigran wird, ohne jetzt ihre Dynamik einzubüßen. Also es gibt immer wieder so lyrische Passagen, aber es ist auch so ein fast drängender Rhythmus darunter oder ein Rhythmus, der nochmal verunsichert in eine andere Richtung führt. Dass ich wirklich sehr begeistert bin von dieser Musik, will gar nicht mehr dazu sagen, außer dass ich empfehle, das mal zu hören. Auch wenn man sonst keine Jazzmusik mag, glaube ich, oder sie sonst nicht hört, kann man, glaube ich, sehr viel damit anfangen. Man wird nämlich dann erkennen, wie vielschichtig Jazz ist, was auch für unterschiedliche Stimmungen evoziert werden können. Und es ist auch ein, wenn man so möchte, altmodisches Album in der Weise, dass man eine Musik hat, die so von Hand gemacht ist. Und wo man auch so merkt, hier werden Dinge jetzt ausprobiert. Man versucht wirklich, mit der Form nochmal zu arbeiten. Nicht einfach, um eine Formspielerei zu machen, sondern auch um wirklich eine Art in der Welt sein zu spüren mit dieser Musik. Und es ist ja das, was bei Jazz auch so gut funktioniert, da wo es dann so unmittelbar wird. Bei allem, was das auch an Verkopften aufzubieten hat. Also ich bin sehr begeistert davon Under the Surface vom Julia Hülsman Quartett. Und damit verabschieden wir uns den Monat und hören uns dann am Ende bzw. live in Frankfurt. Sehen wir uns und dann einen Tag später gibt es dann auch dies als Podcast zu hören. So ist es.
Haut rein.